So will you please call the roll to establish a quorum?
Member Burr.
President Darling-Hammond.
Here.
Member Patel.
Member Glover-Woods.
Here.
Member McQuillan.
Member Navo.
Here.
Member Patil-Brownson.
Member Rodriguez.
Here.
Member Williams.
Member Strauss.
Here.
Member Son.
All right, I hereby call the November 2020 meeting of the State Board of Education to
order at 8.33 a.m.
And I'd like to commence by saluting the flag.
Member I.D. Rodriguez, will you please lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance?
Absolutely.
Please stand.
And ready, begin.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America and to the Republic for
which it stands, one nation under God, indivisible, for liberty and justice for all.
Very poignant words in this week of voting.
This is a big week for civic engagement, and I'm sure we'll have a lot of opportunities
to reflect on that.
Thank you.
I'm going to start with announcements.
I'm delighted to announce that Rigel Massaro has joined the SBE team last week.
She had worked as a senior legislative counsel of public advocates since 2013.
Prior to that, she was a staff attorney for Advocates for Children of New York, Inc.,
a law clerk for the Arizona Court of Appeals, a law clerk at Consumers Union, and an educator
in the Littleton Elementary School District in Cashin, Arizona.
And please join me in welcoming Rigel.
Are we able to put Rigel on the screen?
Maybe not.
We'll have to probably see her a little bit later.
She's going to be a great addition.
And many of us know her from her work in Sacramento on issues that we care about, so she'll be
picking right up.
There are four items on the agenda that have agenda.
Item one, the SBE Screening Committee recommendations for appointments to the Advisory Commission
on Charter Schools, the Advisory Commission on Special Education, the California Practitioners
Advisory Group, and the Instructional Quality Commission.
Item two is the SBE Screening Committee recommendations for three finalists for the 2021-22 Student
Board Member.
Item three, the 2020 Student Advisory Board on Education Report.
Item four, Approval of the Criteria to Define Verified Data and the List of Valid and Reliable
Assessments and Measures of Post-Secondary Outcomes as Required by California Education
Code Section 47607.2.
On consent calendars, the proposed waiver consent items are W01 through W06 and W08.
The proposed regular consent items are items six through eight and item 11.
We will take up both the waiver consent items and the regular consent items later this afternoon.
In terms of public input, members of the public who are wishing to call in for public comment
should view the live stream of the meeting to know what time public comment will occur
for each item.
Public comment may be provided by dialing the phone number, entering a participant access
code, and then following each of the operator's prompts.
Upon dialing in, callers will be added to a caller queue.
The operator will notify callers when it is their turn to provide public comment.
We will also ask callers to please turn down the speaker volume of their computers if they
are following the live webcast to avoid an echoing effect.
Public comment will be limited to one minute for each speaker.
Item 12 is the general public comment item during which members of the public may provide
comment on matters that are not specifically listed on the Board agenda.
Board members, please mute your microphones when you're not speaking and keep your cameras
on at all times except during scheduled breaks to ensure that we maintain a quorum throughout
today's virtual meeting.
And for each item on the agenda, there will be an opportunity for you Board members to
raise your hands using the Zoom participant window.
If you would like to ask a question or make a comment, and Brooks will help me keep track
of that.
So, we're going to start with agenda item one.
First, I'm going to welcome Patricia Rucker, who has just arrived, welcome Pat.
So our State Board priorities item, the State Superintendent would be giving his report
to the Board of Regents and the Board of Regents and the Board of Regents and the Board of
Regents.
I'm back.
Hopefully, there we go.
Can you see me?
Give me a thumbs up.
All right.
Thanks.
Thank you.
I'm going to turn it over to Patricia.
that as well in California.
As we've seen this week, 160 million Americans determinedly voted across this country more
than ever before in our history.
It is a time for civic engagement around these issues and around other issues as well to
guide the course of our country and our state and to ensure that we can live together and
appreciate each other safely and productively at our November meeting last with ravaged
communities in Butte County and in Ventura County.
I'm hoping my internet will hold.
Last November, we honored students and teachers for schools for climate action, a Sonoma County
organization formed after the pubs fire in 2017 to enable students to advocate for climate
solutions.
We thank them for their advocacy, which has resulted in more than 100 educational organizations
adopting climate change resolutions.
At that time, we noted that six of the 10 most destructive fires in California's history
had occurred since October 2017.
A year later, we have experienced the worst wildfire season in our state history.
Over 9,000 fires burned 4.3 million acres of our state this year.
A year ago, I noted that California, that climate change is not only an existential threat,
it's a threat to our ability to provide a safe and healthy learning environment for students.
And it is something that we can address.
Recently, I was asked to join the National K-12 Action Climate Action Commission.
It's an initiative the Aspen Institute has an impressive list of partners, the National
Education Association, the American Federation of Teachers, the PTA, the Education Trust,
the Sierra Club, and many others.
And that commission issued a report examining how states and districts can adopt policies
to help America's 98,000 public schools reduce energy, reduce bus emissions, and reduce food
waste.
I hadn't realized, and probably many others don't know, that schools are among the largest
energy consumers among public sector buildings.
Schools serve over 7 billion meals annually with related food waste.
Schools use about 480,000 school buses for transportation, the largest mass transit fleet
in the country.
And the report highlighted local districts that have policies to support sustainable
practices that can be replicated statewide.
Many California districts were highlighted.
Los Angeles Unified, the nation's second largest district, made progress on its commitment
to reach 100% clean renewable energy by 2040.
The Twin Rivers District in Sacramento was called out as having the largest electric
school bus fleet in the entire nation.
Twin Rivers began converting to electric buses in 2017 using funds from California's
cap and trade program.
The buses have reduced the district's fuel cost by 80%.
Oakland Unified was highlighted for its goal of establishing a garden at every school site
and for its work in food waste reduction.
The district has provided 50% of its waste from reaching a landfill.
These districts are showing that California can confront huge challenges and work to surmount
them.
And we are not shying away from the global challenges.
On climate change, Governor Newsom and the California volunteers announced the creation
of the California Climate Action Corps this summer.
It's just getting started.
But teens and teachers can visit www.climateactioncorps.ca.gov to learn about what is envisioned.
There will be opportunities for high school and college students to spend summers and
extracurricular time engaged in climate volunteering and service activities.
These activities will help students earn the new seal of civic engagement, a recognition
that we want to encourage for all of our students as they and we commit to commuting to supporting
work in our communities.
They can also apply to become Climate Action Corps fellows and those applications are currently
being accepted.
More than 250 fellowships will be awarded.
The state will help to pay for college for these fellows.
They'll be deployed for seven months to a year in frontline communities with various
state and local government committees, nonprofit organizations, universities and colleges developing
and implementing climate action projects.
For our young people, this is part of what they will be living through and with all their
lives and enabling them and us to take more action to preserve and protect the quality
of Californian of their lives is essential.
Of course, it's only one of the many challenges we're facing and I want to talk just a little
bit more about the progress being made in reopening schools, another challenge that
we are meeting and learning to surmount.
Although more than 90% of California students started school and online learning, as the
end of October, there were about three quarters of a million students attending in-person
classes in 21 counties, mostly rural but also suburban orange and San Diego counties.
20 counties have a mix of districts that are open to varying extents in-person and hybrid
learning.
They serve about 1.7 million students and include a mix of urban and semi-urban counties
like Fresno, Sacramento, Ventura, Santa Barbara.
And then in 17 counties where all or most districts are serving students for distance
learning only, there are plans underway for many schools to reopen in January.
These counties serve 3.6 million students and they include L.A., Bay Area, Inland Empire,
Riverside, San Bernardino.
Many creative strategies to finding space and strategies for serving students are being
developed.
For example, partnering with community colleges to use their classrooms while they are in
online learning to create social distancing for high school students.
So there are lots of ways that people are solving the many problems associated with
physical opening of schools.
Many of these districts have brought back students in small groups, often students with
disabilities, English learners, those with other needs.
A number of districts, sometimes working with community partners, have also created learning
hubs to offer spaces for digital learning with adult assistance, with meals, with a
variety of supports for children who are not able to engage in distance learning from home.
We are learning how to open schools safely with appropriate physical distancing, face
coverings, attention to hygiene, attention to creating small cohorts of teachers and
students who stay together throughout the day.
Our Department of Public Health notes that there have been almost no cases of transmission
associated with these school openings thus far.
In addition to the guidance provided by the California Department of Public Health, both
the Department of Education and the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence have
developed guides and toolkits for schools to use when planning how to return to campus.
The state is supporting these efforts by providing two months' worth of free personal protective
equipment to schools at no cost and helping schools procure PPE in bulk and at discounted
rates.
As we know, the Governor's budget this past year, drawing in part on the federal CARES
Act funds, has provided schools with over $5 billion to be spent on closing the digital
divide, sanitation supplies, PPE testing, and then tutoring and other services to address
learning loss.
The state is supporting reopening efforts with new testing partnerships, stepping up
contact tracing efforts, helping with the supply chain, and issuing the guidance.
The state's new contract with Perkin-Elmer, for example, will double the state's COVID
testing capacity and drive down costs and will be made available to many school districts.
We all know that reopening schools is a huge challenge, but we are learning to do it safely.
It is especially important that we get our youngest learners back to school in person
so that they don't use the precious in-person learning needed to learn the fundamental skills
on which they will build the rest of their school careers.
And most countries that have returned to school, as some districts are doing, did so by using
their available space to bring the youngest learners back full-time and then gradually
phasing in older learners as solutions to scheduling and space were worked out.
Because these young students are the most necessary and the safest to bring back in
person, California has offered an elementary school waiver to all districts across the
state, regardless of what tier they're in, and worked out, of course, with the local
public health department to ensure safe procedures.
And I just want to note that California's educators have worked to creatively address
so many challenges this year.
I am optimistic that we'll continue to do so as we meet the many ongoing issues we face
and that we will not just restart schools but reinvent them to be more socially and
emotionally supportive of all students, more relationship-centered, more connected to families,
more focused on enabling civic engagement as well as academic competencies.
And I think that is really part of what we're going to see on the state board's agenda over
the coming year.
I think many of us have really understood that we don't want to return to the status
quo with many of the inequities that have plagued the system of education in every state
for many years.
But we want to return to a new normal, to a new new deal in which the work that we've
been engaged in over the last decade really does come into fruition with the opportunity
to think differently about how we organize schools, about how we support our educators,
and about how we support our students.
And with that, I'm going to turn it over to the SPE screening committee's recommendations
for ACCS, for ACSC, for CPAC, and for IQC.
We're going to first take up the screening committee's recommendations for those appointments.
The public comment slide should be put up now.
I'm hoping that that will appear.
We're going to open the phone line for public comment.
Hopefully the public comment slide will appear so that will be easy to do and the public
members will have the instructions.
I will read them but I hope you'll also see them because this is a lot to take in auditorily.
Members of the public wishing to provide comment on this item may do so by calling 712-432-0075
and entering access code 651-905.
There we go, there's the public comment slide.
And while we're waiting for any members of the public to call in, I want to ask Vice
President Strauss, who chaired this year's process, to share the recommendations from
the screening committee regarding appointments to the Advisory Commission on Tourist Schools,
the Advisory Commission on Special Education, the California Practitioners Advisory Group,
and the Instructional Quality Commission.
Well, good morning.
I was joined this year by members Ting Sung and members Cynthia Glover Woods, who worked
really, really hard through this process and we're a great team together.
For each of our Advisory Commissions, a state board staff member and a CDE staff member
joined us as well.
So for the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools, we have 15 applications.
I'll just say we have an additional opening we'll be posting next week and we're going
to be interviewing for Charter School Administration.
For the Advisory Commission on Special Ed, we have 27 applications.
For the California Practitioners Advisory Group, we had nine.
And for the Instructional Quality Commission students, we had nine.
So it is my pleasure to give the state board the recommendations.
We're recommending reappointment for a two-year position to Wesley for the Advisory Commission
on Charter Schools for Wesley Siever, who's currently a superintendent in Kingsburg Elementary
Charter School District, who represents district superintendents, and Erica Jones, a teacher
in Los Angeles Unified, representing teachers.
That's for the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools.
These are reappointments for two years.
We're also recommending an appointment for two years for Andrea Fasel.
She's a teacher at Downtown College Prep representing teachers.
And we're recommending that for a two-year term.
There's an addendum that was just posted on this.
For the Advisory Commission on Special Education, we're recommending that the following individuals
be appointed.
Stacey Adler, Superintendent of Mono County, Office of Education, representing three categories,
a parent and student with disability, state and local official or administrator, and also
representative of charter schools.
Marie Alvarado-Gil, Regional Director of Rocketship Education, she's a parent of a disability,
and represents charter schools.
And Sarah Notch, who's the Executive Director, Special Education and Instruction for San Mateo
County Office of Education, parent of a student with a disability, and a state or local official
or administrator.
For the Advisory Commission recommendation to the California Practitioners Advisory Group,
we're recommending three reappointments for a two-year term.
Jesse Levin, an educational researcher working for the American Institute for Research.
Ed Manasala, the Superintendent of El Dorado County, representing superintendents or other
administrators.
And Nancy Portillo, Chief of Staff for the Archdiocese of Los Angeles, representing private
school children.
For the appointment to the California Practitioner Advisory Group, we're recommending a three-year
term for Mia Cooper.
She's representing the specialized instructional support personnel.
She works in San Bernardino City Unified School District.
For the Instructional Quality Commission, we are recommending, so you might know that
as a result of students appearing in front of the school state board a couple of years
ago and then going to the legislature, we have the authority to appoint one of our IQC
members as a student instead of an adult.
And so this year actually is the first year a student is serving during their senior year
on the Instructional Quality Commission.
So this appointment will be for next year's, for senior, she's a junior now and she'll
be serving in her senior year.
This is Juliana Garcia, she's a junior at John F. Kennedy Middle College High School
in Coronerco Unified School District, and she will be appointed for the IQC.
Those are the recommendations of these four screen committees.
And I would just ask, I would just say we interviewed amazing candidates with incredible
experience and willingness to serve the state of California and support our students.
It was a pleasure to meet them, and we did it on Zoom this year, so we actually got to
see them rather than just talk on the telephone, and it was a really thoughtful, really engaging
conversation.
I just would ask if Member Glover-Woods or Member Sung wanted to make any comments about
the screening process, and then I would move approval of these recommendations.
Thank you.
Good morning, and thank you, Member Strauss.
I will just echo what you said as far as the pleasure it was to serve on the screening
committee and meet such phenomenal people.
Also, again, just to underscore the phenomenal nature of the students that we had opportunity
to meet during the interviewing process.
Our future is indeed bright and, again, quite excited to see the young people that are coming
through.
Awesome.
Yeah, and I would also echo all of the comments made by my colleagues.
It was the first time that I served on this screening committee, and I was, too, just
amazed by the educators and the parents who applied for the positions, and it was really
difficult through the paper screening as well as through the interviews.
So really appreciated the opportunity to be able to talk and meet with all these people.
And I would also echo Member Glover-Woods' comments about the students.
Oh, so inspiring.
Just made our day.
Yeah, so I think that Governor's going to have a hard time making a selection, and I'm
glad that we're going to honor all of those finalists.
We're open for public comment, and then we'll come back for any board discussion on this
item before we take a motion.
Is there any public comment?
Yes, we have one person in the queue.
Caller, welcome to the State Board of Education meeting.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
My name is Lindsay Noffelt.
I'm a parent with a second grader at Berkeley Unified School District.
I'm calling to express my concerns about the Statewide Literacy Plan.
As you continue to review...
Caller, pardon me.
This is only for item two.
We would ask you to...
Or I'm very sorry.
For item one, we would ask you to call back during public...
General public comment later this afternoon.
Thank you.
Is there any other public comment on this item?
No, there are no other callers at this time.
All right.
We're now open for board discussion.
Maybe we can take the screen down, the screen share down, so it's easier to see all the
board members.
Is there any board discussion?
Feel free to raise your hand in the participant list, or I can watch for you to raise it in
person as well.
Any discussion from the board?
I am seeing none.
So at this point, I think we're ready for a motion.
So I move approval of the recommendations for the screening committee for ACCS, ACSE,
CPEG, and IQC student.
All right.
Thank you.
And do I have a second?
I'll second.
Thank you very much.
Any further board discussion?
All right.
We're going to ask you to raise your hand in the participant panel of Zoom.
Let's see if we can all do this.
This is a performance task.
You've got to go to the participant.
I'm sorry.
I think we need to call the roll, which I can do.
Okay.
Yeah.
The script said raising hands, and that was a new one.
Okay.
Hold the roll call.
Brooks, please call the roll.
Yes.
I will note that some people successfully accomplished the performance task that I want
to recognize.
Duly noted.
And now on the public record.
Member Burr.
Aye.
President Darling-Hammond.
Member Fatah.
Aye.
Member Glover-Woods.
Member McQuillan.
Yes.
Member Navo.
Aye.
Member Patil-Brownson.
Yes.
Member Rodriguez.
Aye.
Member Rucker.
Yes.
Member Strauss.
Member Son.
Aye.
It's unanimous.
All right.
Thank you very much.
We'll move on to the draft preliminary report of actions and minutes for the September 10th,
2020 board meeting while we're waiting for any members of the public to call in.
And maybe we should put that public comment.
And call in slide up again.
Do I have a motion from a board member to approve the September 10th, 2020 state board
of education draft preliminary report of action meeting minutes?
I will move approval.
Thank you very much.
Do I have a second?
I second.
Thank you very much.
Are there any public comments?
No, we do not have any public comments.
All right.
Any further discussion?
Brooks, will you please call the roll for the roll call vote?
Member Burr.
Aye.
President Darling-Hammond.
President Fatah.
Member Fatah.
Aye.
I elevated you.
He will be president of something.
We're all about student voice.
Of something.
Member Glover Woods.
Aye.
Member McQuillan.
Yes.
Member Navo.
Aye.
Member Patil Brownson.
Yes.
Member Rodriguez.
Member Rucker.
Yes.
Vice President Strauss.
Member Sun.
Aye.
Synonymous.
All right.
And I'm not yet seeing our state superintendent, so we're going to go ahead and launch into the
liaison reports.
I want to invite you to report out on any liaison activities that were not related to items in our
November agenda.
We'll begin by calling on board members in reverse alphabetic order based on last name,
and I'm going to start with Lisa.
Hi.
So the California Workforce Pathways Advisory Committee is meeting in a couple weeks on the
20th.
We'll be getting an update on the CTIG grant and the K-12 Workforce Grant.
The applications have come, the, sorry, the selections have been made, and so we'll get
an update on that.
And just an update on the work that we're doing with the statewide
the Career Technical Education Plan, and that's really all I have to report.
All right.
Vice President Strauss.
Thanks.
On September 16th, the Instructional Quality Commission met, and then the State Literacy
Grant, they reviewed it, and it went out for public comment.
Also, the Ethnic Studies Model Curriculum, the public comment period has now ended.
And we'll be meeting on the 18th and 19th and going over the next round of edits, and
I'll be joined by member Glover Woods and member Rucker.
On September 17th, the Science Collaboration Committee met.
That's the effort to continue to implement next generation science standards throughout
the state.
They're doing a lot of work to help teachers with distance learning and providing really
wonderful opportunities for assessments and benchmarks and lots of promising practices.
It's a great support network.
I think a lot of our content is doing that, and I just really am honored to be part of
it and to watch how they connected the work to equity and social justice.
On the 21st of October, the Advisory Commission on Special Education met, and they did an
update on the State Performance Plan and looked at the system of support and how we're
supporting school district, particularly for students with special needs.
I just have to say it was just wonderful to listen to the report.
If you have some time to look at that commission meeting and to see the kind of work we're
doing with distance learning to support special needs students, particularly the support of
inclusive practices presentation that we heard was really heartwarming to see the wonderful
practices during the pandemic to address distance learning and the barriers to inclusion.
We also got a report from the state special schools and how they're working on instruction
during COVID-19, and I think we know everybody's working so hard, but these were highlights,
particularly serving our students with the challenging learning situations and learning
needs.
We had a report on the California Special Education Funding Report.
It's a study that was done by WestEd and talking about the challenges in special ed funding,
in special ed funding, particularly around what is equal practice, how do we align our funding
systems, and what is the role of selfless.
I think we'll be hearing a lot more about this, but it was really quite important to
listen to.
Again, it's on the advisory customer special ed website from that meeting.
I think you'd be interested in hearing more about that.
And then we have a new special ed director, Heather Calamese, coming to us from Illinois,
and she did an update on the activities of the division.
And then we had to wish and thank Summer Harding and Sarah Walker, who served for eight years on
the commission.
They had two terms.
They both served on the commission and were really wonderful members as well.
California is part of the National Association of State School Boards of Education,
State Boards of Education, and they had a western regional meeting on Friday, October
23rd.
So I was really interested to know that our western area includes islands, including
American Samoa, Guam, the Northern Mariana Islands.
And so it was really interesting to see.
It was all done, obviously, remotely.
But to hear what other states are doing, I would say they did highlight our work in advancing
social emotional learning in California for the western area, and also discussed what
different states are looking at during COVID, particularly around student support,
accountability, and policy.
So very interesting.
First time I've been part of NASP, and I think we will look forward to continuing collaboration
with them as well.
The new president of NASP comes from Utah, State Board of Education, and is part of the
western group.
And then the California State University has two advisory boards.
One that, remember, Darlene Hamm and I served on a real meeting next week on quantitative
reasoning, looking at fourth year of math preparation in high school for students so
they're ready for college.
But they are opening another one, a new initiative starting on Tuesday, calling the center to
close the opportunity gap.
And I think this really addresses a lot of what we've been talking about in California,
about getting our students ready.
And so they're looking at evidence-based strategies to eliminate opportunity gaps.
So they'll be looking at joint initiatives to increase academic success.
That center opens next week, and I'll have more information once it opens.
That concludes my report.
All right.
Member Rucker.
Well, good morning.
I work with Board Member Song on the Career Technical Education panel.
As Board Member Strauss already pointed out, we work together on the IQC issue.
So I won't repeat any of those reports.
I'm also working with NASB on the Whole Child Study Group.
We have been meeting every other month since the group was created back in the spring.
We're continuing to expand our discussion about what it means to support students and schools
in this environment as more schools attempt to open and make the transition,
the full-time face-to-face instruction in the midst of this pandemic.
There's a lot of work being done to collect and develop guidance and collect models
of good practice from schools and districts across the states.
California models, several of the ones that Dr. Darling-Hammond already mentioned,
are being included and being looked at by NASB.
Our next meeting is coming later on this month.
I believe it's on November 17th.
I'm also involved as the liaison to the State Council of Support for Military Involved Children.
These are dependents of military parents.
And we have been meeting with our new support commissioner, Kai Jackson, on a very regular basis.
One of the primary goals this year includes expanding the involvement
of other military communities, including the Coast Guard,
as representatives on this State Council to discuss matters for transition and engagement
of students who transfer into our schools.
Our current legislative liaison is Assemblymember Ty Gloria.
And with the changeover with the election, we are waiting for the legislature to identify
who our next legislative liaison will be appointed for this activity and for that position.
Finally, the last thing that I will briefly report on
is I am the liaison for the Math Curriculum Framework Committee.
The Curriculum Framework Committee has had a meeting, two meetings,
since our State Board of Education meeting in September.
We met in September, in October, and we just completed a set of meetings in November.
The committee has made some recommendations to the board asking particularly about board policy
and the criteria and policy that the board created for guidance for the framework and
the development of the framework for the committee.
Rather than presenting those recommendations to the board today,
because we couldn't take action on their request at this point anyway,
there is going to be a scheduled meeting with the writers and department and State Board of
Education staff on Monday, and I'll be facilitating that discussion.
We'll be taking a look at not only the board's current recommendations and guidance for the
development of the framework, but also take a look at how we will take an in-depth discussion
on the development of Chapter 12, the criteria for the publishers, as well as looking at and
understanding what the recommendations will be for course development, whether we're looking at
the integrated courses or the recommendations that districts may consider in creating course
pathways through the high school program, as well as the assignment on Algebra 1 for students
beginning in 8th grade, and I'll be ready to report that information back to the board
at the September meeting.
So this Monday's meeting is unusual.
It's a unique opportunity for us to have some very in-depth discussion at a point in time
where made multiple decision points, important decision points that will revolutionize and
really change the intent and purpose of the framework will be considered and developed.
So I'm looking forward to being able to come back and make a presentation to the board
about that at the January meeting.
That's the end of my report.
Awesome.
Member Rodriguez.
Yes, good morning.
So I attended the October 8th and 9th CTC meeting as a liaison, and there is a new student liaison,
but I'm going to come back to her in just a minute because I want to go over some of the data that
was covered regarding teacher prep programs.
The annual report card was presented, and the CTC dashboards are just – they do not disappoint.
If you have not been on CTC's website, please go on there and search and dig, and you'll get lost in
just tremendous amount of depth and breadth of information.
So some of the highlights from that report are, you know, that more teachers, it appears,
are being instructed by K through 12 staff than institutions of higher learning.
And for a more traditional route, 15,000 K through 12 staff
provided supervised clinical experience, and for the alternative IHE-based route,
6,000 K through 12 staff provided supervised clinical experience.
There was also, you know, the highlights on STIPS and PIPs, right, which are some of the
waivers that are provided by the CTC or districts, you know, and they have STIPS or
for acute staffing need due to unforeseen circumstances.
In the 2018-19 report, 3,600 STIPS were issued, right, you know, and again, the concern is
having a qualified, highly qualified teacher in front of all of our students here in California.
And then the PIPs, 2,500 PIPs were issued in the year 2018-19.
There are limited assignment teaching permits. These are for credentialed teachers who are working
outside of their credential area while working for an authorization.
Hi, Jay, I think you have an internet problem.
We'll give it a, there she is, you're back.
Oh, wow, it cut off, disappeared. All right, so I hope that you heard all the way up to the
variable term waivers. And so these are the final option for employers to meet staffing needs
when a suitable, fully qualified candidate cannot be found. And there were 400 new waivers issued
in 2018-19. The commissioners really emphasized how much they want for communication to exist
between the Ali-8s and the educator preparation programs and for there to be a,
are you, am I still here? You're still here.
And so, you know, and as part of the teacher candidate program, there's an individual
development plan that guarantees the continual improvement of the candidate as they're going
through the process, right? So that as they go through the process with a supervised mentor
or, you know, the qualified teacher, they become, they're fully prepared to take on the challenges
of the classroom. There was, there were a few examples within some of the accreditation reports
of where some of these programs are working beautifully, right? And that's what we need to
really strengthen so that the quality of our teachers that are coming into the workforce
are being able to meet the needs of our students. And especially right now that we're having such
challenging times, especially for our teacher, our current students that are in teacher prep programs
given the environment that we're all in. I'd like to highlight a teacher residency program.
LA USD conducted collaborative meetings with the residency partners. They discussed program
components and really highlighted their exemplary partnership. And that's something that,
you know, would, is important to highlight and recognize and continue so that there is
strong partnerships between the teachers, the IHEs, the districts, and they're working together
to build better prepared teachers. So the, additionally, you know, the CTC is also
responsible for teacher discipline. And the number of cases that are, that have been open
have gone down considerably. And the staff that works in this department
has just worked arduously to continue processing the cases. You know, there have been
funds that have been dedicated, making sure that the legal staffing is there and that these are
getting worked out and carried through in a way that's beneficial to all parties
and that there's due process. But I'd like to come back and highlight the beginning of the meeting,
you know, when commissioners do their reports, it was very emotional. And it has been very emotional
for the last few meetings as we're talking about the racial inequities, right, that we're just,
it seems like confronting with a lot of commitment in California and having these
discussions about what our students are going through and what our teachers are going through.
And, you know, some of my colleagues on that commission, counselors, teachers, just feeling
like, you know, they're having a hard time with everything that's happening, right, whether it's
the civil discourse or being online and not being able to be there for our students the way we are
when we're face-to-face. And we brought in a new, or there's a new student liaison, her name is
Corey Jones. I keep saying we because it feels like I just left the CTC. But Corey Jones, she's
a new student liaison and she was just, she was captivating in her commitment, in her voice,
very powerful and thoughtful. And she just broke through this digital environment.
And I just really felt her desire to humanize, right, and bring that thing that we can't really
put a label on in teaching that, you know, being able to embrace our students and carry them on
to learning and to continue. And so one of the things that she said is that trying to become a
teacher, right, she's a student teacher right now, in this ambiguous time is so challenging.
And anybody who is either teaching or teaching teachers or working with teachers or students,
it just shout out resilience. And so it was very powerful to hear that because it's true and I want
to, you know, acknowledge everybody, all of us in education who are confronting this. And if
Commissioner Martin from San Diego Unified, who is actually, her district I think is mentioned
in the report that we're going to be looking at in a bit. She read a poem by Maya Angelou
and it was incredibly, you could see everybody, we were all crying. And I'd like to share that
with you because it really, it took Corey Jones, our new student liaison's words and everything
that all of the teachers and counselors were feeling about the social emotional component,
students and teachers just feeling like they're at the end of their rope. And so without further
ado, if you'll indulge me, the poem is Continue. My wish for you is that you continue, continue to
be who and how you are, to astonish a mean world with your acts of kindness, continue to allow
humor to lighten the burden of your tender heart, continue in a society dark with cruelty
to let the people hear the grandeur of God in the peals of your laughter, continue to let your
eloquence elevate the people to heights they had only imagined, continue to remind the people
that each is as good as the other and that no one is beneath nor above you, continue to remember
your own young years and look with favor upon the lost and the least and the lonely, continue
to put the mantle of your protection around the bodies of the young and defenseless, continue to
take the hand of the despised and diseased and walk proudly with them in the high street some
might see you and be encouraged to do likewise, continue to plant a public kiss of concern on the
cheek of the sick and the aged and the infirm and count that as natural action to be expected,
continue to let the gratitude, the pillow upon which you kneel to say your nightly prayer
and let faith be the bridge you built to overcome evil and welcome good, continue to ignore no
vision which comes to enlarge your range and increase your spirit, continue to dare to love
deeply and risk everything for the good thing, continue to float happily in the sea of infinite
substance which set aside riches for you before you had a name, continue and by so doing you and
your work will be able to continue eternally. Thank you. Thank you IJ. That is a wonderful
sentiment on which we can be reflecting today. I see that State Superintendent Tony Thurman is
here. Welcome Tony. We are in the midst of liaison reports but we're going to come back to those and
let you make your remarks at this point. Good to see you. Good morning Madam President and I'm happy to
wait until the liaison reports are complete. All right then we will continue and so Member
Patio Bronson you are next up. Great so I wanted to give an update on some of the liaison work
on early childhood, early learning. As you all might recall back in 2019 the Governor and the
legislature approved two new bodies. One was the early childhood policy council to provide advice
and counsel on early learning policy issues and it also commissioned the master plan for learning
and care which was modeled on the higher ed master plan to create a long-term planning
effort in order to ensure that it is a thoughtful systemic rollout of how the system grows and
supports early learning for our youngest students. The major tenants that they were looking to
address were around funding reform, around workforce development, preschool expansion,
mixed delivery encompassing both family child cares, center-based programs and school district
programs, shared services, and data sharing so that eventually we can link the early learning
data with the K-12 data and actually provide a path towards longitudinal tracking to figure out
how kids are progressing and what services and dosages of services they're receiving.
What's exciting I think is that the master plan committee which is being led largely by Wested
has frontlined a number of themes around equity for the most vulnerable, partnerships with
families, developing the workforce, and a whole child approach which in the parlance of K-12
oftentimes tracks to social emotional learning but also is encompassing of health, mental health,
developmental screenings, IEPs. So the original plan was to have a master plan by October 1st
but for very reasonable reasons related to COVID the date has been moved back but there has been
quite a bit of outreach and stakeholder feedback. There were two large meetings with the parent
advisory committee and with the workforce advisory committee in September and the expectation is that
it will be made public before the end of the year and the date will be announced soon. We have
our preview meeting as the early childhood policy council to see some of the early recommendations
coming up later this month on November 16th and I think maybe just it's helpful to put a
shine a light on how the two systems are working together. Many family child cares have not closed
during the pandemic at all and have moved from the traditional role of serving younger children
but also now serving younger children and school-aged children and oftentimes playing the role
of ensuring that when parents are essential workers and kids need help getting online
that they are playing that parent support role for so many kids in order to make sure that they
can participate for virtual learning and I think and I'll stop there because I think we're running
a little bit tight on time so I look forward to being able to share the recommendations as they
come out and by January we should have lots more specificity to share with this group.
Linda I think you're on mute did you call me?
Yes I called you on mute.
That's great hello everyone yeah and board president I apologize for my for not being
able to do my background in complete transparency I have three teenagers in this house so if they
walk by mostly boy teenagers are unaware of their surroundings so I'm just going to say it right now
you are freezing can you hear me now okay so I'll update I'll be brief I'll update great
I'll update on we have four goals related to the CCE I'll be brief and highlight two of those goals
so that we can hear from our state superintendent goal one is related to direct technical assistance
and CCE has been working on developing the progress monitoring for LEAs receiving direct
technical assistance and they're currently working on producing a public facing visualization
that conveys the progress of LEAs receiving direct technical technical assistance and that work is
primarily the learning that's coming from Alameda County Office of Ed and Oakland Unified School
District and that work will produce an impact report at the end of the 2021 school year that
will be produced annually to to show the impact of direct technical assistance across the state.
Goal three is the facilitation and development and implementation of structures and relationships
and processes to support the expansion of the system of support and I'd like to thank board
member Strauss for highlighting the AXE presentation on the system of support that was done October 21st
so Dr. Carla Estrada as well as our SELPA content leads participated in that presentation the SELPA
content lead for evidence-based practices SELPA content lead for English learners and the SELPA
content lead for universal design for learning and I would agree with board member Strauss
incredibly appreciative and also the CCE received some good feedback about promoting those resources
to engage more general education practitioners and lastly the hashtag come back California
CCE has been working on sharing tools and resources and practices to facilitate dialogue among
LEAs as they navigate the challenges on returning students to school and all of this information
can be found at the CCE website which has had a makeover and it looks it's really easy to navigate
so cce-ca.org and again thank you to Sue Burr for the found laying the foundation for the CCE
she contributed many years of service to the CCE and all of the good work that's coming out now is
as part of her leadership and so just thank you Sue and that will do it for me. Great. Member McClellan.
Thank you. This past month I had the pleasure in the honor of participating on the superintendent's
round table on Native American studies. I was impressed it was a it was a rather short meeting
but a great turnout and the number of folks listening and participating was was quite large.
It covered you know accuracy in studies of Native Americans. Some of the challenges are that there
are so many tribes in California over 120 federally recognized tribes and trying to select curriculum
that covers and accurately covers all the tribes throughout California will be a challenge and then
will be a challenge and then our diversity in the state you know what happens in northern
California compared to southern California very different but I'm really looking forward to
this process and continuation of it and again a very big turnout of folks who were on the call.
The second thing you're going to hear later today so my participation in the student advisory board
on education helping those students prepare for their later presentations today that you'll be
hearing but it was a fantastic process and very impressed with the students and their preparation
for what they'll be presenting later today. It was it was a fun process that's all I have. Thank you.
All right thank you very much. Member Glover Woods.
Thank you and most of my comments I gave during item one. I did have opportunity of course to be
part of this screening committee. I did share my comments for that and Vice President Strauss did
cover the information for the upcoming IQC work around the ethnic studies model curriculum. So I
have nothing further to add there. I will just share I did have opportunity to participate
to participate in the NASBE convening that took place last month and in particular the
session that was held for new state board members was quite informative a great orientation and if
there are any newer state board members that I'd like to see what was discussed I think they are
going to archive that particular presentation and that's all I have to share at this time. Thank you.
Thank you. Member Fattah. Thank you President Darling-Cham and this past weekend I had the
honor of attending the Student Advisory Board of Education hosted by the California Association of
Student Councils from October 30th to November 2nd. As board member McQuillen already echoed
we're going to be hearing from them a little bit later today but my role at that conference was just
facilitating the election process for next year's student member on the state board of education.
And so the student delegation at the conference narrowed down the 12 semi-finalists that the
screening committee selected to six finalists after hearing them deliver speeches and speaking
with them directly and I also staffed board members Strauss, Sun and McQuillen on the interview
committee to select the top three candidates who we will be recommending and I believe it's item two
to the governor. We will also be meeting shortly and I think I speak on behalf of all four of us
when I say that it was an incredibly difficult decision probably one of the most difficult
decisions I've ever had to make to narrow down those six candidates to three and that
concludes my liaison report. All right thank you. Member Burr. Good morning. All of the issues that
I worked on will be coming up either today or tomorrow so I'm anxious to hear from Superintendent
Thurman that completes my report. Thank you and I'm going to give one item for us and then move
straight to our state superintendent. This has been a month of many many meetings of all the
education groups. We do belong to the National Association of State Boards of Education as I
mentioned earlier. I served on a NASB panel on how state boards can promote equity and spoke about
a lot of things that are already on route in California but also heard from some other
state board leaders about what they're doing around equity in their states so that's a very
interesting conversation and one that you may want to tune into. The video and audio from that are
available and will be sent to you with a link not only from that session but from the whole
conference. A lot of talk about the importance in this moment of really humanizing education
so a link to member Rodriguez's comments that I think is coming out a lot of discourse in education.
I'm going to with that turn the floor over to State Superintendent Tony Thurman. Tony, great to see you.
Thank you Madam President. Good morning, good morning board members and good morning to everyone
who's following today. We hope that wherever you are you continue to be safe and well. Today I get
to join you from the California School for the Deaf in Fremont. I have been having the opportunity
to work here and work at the California School for the Deaf in Riverside and I can tell you that
both of our schools offer incredible preschool programs to help many students who have no exposure
to language until they start school. I also want to mention the California School for the Blind also
in Fremont. We have three incredible schools serving incredible students with great educators
doing great things even in the pandemic. I also want to just thank all the board members. Many of
you have had a chance to either be on phone calls with or Zooms. It feels like we're in regular
communication always with the state board president on issues on a regular sometimes on the daily.
I'm grateful for the opportunity to speak with board members Rucker and I think I've been on
at least a handful of Zooms with board member Fatah and his great leadership and advocacy for
students in ethnic and racial justice in the state. Thank you board member McQuillin for joining
our virtual teaching conversation about how we teach correct and culturally competent
learnings about Native American history in California schools.
Thank you board member Dr. Glover Woods for the wonderful introduction of school board members
in San Bernardino and Riverside counties. It's an honor to see you all madam president,
madam vice president. I want to start off by again just acknowledging the resilience
of our students, our educators, administrators, and their families. We've been at this since March
addressing the impacts of the pandemic, addressing the impacts of racism, addressing the impacts of
fire, and now something I never knew existed election anxiety and hearing people say that
anxiety even from the election can create physical manifestations for people and so we want to
encourage those who need it to reach out to your provider if you need support to reach out to support
wherever you can get it. The biggest conversation continues to be school reopening. Many of our
schools have opened. Many of our school districts have set opening plans that lead them in the run
up from now to January. Many have used the small learning pods model to figure out how to get open
and our schools still continue to have conversations about how to open safely. That continues to be
the key conversation and our staff is leaning in with many of our school district leaders to
ask the question, what's the impacts of distance learning? What are you seeing? What is your
experience? How are you measuring learning in real time? We're happy to share some reports with you
as we go. Our chief deputy Dr. Stephanie Gregson has been in conversation with many of our large
districts to hear some of their lessons learned already just months into this next round of
distance learning which we're happy to share with you. We're grateful to our partnership with the
Office of Emergency Services to help us get personal protective equipment to school districts.
This is among the top priorities in order for our schools to be able to safely open and remain open
is PPE and access to robust testing and there's still many conversations going on. The governor
and his team are announcing a new way to augment testing for schools. We've been in conversation
with school districts, mayors of our largest cities, all who are coming together to say how
can we open? On the subject of PPE, I want to thank General Motors who's come forward in a
new partnership and donated 500,000 masks that we can distribute to school districts across our state.
We've prioritized in the delivery of those masks our tribal communities where we know there is
disproportionate impact as it relates to the pandemic. We prioritize communities where there
are higher risks and underlying health issues. We've even been able to send some masks and we're
working with OES to get child-sized masks for children of farm workers, many of whom do not
have access to PPE, many of whom both children and their parents are often working outside where
air conditions are not good. Again, thank you to OES and others who helped us to send masks to make
sure that they are protected. Again, this is a very tough time. Everyone is leaning in to make
this work. I give our students and our educators and their families A-plus for effort. I want to
let you know that we have some great teachers everywhere, but I want to acknowledge a handful
today who have been selected to be the teachers of the year in 2021. The pandemic has caused many
celebrations to end, but we've decided it is important to continue to recognize excellence
in the teaching profession and in education for our classified workers in spite of the pandemic.
So allow me just to share these names of these teachers and where they serve so that you may be
aware of them. The first is Jim Klipfel, who's a ninth grade high school teacher in social studies
at Saugus High School in the William S. Hart Union High School District. He not only will be
one of our teachers of the year, but he is my nominee to be a national teacher of the year,
and he'll be competing against teachers of the year candidates from all of the 50 states. I'd
like to also introduce you to Allison Sear, who's a third grade multiple subject teacher at Lyndon
B. Johnson Elementary in the Desert Sands Unified School District. We had a wonderful conversation.
She couldn't believe it that the state superintendent was calling her to tell her
that she had been selected. I told her that honor is ours to be able to lift up teachers
during this time. I want to acknowledge Kisa Brown, who's a seventh and eighth grade
introduction to Spanish and advocate teacher at University Heights Middle School in the Riverside
Unified School District, another fabulous example of what our educators are doing,
and Laura E. Gomez-Contreras, who I've asked to become, I've asked all of our teachers of the
year to become advisors to us. Laura was sharing so many great examples of how we close the digital
divide. She is also a third grade multiple subject teacher at Martin Elementary School in the Santa
Ana Unified School District, and finally, Nora Nguyen, a sixth through eighth grade Spanish teacher
at McKinley'sville in the McKinley'sville Union School District in Humboldt County.
Salutes to all your wonderful educators. Thank you for what you do, and congratulations on being
named as our Teacher of the Year for 2021. As you've heard from Board Member McQuillan,
we've made our focus, our continuing focus, how do we use education to address hate. We're
looking forward to the IQC meeting later this month. Tomorrow we'll be posting some updates,
places where we made adjustments to the curriculum, and what we see is a very robust conversation
about how to strengthen the curriculum, how to strengthen the model, and how to create the model
that school districts can use in the future to continue to have important conversations as our
students ask to see representations of people of color and their contributions to California,
to our nation, and to our world. As we prepare to run up to the Ethnic Studies conversation,
I want to come back to the conversation that I shared with you, that we have selected 11 school
districts to receive mini grants to have professional development to do what we call education to end
hate. This means that we've awarded grants to districts to allow them to have anti-racism,
anti-bias training, and we've connected them with trainers, world-class trainers who can help them
in doing that. There's more than 11 school districts. We're happy to share that with you.
I do want to also share with you that we will be holding a handful of professional developments
hosted by CDE, virtual professional developments, where we continue to delve into conversations
about how education can counter hate, following up on the wonderful conversation we had with educators
about culturally competent pedagogy as it relates to Native American history and what we teach our
students and how we offset things that get taught that sometimes aren't even in our standards
and sometimes cause harm to our students. We will be hosting this month on the week of November 16th
a first conversation, a professional development, a virtual professional development on teaching
Native American history and Native American studies. Stay tuned for details there. That
will be followed on December 8th by a professional development webinar on countering anti-Semitism.
We've seen a rise in acts of anti-Semitism around the world. We've seen many of our students across
the country being tracked with anti-Semitic hate. And then on January the 12th, we will begin a
conversation about how we counter Islamophobia in our classrooms. We know that many of our students
are impacted by misperceptions and stereotypes in the things that they sometimes hear even in
school and bullying and things of that nature. And so on January 12th, we will begin a conversation
for educators, professional development on how to counter Islamophobia. One quick update on our
efforts to close the digital divide. Just want to thank some donors who've come forward in what is
now a $420,000 donation of technology to communities in the San Diego area with the priority
on tribal communities that have been without access to computers and the internet. I want to
thank San Diego Gas and Electric Company and Southern California Gas and the San Diego Community
Foundation for making this work. We continue our efforts to ensure that the internet will
flow like electricity. And myself, Chief Deputy and others have participated in the legislative
hearings on how to close the digital divide. We're preparing to make an announcement of a new
innovation competition. We're inviting Californians who are innovators, who have access to research
and development to help us identify the next big solution to close the broadband gap, focusing on
those communities in our state that don't even have the infrastructure to have broadband. I want
to thank Dr. Gary Michaelson and Genentech who've already made donations that have taken us to
upwards of $500,000 for a cash prize for this competition. Stay tuned for more updates. My final
announcement is really a thank you to the staff at the California Department of Education and the
staff at the State Board of Education for their endless work to continue to support a thousand
school districts and to support six million students. I have to call out a TSD. I lost track.
We've done 90 plus webinars since the pandemic has started, but I've lost count. I'm sure we're
upwards of a hundred. We haven't had a single break in, not going wood. We've been able to deliver
the messages to school districts without interruption. I got to thank our communications team
who continue to help us get the word out about devices and grants that we've made available.
Our teams that work in special education and nutrition services. Many of you know that at the
top of the pandemic, we were serving meals at 5,000 different locations. Our schools are really
getting it done. Our early learning and education teams, there's a big transition taking place
where many of our subsidized child care programs will be moved into the Department of Social
Services. This is very difficult for us, but we're taking it on faith that there's the opportunity
to streamline and maximize what families get in our subsidized child care programs when all the
programs live together in one agency. But I have to acknowledge everyone who works in child care
and everyone who works in early education and of course, expanded learning. What people forget
is that during the pandemic after school programs do a lot of great things to augment what students
learn during the day and they have safe and structured places. I know I'm going to get in
trouble because there are other divisions that I have not mentioned. All of our division directors
are great. All of our exec team members are great, but I got to shout these folks out who've been
doing incredible work to support an entire education sector during the pandemic. Madam President,
this concludes my report and I would submit to any questions from you or any of the members.
Thank you so much. We really appreciate it. And with that, we're going to move on ahead to
item number two and we'll get that one done before we take a little break.
Item two is the 2021-22 State Board of Education student member recommendation of three finalists
for submission of the governor for consideration and appointment. These are the students I was
thinking about earlier and that member Fattah identified in his comments. The State Board of
Education screening committee recommends that we approve the three finalists for the position of
student member as identified in the addendum. The item will be presented by screening committee
chair, Vice President Strauss. Vice President Strauss, please begin. As I do my presentation,
you see that the finalists have joined us, so you'll actually get to see the students in person of
the ones we're talking about. So let me just say we had 74 students apply to be the next student
board member for next year. It was an amazing number. Reading those applications, we had to
narrow to 12 and it was tough. Amazing. And then we, and this is the process we use every year,
the 12 students then present their platforms and what they want to do to the student committee,
what you're going to hear from. The students then narrow that 12 to 6. So then we had the pleasure,
member Sung, member McClellan, myself, member Fattah, and Patricia DeCosmo State Board, we
got to interview six. It was, as Zaid said, the hardest decision we ever had to make. So for all
of you who are going to present today, let me just say it was our highest point. It was so amazing.
The future of California is in great hands for the next generation based on the students I'm
going to introduce you to now. So the students that we are recommending in alphabetical order
as our free finalists, these will be presented to the governor. He's going to have a really hard
time, but let me introduce them to you now. Rana Banaka, she's from Modesto High School within the
Modesto City School District in Stanislaus County. Zachary Patterson at University City High School
within the San Diego Unified School District in San Diego County. And Jayden Stewart, North Hollywood
High, highly gifted magnet within the Los Angeles Unified School District in Los Angeles County.
Those are our three finalists. But we have to name our semi-finalists, so let me tell you who they are.
Stephanie Hu from Tesoro High School within the Capistrano Unified School District in Orange County.
Jeffrey Oh from South Pasadena High School within the South Pasadena Unified School District in Lake
County. And Katherine Sue at Westlake High School within the Conejo Valley Unified School District
in Ventura County. These were the semi-finalists that were presented to the students and I want
to recognize them and we will be mailing them all a certificate. Normally they get to come in front,
we give them a certificate, we take their picture. We're going to have to do the best we can remotely,
but I just want to let all the students know that we will be sending you a certificate in
recognition of your achievement. Michael Blair from James Enix High School within Modesto City
Schools in Stanislaus County. Paula Escobar, Evergreen Valley High School within the Eastside
Union High School District in Santa Clara County. Alexander Phan from Centennial High School within
Kern High School District in Kern County. Emma Jockray, Turlock High School within the Turlock
Unified School District in Stanislaus County. Benjamin Soloth, Oakland Technical High School
within the Oakland Unified School District in Alameda County. And Jennifer Tran, Bolsa Grande
High School within the Garden Grove Unified School District in Orange County. So I present to you,
those are our semi-finalists and our finalists. What an amazing group of students and when we're
ready, I'll be most happy to make a recommendation to the board for approval of our part three.
Awesome and congratulations to all of you. It's wonderful to get a chance to see you. You look
fabulous and we just appreciate so much all that you are doing and all that you will do
in the careers that you have to come. I want to put the public comment slide up if we can.
And while we are waiting for members of the public to call in, can we get that slide up?
I want to invite other board members who participated in this year's student selection process,
if they have any other initial comments and then we will see if they have any comments.
I just want to echo Member Strauss' comments as well. Zachary, Stephanie, Raina, Jeffrey,
Jayden, Catherine, you guys were amazing and it was so difficult in our decision. You inspired me
and I feel so much better about our future. So thank you so much for your time and the work
that you did in putting into the interview and the application process and congratulations to
the three that will be going on. Thanks. Wonderful and Jim? Yes, I just wanted to
echo the same thing. I was so impressed with all the students, their preparation,
reading their applications and the letters of recommendations that were so strong.
I'm also very hopeful about our future. After hearing from these students and their leadership
qualities, I'm just so impressed with them. So thank you for allowing me to participate.
Terrific. Any other comments at this moment? We do want to see if there's any public comment.
Is there any public comment? There are no public comment speakers at this time.
All right. We're open for any board discussion and you can raise your hand in the participant
or you can just wave your hand at me. Any other board comments? I will make a motion
to approve the three finalists to send to the governor's office for a state student board member
for the following school year. Sounds great. Do I have a second? I will second.
Go ahead. Go ahead, say. Oh, I will second. All right. That seems very appropriate.
We'll now have a roll call vote. Brooks, will you please call the roll? Member Burr.
Aye. President Darling-Hammond. Aye. Member Fatah. Aye. Member Glover-Woods. Aye. Member McQuillan.
Aye. Member Navo. Aye. Member Fetillo-Ronson. Aye. Member Rodriguez. Aye. Member Rucker.
Yes. Vice President Strauss. Aye. Member Son. Aye. Unanimous. All right. Terrific.
At this point, we'll take a 10-minute break. I'm going to also hand the gavel to Vice President
Strauss for the next item when we return because I have to be in another meeting for a short time.
We'll see you back. It is now 9.57. We'll see you back at 10.10.
We'll try to build those in today, just so you know. This item is an annual item for us.
It is presented by the student representatives of the 2020 Student Advisory Board on Education,
better known as SABE. Actually, I have to just say it's a highlight of our work. What you're
going to hear today from the students could impact practice going forward. Let me just say,
we really listen carefully and we are very excited to hear this presentation.
Eileen, I apologize. We need to reestablish the quorum.
Sorry. Brooks, would you please call the roll? Of course. Member Burr.
President Darling-Hammond. Member Fattah.
Here. Member Glover-Woods.
Here. Member McQuillan.
Here. Member Navo.
Here. Member Patella Brownson.
Sorry. Yeah, I have to go. Here. Member Rodriguez.
Here. Member Rucker.
Here. Vice President Strauss.
Here. Member Son.
Here. Thank you.
Okay, thank you. Actually, I thought we might have to do that, so I appreciate you correcting
me and we'll do that in the future after our breaks. So now we're going to hear from the
2020 Student Advisory Board on Education and I'm going to ask Elijah Tsai, President of the
California Association of Student Councils, and Diego Bustamante, the 2020 Sabe Director
and CASC Education Policy Director, to provide introductory remarks and they will then introduce
all of our individual student presenters for the seven topic areas that we're going to hear.
Elijah and Diego, please begin.
Elijah Tsai Good morning, State Superintendent Thurmond,
President Darlene Hammond, Vice President Strauss, esteemed members of the State Board
of Education and honored guests. My name is Elijah Tsai and I'm a senior at Lincoln High School
in San Joaquin County and the current state president of the California Association of
Student Councils. Since its inception in 1927, CASC has amplified the student voice, providing
avenues for young leaders to be heard during key moments in history. This year has been like no
other. Facing a tumultuous world, California students have experienced tremendous adversity,
each unique to themselves. This year's Student Advisory Board on Education has brought students
together from all over California, combining their experiences to represent the student voice.
An integral part of this conference and our delegation has been an election process for
the 2021-2022 student board member on the State Board of Education. I'd like to commend many of
the people who have made this conference and election process possible. The 12 semi-finalists
who have taken an active role in our candidacy and their respective proposals, the Board of
Education staff, and the current student board member Zej Fatah for conducting the elections
he went through only a year ago. Our consistent platform of presentations to the State Board of
Education is an utmost honor. Once again, it's CASC's privilege to represent this California
Department of Education's emphasis on the inclusion of student voice in the development of education
policy. Without further ado, I welcome the CASC Education Policy Director Diego Bustamante for
more details on the conference. Thank you for that introduction, Elijah. Good morning and thank you,
Superintendent Tony Thurmond, President Darling-Hammond, Vice President Strauss, and esteemed
board members for allowing us this amazing opportunity once again. My name is Diego
Bustamante and I am a senior at Lincoln High School in Stockton's Lincoln Unified School District.
I am the current Education Policy Director to the California Association of Student Councils
and the 2020 Student Advisory Board on Education Conference Directorate. For over 50 years, students
from all over California have come to critique, assess, and evaluate the state of their public
education and their school systems at the annual Student Advisory Board on Education Conference.
This year's conference took place from Saturday, October 31st to Monday, November 2nd and was
composed of 72 delegates representing all of CASC's 12 regions. It is important to acknowledge the
significance of this year's SAVE. During a normal year, we would all be in Sacramento right now and
the delegation of students would be sitting behind me filling every available seat and dressed in
their business professional attire. However, as with the majority of everyday tasks and events,
the COVID-19 pandemic has forced us to adapt. This year's conference took place virtually
with each student connecting from their own home through their personal or school-issued computer.
In light of the shift to distance and hybrid learning, this year in specific has seen the
amplification of many of the negative patterns and faults in our education system, in addition
to bringing forth a whole host of new issues and discrepancies. The student voice has and will always
be a critical perspective in the decision-making process, but student feedback within education
has never before been of greater consequence as we strive towards a more equitable education
system in the age of COVID. The students who made up this year's delegation are intelligent,
show exceptional initiative, and are open to both feedback and change. Their passion for
their own education, their willingness to be flexible, and their drive to enact positive
change in the systems around them inspires not only me but the rest of my staff as well.
Our qualifications are this, we are the ones who wake up early in the morning and attend school
in whatever fashion that may be this year. We are the ones who experience the California education
system. These delegates here have proven themselves to be competent in advising the
State Board of Education. With this in mind, this year's delegates have had complete control over
the topics presented to you today. With no bias from staff members, delegates debated, voted,
and decided upon seven topics that truly embody what the delegation views to be areas of concern
in the California education system. Over the course of three days, they took it upon themselves
to compress all of our different experiences, ideas, passions, wants, and needs into seven
thorough proposals. The seven issues that the Student Advisory Board on Education has decided
are areas of concern that need to be addressed in our education system are in order. Student
representation, civic engagement, racial equity, school safety, mental health, distance learning,
environmental and environmental sustainability. If you would like to view our packet of proposals,
you can check out the agenda item on the CDE website or also go to tinyurl.com slash save 2020.
That's tinyurl.com slash s-a-b-e 2020. Our first presentation will be on the topic of student
representation presented by Benjamin Salem. Thank you very much.
Good morning, esteemed members of the California State Board of Education. My name is Benjamin Salem
and I attend Oakland Technical High School. On behalf of the Student Advisory Board on Education,
we recommend that the State Board of Education encourage local district governing boards to
appoint students to district-wide subcommittees and create statewide guidelines outlining the
rights and roles of youth leaders, promoting this change by appointing youth to all statewide
commissions and creating a state SVM advisory board. From a young age, we as youth are told
our voices don't matter. Our teachers, our families, even our friends reinforce that we
are powerless in our decisions. Elective representatives actively discourage youth
from advocating for equality and change, eliminating accountability and activism.
In Oakland, our schools began to reduce the general budget in 2018 without consulting our
LCAP student directors, one which was me. During this time, our entire restorative justice team,
our foster case workers and the school breakfast team were reduced to a total budget of zero
dollars. Students consistently and tirelessly protested these cuts, but without representation
and discussions, we were powerless. Hundreds of students lost crucial support services that they
relied on without these programs. Imagine what would have changed if students had been centering
this discussion and if we had students at the table on budget cuts, the district would not
eliminate these services. Throughout our research and development process on local representation,
we identified the systematic effects of lack of leadership. Elected student board members
were repeatedly ignored by their colleagues on the board, and these youth elected by student body
were not allowed to attend their board meeting, relegated to sitting on Zoom while their adult
peers spoke freely. Similarly, in Palo Alto and Oakland, superintendent advisory councils and
other leadership groups were canceled due to COVID-19 without considering the ramifications
of student leadership or the viable options of hosting virtual meetings. Many districts create
a series of hurdles to prevent youth from speaking their mind and creating change in their communities,
only exacerbated by the lack of any precedent or institutionalized support for youth.
To combat this, we must expand these pre-existing governing bodies to all district decision-making
groups, allowing youth to serve in local positions of leadership, like their district subcommittees.
We recommend these opportunities are protected by a clear set of rights for youth officials
overseeing their roles and responsibilities, creating guidelines for youth legal partnerships.
We believe the exemplary leadership demonstrated by CSBA and the State Board of Education can be
replicated in all districts, including students in all decisions and therefore achieving performance
goals. The strategy of inclusion benefits both students and school board members,
allowing both sides to support students and promote leadership. We believe that less than
$5,000 required per school district to implement these positions, with an optional cost to appoint
a student advisor. But regardless of the cost of impacts or initiatives, there are countless
benefits to appointing youth to positions of leadership. Student board members already serve
as some of the most passionate advocates for youth initiatives, and other youth will advocate
for their other priorities. We observe that students and students represented in our education
are more likely to pursue research and support, and are more prepared for life beyond high school.
Districts without a student board member almost exclusively score failing grades in performance
and college readiness, demonstrating inequities exacerbated without a student balance. And the
simple act of instigating this change offers youth the opportunity to confront prevalent issues in
their communities, which drastically increases youth opportunity and student achievement so that
most represented districts excel in performance. This positive change is demonstrated by the
effects in San Francisco USD. In 2018, their district created an SPM position, appointing
two students from the district, and over the course of that first year, SF Unified achieved
significant improvements in student performance, finally achieving a rating of green from the CDE
dashboard. I can attest to the fact that representatives on boards lead to lasting
performance and stability, as SPMs effectively identify unnecessary initiatives and successful
programs. By standing in front of you, as a student, as a leader, and as a changemaker in my community,
passionate about representation. It is integral for us to serve and uplift students as they are
key stakeholders in our education. We must be certain that every student leader has equal
rights and opportunities to support their peers. This is why we recommend that the Board of Education
encourage governing boards and administration to appoint at least one people to each board
and district committee. We believe these changes will meaningfully impact student achievement in
our schools, and through this, we hope to lift the voices of our peers. Thank you.
Great, we'd be happy to take any questions or comments from board members now.
So Dia, just to clarify, do you want board members to make comments after each of the
seven, or do you want to hold till the end of the seven? Yes, if we could have comments
after each one, that would be great. Okay, so this one is about student representation
on boards and the voice to gain critical perspectives from students. Do we have any
board member comments? Oh, should I have to raise my hand? Yeah, go ahead, go ahead. Okay,
thank you, Board Member Strauss, and thank you so much, Benjamin, for your passionate speech.
I think there was a part of your proposal in which you talked about the possibility of creating a
student board member student advisory board for the state SBM position, and I think that that's
an idea that we should definitely consider on the state board because
I feel as though the student board member on the state board's perspective is currently informed
just based on conversations had with members of organizations such as the California Association
of Student Councils and GENEP, and I think that therefore it's kind of more shaped by interactions
and independent research rather than kind of working in tandem with individuals who understand
certain regions of our state better than the student board member can research, and so I think
that that's definitely something that we should consider as we kind of move forward with this
state student board member position, creating the student advisory board, because I think that that
can help the state student board member kind of inform their perspective a lot more, and yeah,
thank you. Thank you. Member Rucker, you have your hand up.
Thank you. First of all, I want to thank all of the students who participated in developing
this proposal and having the conversations about it. Normally at the board meeting, if we were
sitting at the dais, they would be in the room sitting in the audience and we would ask them
to stand so they could be recognized for their participation in putting the report together, and
that's not something that can be done today, so I just want to make sure that for all the students
whose names appear in this report, and it's been posted, I recognize you and I really do thank you
for your thoughtful approach and the ideas that you developed in this project. I do have a question
concerning the idea of the student board member advisory committee. When you think about student
voice, the student voice at this dais and at this level has come to be represented by the students
who come to this annual convening as members of the advisory committee for the state board
and my colleague on the state board, Zahid Fattah, but I want you all to think about and look back
at your own campuses. There are many, many students on your campus who serve in a leadership
capacity in many ways on your campus, and while I think your proposal is highly laudable and worth
considering for the work that is done to appoint and identify the student member, I think that the
power of your recommendation and your idea is its ability to expand who the student voices are
that can be represented in these type of advisory committees. So we're not just looking at one type
of student voice for setting policy, but all of the student leadership voices at your campuses
that contribute to creating the culture and the climate at your school. This is an opportunity
and a vehicle for expanding and giving a place to those leadership voices as well. So I really
would like to encourage you to think about that too. Thank you very much. Member McQuillin, I
believe you have your hand up and you've been part of this process. Do you want to make any comments
about this student representation proposal? I would just like to thank the students for all
their work and their flexibility. This is an unusual time that the students have shown a lot
of resiliency in attending this conference virtually and I know they've sacrificed a lot by
not going in person. I just wanted to thank the students for this presentation and all of the
students for their good hard work. Thank you. Thank you, Member McQuillin. So I would say just
to the rest of the board, when we listened in the student interviews about student voice and
perspective, we heard some amazing ideas besides advisory committee, including usually in social
media to make sure they got student perspectives. So I do think as the world is changing, as
technology becomes so much a part of all we do and students do, there are really some really great
opportunities to make sure in this huge diverse state, more than 6.2 million students, that we
hear from all 58 counties, that we hear from the diverse perspectives of urban, suburban, rural,
and I think the students brought us a lot of really good ideas. So for this first presentation,
I just want to thank Benjamin and the team that put it together so articulate. Oh, excuse me,
Member Rodriguez, I see your hand is up. Yes, Member Strauss, thank you. I wanted to speak earlier,
but the mail showed up and the dogs were barking. Anyway, I just want to acknowledge, thank you for
your presentation. And I have read this report with such delight. And as a teacher,
I value student voice and parent voice tremendously. You know, and in this environment,
I've asked, you know, one of the things, and this is actually another issue in this report,
but going back to the representation, you know, as Member Rucker said, you know, what would this
look like at the local level? And it would be, this is a great time to go back to President
Darlene Hammond's comments at the beginning, right? What is this, how are we going to emerge from this
and how is it going to be new? And I would really like to see student voice and vote, right? Because
we have student members in a lot of different capacities, but I would like to have you be able
to vote and to be responsible to your body of peers beyond ASB and, you know, beyond some of
these programs that students are selected for because of their academics or what have you,
but to really, you know, I think of the program Mosaic, making our schools an inclusive place,
but actually making California be, you know, where we bring a voice to a lot of different students
who have the voting power. So thank you for this. This whole item is very exciting to me.
Member Glover-Woods?
Thank you, Vice President Straus, and again, I'd just like to say kudos to the idea and the thought
of more increased student representation. Student voice is extremely, extremely important,
and one thing that I just give to all of the phenomenal student leaders for ongoing consideration
is how to best be sure that in that representation that the voice of all students are heard. I'm
thinking in particular for students that might be a bit disenfranchised from school, might not be
as successful in school. I'm sure these are conversations you've had in your settings as well,
but to be sure that the voices of all students, including those that, again, might be
disenfranchised with school or not as connected, that their voices are heard as well.
Thank you, Member Glover-Woods. Are there any other board members that would like to make a
comment? We have six more areas, so we have lots of feedback to give our students as well. So at
this point, Diego, I'll turn over to the next section. Great, thank you so much. Next, we will
have Anusha Athreya present on the topic of civic education. Thank you, Diego. I stand before you,
the Board of Education, proposing a policy that would affect over 10,000 schools across California.
Being 16 years old, I'm at an age that most adults regard as too young to care about these issues.
The first time that I learned that I could pre-register to vote at 16 was before the
2016 election in sixth grade. My history teacher, Ms. Nieres, used the entire class period to explain
the electoral college and the impact on the election on us as students. I am lucky to have
the opportunity to learn about my civic rights so early on, but the reality is that most students
in California don't have the opportunity to engage in civic discussions in schools until late in high
school, an issue that has stigmatized youth expression in civic leadership. My name is Anusha
Athreya, and I'm a junior attending Archbishop Mitty High School in San Jose, California.
On behalf of the Student Advisory Board of Education, we strongly recommend that the
State Board of Education facilitate the creation and distribution of a digital student civic
learning handbook, which would detail the ways in which a student could engage civically with
their community with the goal of improving civic engagement amongst youth. Now more than ever,
California students seek civic engagement and political discussions on a daily basis,
and with the desire in young people to engage in their political realities becomes more evident
with each passing day, so do the vast disparities that lie in regards to civic opportunity
accessibility in marginalized communities. Furthermore, in Petaluma Unified School District,
when the administration was pressed by students on how to participate civically, the district
responded coldly and negatively. Students in districts across California are not aware of
the opportunities for civic participation at their disposal, which includes organizations like
CASC and student board members. We love having a voice, but most of the time, youth feel alienated
from the political discussion because it's assumed that we don't have the knowledge to engage in
these conversations, especially in our current political climate. The presidential election was
just two days ago, where a little bit more than 12 million Californians cast their vote for state
ballot propositions, and many students are apprehensive about the future of our nation.
With our entrance to voting approaching faster, it's a fundamental necessity that all students
have the tools at their disposal to make their voices heard. We believe that the student civic
learning handbook should include essential information needed to inform students to become
a civically engaged member of society. With the State Board of Education creating a digital model
handbook, this format can be passed down to local school districts and adapted within their specific
policies. We propose this recommendation to be facilitated by a committee consisting of students,
parents, teachers, school district administrators, and any other pertinent community members with
steps taken towards distribution and accessibility for all students. A standardized STL handbook made
readily available to all students would create a culture in which students receive greater
engagement in civic opportunities, such as voter registration, civic leadership, and understanding
of policy language, thus greatly increasing accessibility and allowing previously marginalized
communities to effectively use their voice. It's imperative to recognize the important role that
civic education plays in the lives of students in California, and the current lack of quality
in civic education has left many students without the tools to properly express and represent
themselves. As a result, local education agencies miss out on the input of their primary stakeholders.
Students, we acknowledge the board's decision to pass the state seal of civic engagement,
which will incentivize high school students to expand their civic literacy, the requirements
to learn about constitutional policies and democratic principles, and the STL handbook
will only reinforce these ideals of civic engagement proposed within the state seal
and provide students with a set of tools for when participating in political and legislative
discussions. I am proud to be an advocate. I represent those who don't have the opportunity
to be here today, and with the necessity of civic engagement in today's political atmosphere,
everyone deserves an opportunity to be represented. For these reasons, we strongly suggest that the
State Board of Education facilitate the creation and distribution of a student civic learning
handbook so that California can make a significant change in our education system
and empower all civically engaged students. Thank you.
So we'll go to board member comments on the proposal for civic engagement and
a handbook to support student activity. Do I have board members who would like, let's see,
member Rucker, I see your hand up. Well, I see board member McQuillan's hand is up first. Maybe
it might be more appropriate for him to speak before me. Okay. I think he was first. I think
he put his hand up before I did. Okay, thanks. Sorry, I was going on the screen I saw. Member
McQuillan, would you like to make a comment? Oh, just briefly, I just want to congratulate
the students on their presentation, a great job, and I think this is a very important
handbook recommendation that you've made. When you think of the schools all over California,
they're kind of all over the map in terms of defining what civic engagement is, and it would
be very helpful to outline that for students, especially with the latest action we took with
the seal of civic engagement that we approved a couple of meetings back, but good job and great
presentation. Thank you. So member Rucker, and then after that, member Patio Bronson.
Well, Ms. Anusha, I can't say your last name, so please accept my apology for addressing you by
your first name instead. But I want to let you know, it's interesting, yesterday afternoon I
had a conversation with a friend of mine. She's a high school English teacher in San Ramon,
and we were talking about this very issue, and I mentioned to her that the board had approved the
state seal of civic engagement for recognizing students in the local school community.
Not only did she not know anything about the state seal, not only did she not know that her
district could create the policy and craft the criteria for identifying students, but she also
didn't know that it could include a whole variety of ways that students could be recognized
for their civic engagement. So I think your idea is an excellent idea because it would actually make
the basic premise that the board approved actually become a living activity and a living document
for districts to look at and engage in. Not only would teachers become more aware that this
opportunity exists to recognize a whole lot of ways that students are involved,
not only in their school community, but involved in the community in general in civic ways.
And so I think this is an excellent idea. Again, I want to applaud you as the presenter, but also
your fellow members on your committee who participated in doing this work. And again,
I see your names and I appreciate the thought that you put into this. This is an exciting
opportunity for the board to see at the local level an idea brought to fruition in very creative
and relevant ways for students just like you, but also as board member Glover Woods pointed out,
for students who do not necessarily see themselves as members on a student council,
but who do get engaged in other activities like Black Lives Matter or who do voter enrollment,
voter registration, or I know a particular young lady who lives in Vallejo. She actually
worked a poll, a voting poll on election day. And I think it's important to recognize that
type of work as well. So thank you very much for this very, very thoughtful and creative idea.
I also wanted to congratulate the group and Anusha on the excellent presentation. Clearly
you all have thought about this and come up with something that is both actionable and realistic,
and I really appreciate the presentation as well as all the hard work that went into it.
As some of the board members had mentioned, we just recently passed this motion around the seal
of civic engagement and it's very much our, I think, hope that that action will also provide
additional sort of wind in the sails of exactly this type of effort so that LEAs, so school
districts and county offices of Ed will know that this is something that is both within
their capacity but also something that is encouraged and something that for which students
should be rewarded when they take initiative. I think as is often the case, sometimes it is
happening in sort of pockets of excellence and then there are places where it is not happening at
all. But this particularly two days after the election where we don't actually yet have a
declared winner, there's really no better applied learning experience than right now. I can certainly
attest to the fact that I've been watching all the electoral boards with my own children
and in addition to sort of the civics learning part of the electoral college, I think my fifth
grader can now pick out Michigan, Wisconsin, Georgia without the math names, which is a new
and exciting part of sort of knowing how both the electoral college works but also a little
bit of geography. But I just want to, again, commend you all on what is an excellent and
well-thought-out idea and I hope that we can find a way to actually bring that to life.
Thank you, Member Pratip Ronson. So Diego will move on now to the racial equity presentation.
Great. Thank you so much for that. Next, we will have Eliane presenting a proposal on racial equity.
Good morning, esteemed members of the California Board of Education. Just this March, some students
from my school joked about staying six feet away from me in fear of contracting COVID-19.
The matter of the fact is microaggressions like these aren't micro. As a Chinese American,
as a Chinese American, I felt alienated and humiliated, but I invalidated my feelings and
chose not to report it because I had been conditioned to think that getting upset over
such remarks is overreacting. My name is Ellie Lian and I'm a sophomore from Portola High School
in Orange County. I am one of more than four and a half million students of color in the California
public school system and I'm one of the countless students affected by discrimination. Today, I'm
speaking on behalf of my group covering racial inequity in the California education system.
In light of recent racial justice movements, the urgency of equity has only been magnified.
Students such as myself feel uncomfortable and even unsafe speaking upon racial experiences.
In addition, many local educational agencies do not recognize the experiences of discrimination
that students who are BIPOC, Black, Indigenous, and people of color have to go through. And as a
result, no effective disciplinary actions are taken. We need to create an environment where all
students feel safe to learn and thrive regardless of cultural background. In recent years, there has
been an increasing attentiveness to discrimination on campus and there has been legislation passed
in efforts to address this matter. Although this is a step in the right direction, FBI data shows
that since 2018, hate crimes on campuses have actually increased by 25% and due to recent racial
justice debates and COVID-19, the racial inequity has only been aggravated on our campuses. We heard
stories from Tesoro High School where a French teacher called a black girl a monkey with no
disciplinary action taken. We heard stories from Annaleigh High School where a student of color
was told by educators she had little chance to attend college despite her strong academic
performance. These are our students going to school on our campuses whose experiences were
largely ignored because they had little confidence and their schools had believed to listen or
administration failed to follow through with consequences. These students reflect a small
sample of a large number of BIPOC students whose experiences are repeatedly invalidated and downplayed
and therefore are unheard, unknown, and underrepresented. In response to this, we
use insight from students of all backgrounds and experiences to create a holistic solution that
follows the footsteps of AB9, also known as Seth's Law, a legislation passed in 2011 that requires
the state superintendent to provide anti-discrimination resources for LEAs, intervention
from school staff who witness acts of racism, and student accessibility to procedures and policies
for handling discrimination. Our solution calls for the California Department of Education and the
state superintendent of public instruction to develop and encourage the use of a blueprint
consisting of effective methods that provide comfortable and accessible ways for students to
report racially charged incidents and then encourages the use of restorative disciplinary
action. The proposal requires superintendent Thurman to instruct the task force on safe schools
to design a blueprint of practices for reporting incidents of racism and complete subsequent
research to formulate this model. We also suggest holding surveys for students in regards to this
model as well as including student student representatives so that all stakeholders,
including students, are represented in this task force. After development is complete,
Superintendent Thurman will distribute it to school districts and local educational agencies
along with the other resources he has to provide under AB9. We recognize the great work you all
have already done and greatly appreciate the effort that has been taken to make this pressing
issue a priority. So while there may be some costs required for funding research and expert opinions
from the racial equity field, the established platform we already have to build off of means
that the development for procedures related to racially targeted incidents will require minimal
costs. This means that the benefits of this policy will greatly outweigh its economic exertion.
The positive change that AB9 has brought so far also supports the liability to our method.
Since its implementation, a grand jury report that examined bullying from Marin County showed
that 25 schools have taken their own initiative to launch various methods such as anonymous
tip lines, surveys, and forums for students to vocalize these incidents for investigation.
Many have even implemented restorative justice practices such as peer courts counseling
and peer mediation. Our proposal is simply in addition to AB9 that increases accessibility
and guidelines for school districts. By providing students a safe and proper platform to be heard,
schools will be able to directly gauge the experiences of its BIPOC students,
thus instigating a sense of urgency within schools towards racial equity and equality.
Once racial offenses hold consequences, BIPOC students will be validated,
improving not only the school climate but also actively dismantling the normalization of racism.
Thank you.
Thank you, Ellie, so much. So board members, you want to put your hands up? And I just would
say to member Rodriguez, I apologize. I think your hand went up just as we were transitioning. So
I'll call on you first and see if that's and then member Rucker right after that.
Okay, and I didn't want to interrupt because the new the presentation really had started
speaking. And so I didn't want to jump in there. But thank you. And so I'm actually going to speak
on what you said. And thank you so much for your your your your authentic. It wasn't just like a
report. It was very personal. And I appreciated hearing that very much. But going to the civic
engagement, that's right up my alley, because I've been the mock trial coach and have had mock
elections. And I know that there, there are a lot of things in place for civic engagement.
But a lot of times, it's for students who are competitive. And so it doesn't really include
students who need to learn civic engagement, to be able to access their rights and know when
their rights are being violated. I had the opportunity through street law to meet the
founder of mock trial. And he moved to Washington to work in urban schools, because he was really
disappointed at the way in California, it had become so elitist and so competitive. And, and
it was missing the point of having all students learn their rights, learn how to navigate the
court system, learn about Supreme Court cases, etc. I think with No Child Left Behind, when we
started looking at math and English language, history and civics just sort of if it wasn't
being tested, it was being ignored. And I remember having a conversation with former president Mike
Hurst, about how he wanted to see civics in every single grade at some level every teacher. So it
brings me back to the systemic thing. If it's an additive approach, it's probably not going to
happen. Because we have so much on our plates already at the practitioner level, that it really
needs to be woven into everything that we do. And with that comes teacher preparation and teacher
awareness, right? How to listen without judgment. If a student is politically saying something that
I disagree with, how do I not shut that down, right? And those are skills that we have to learn,
because unfortunately, you know, it goes into the next point about BIPOC students and that feeling
of, because I know what that's like. I absolutely know what it's like to be in a place and to look
around and feel powerless, feel powerless because of my race, because of my language of origin,
right? So I know what that's like. And there are, as I was reading, as I was reading the report,
and read about Seth's law that you mentioned here, I actually asked about 30 teachers that I know,
excellent teachers throughout California, if they were familiar with Seth's law, and nobody was.
And so it made me wonder, like, what are we not communicating to the people that are actually,
you know, working? And it's not because, I mean, these are teachers who are on top of policy,
on top of, you know, a lot of, they stay relevant and really care about kids. And they're not teachers
who bully students either or would accept that. So I was surprised to know that that information
isn't in the hands of the practitioner. And that's what we need to do to make this just so
that it's such part of our mindset that we're not, you know, that we've inculcated. And
I believe that the standards for teacher preparation include the new standards that,
you know, for the last three, four years include a lot of this inclusion. But we still need to
do more. So I really appreciate your advocacy. And I want to see this become an integral part
of our classrooms and our schools. So thank you.
Thank you, Member Rodriguez. So Member Rucker and following Member Rucker, Member Glover-Woods.
Ms. Leon, I'm going to begin with an unusual request and ask if you would please
read the names of all of the students who work with you in your committee on this project. Would
you please read them aloud if you have that information? Yes. Give me a second to pull that
up really quickly. Okay. So while you're pulling that up, let me just say it's, this is a very
personal issue for me. For the years and all the years that I have been on the board, I have never
heard anyone so articulately state the issue of microaggressions in the way that you and your team
have done. Let me say that first of all. And I would like to say, and I would like to pretend
that we live in a world where people grow up and learn not to do that. But the same issues of
microaggressions that you identified so personally in your story are the same issues that I'm sure
all of your peers who are here this week have also dealt with, but also we watch as adults
engage in the same behaviors. I have, I personally have encountered and dealt with those same
behaviors and being a public figure, I am very careful how I choose to enact or react to those
things because probably one of the most dangerous microaggressions that I have to deal with is being
labeled as an angry black woman. So I truly do appreciate what you have stated, what you have
offered here as an idea. And it is, it has been my personal campaign as a member on this board to
address this, not just because of the issue of bullying. This is a board that has committed
itself to addressing the issues of what it means to close the achievement gap. This is the one issue
that remains unnamed on all of our agenda and all of our activities and all of the things that we
have attempted to pay attention to. We talk all the time about equity. We talk all the time and
look at and call attention to the gap in performance among our students, in particular with ethnic
minority subgroups and with particular concern to the over-identification of African American
boys in being referred to special education. But the fact of the matter is the issue of
microaggressions and the problems that are caused by the students who have to deal with that is a
key and significant factor of why there is an achievement gap and why many students do feel
disenfranchised in their schools and their communities. So I want to thank you for being
willing and being brave to draw attention to this. And that's the reason why I want to make sure I
ask you to identify the name of your colleagues who participated in developing this project. So
I'll pause here and ask you to read your names aloud if you have it now. All right, there's
Katherine Xu, Stephanie Hu, Kamiya Tofi Rad, Jennifer Cruden, Raina Bakhnakhan, Max Ramirez,
Resendez Vicladina Hernandez, Lamis Yassin, and the counselor is David Ching and the research
committee is Estrella Pacheco. So thank you very much and I want to give my personal thanks
and appreciation to each of the students that you name. And what I can promise you here sitting here
today is whether for the entire, for the balance of my tenure on the board and even when I leave
the board and in all my other personal and professional endeavors, I will do my best to
make sure the things that you proposed here are things that we can make a reality. Thank you so
very much. Thank you. Sorry, I would really quickly like to mention that the writer of this proposal
is Erin Tack. Sorry, I missed her. Okay, thank you so much. Member Glover Woods.
Thank you and Ellie, I first would like to just applaud you for the very personal way that you
started your report and many of my fellow board members have spoken. I'm not going to elongate
the time so we can get into some of the other areas, but I just want to underscore how important
the recommendation that you have shared with us really is. We have ongoing conversations about
equity in the field of education. In almost any form you go into, equity has become the word that
is utilized. We spend a lot of conversation and time looking at how do we expand our curriculum?
How do we be sure that the lived experiences of people of color are really told in the various
content areas? But your proposal and the proposal of your colleagues is so critical because all of
that conversations about equity, diversifying the curriculum, all of that falls flat if students are
dealing with microaggressions as they are on a regular basis on campus. And Ellie, you stated
it so eloquently when you said microaggressions are not micro. They are not. They are the things
that impact what a student's experience will be on campus from day to day and how they're able to
either be set up for success or not set up for success because of the environment that is created
for them. So to have something convened to be able to look at what those best practices and
model practices are so that when racial microaggressions are taking place on campus
by students, by teachers, we want to be sure that there is a way that students can communicate
what they are experiencing and what is happening to them. And I really think that again this
recommendation helps to put some meat on the bones of all of the other conversations we have in
education around equity and diversifying the curriculum. So again, I applaud you for speaking
on behalf of your colleagues. Kudos to Member Rucker for having the names that those students
read aloud for this purpose. And I do hope we do some further exploration into how this recommendation
can come to fruition. Thank you, Member Lover Woods. Diego, I'll turn it over to you for the
next section which follows this. Thank you. Okay, so next up we have the topic of school safety
presented by William Hin. Good morning Superintendent Thurmond, President Darling Hammond, and esteemed
board members. My name is William Hin and I'm a senior attending San Diego High School in the
Garden Grove Unified School District where I proudly serve as a School District Student Board
Representative. On behalf of the Student Advisory Board on Education, we strongly advise the State
Board of Education to recommend and set guidelines for local education agencies to establish various
methods for students to communicate to local administration their safety concerns such as
sexual harassment, staff misconduct, and possession of dangerous substances and weapons.
And that these student voices be taken into account when schools execute campus-wide safety
initiatives. Last year on her walk to school, my friend's backpack was grabbed by a strange van
who asked her where she was going. Terrified, she broke away and ran to her school campus.
Shaken, she reported the situation to her school administration but instead of being comforted,
she was sent straight to her school resource officer. The SRO terrified her by questioning
and recording her without her permission. That day my friend experienced two uncomfortable situations.
If she was able to express her discomfort, the administration would understand how to improve.
When schools lack student input on school safety, the systems in place put the mental and physical
safety of students at risk. In a discussion between 10 students from distinct and diverse
regions of California, each person felt that student input was not acknowledged sufficiently
in creating and enforcing school safety. This was mirrored in the observations we had of school
administrators failing to recognize the value of the student perspective. One notable example
occurred at a school in Chula Vista where there was an armed robbery at a school nearby.
Yes, students were unable to enter the school because of premature action and lack of procedures.
We understand these situations happen, but without consideration of the student perspective,
school safety guidelines can create an uncomfortable and in some cases,
blatantly unsafe learning environment where the feelings of students are discredited.
While we recognize that there are pre-existing channels where students can provide their
perspective, we believe students need more accessible outlets in order to communicate
safety concerns to administration at each school site. We are not proposing the creation of new
measures. We are suggesting researches on campus where students are able to voice their safety
concerns and have their perspectives taken into account by administration. For instance,
at a school site level, we propose the implementation of anonymous tip lines where students can
immediately express any pressing issues such as bullying, sexual harassment, teacher misconduct,
and other potential safety risks. At a school in Garden Grove, this type of tip line was established
and made easily accessible through the school's website and wasn't printed on every student's
ID card. In one instance, this tip line was used after school to inform the administration
that a student was threatening to bring a gun on campus the following day,
which allowed the police to apprehend the student the next morning.
Student voices could also be taken into account at a district level through district board meetings
where students have the time to publicly share their concerns or experiences regarding campus
safety. While these are only some recommendations from our complete proposal based on our research
and as a delegation of stakeholders in the system, these precautions are what we need to see implemented.
The proposal we provide you with today will give students a multitude of platforms to express
their own perspectives to enforce and improve site safety. Consequently, the proposal would
promote a greater sense of protection on campus, enhancing learning engagement, and thus decreasing
chronic absenteeism among students that feel unsafe at school. I stand before you today to
alleviate many fears students face within the California education system. California embodies
more than six million students who face distinct situations that need to be addressed immediately
in order to provide a safe learning environment. Because we, the students, are the primary
stakeholders of the education system, our viewpoint will be the most truthful when reflecting the
prevailing issues of our system safety measures. Therefore, we advise the State Board of Education
to recommend guidelines for local education agencies to establish various methods for
students to communicate local safety concerns and that these student voices be taken into account
when schools execute campus-wide safety initiatives. Thank you. Thank you so much,
William. So I'll look for Board members who want to make some feedback comments on the
school safety proposal. Member McQuillan. Great job, William. Very succinct, very good presentation.
I want to thank you and your team for the research and this very valuable presentation.
You know, we know systems that allow a lot of feedback and return of information within that
system are more healthier systems. So your recommendations are right on point as well as
the last presentation and giving a stronger and additional avenues for students to give feedback
to the systems that serve them. So very good and thank you. So I'll ask if there are any other
Board member comments on the school safety proposal. I'm looking at the hands raised,
trying not to miss anybody. I do want to say to the students who presented on this presentation,
on this topic, this is a really important topic close to our heart, especially as school
and district leaders and state leaders. And I think your suggestions to make it safe for students
to be able to report, to feel comfortable when they're really uncomfortable and talking to staff
and the suggestions of what some of your districts have done to already address that will really
help as we share that in the state. And I just would say if students aren't safe, they can't be
engaged in learning. And we know there are so many things, especially some of our schools are really
large. I know the school I was high school principal had 3,500 students. You can't know all
that stuff. So you have to create safe avenues and safe ways for a variety of different reporting.
And also I think sensitivity to staff so they're aware of that, both the certificated staff and
the classified, the school resource officers. So again, William, you and your team brought up
important issues and I know we take those seriously at the state board level and at the
Department of In. Well, thank you very, very much. I'm going to turn it over to Diego for the next
report on mental health. Great, yes. So the next topic will be mental health and it will be presented
by Karina Pan. Good morning Superintendent Thurman, President Darling-Hammond and esteemed members of
the board. My name is Karina Pan and I'm a junior at Temple City High School. I am here to speak
about the pressing issue of mental health instability in children and youth across California,
especially given the current situation of COVID-19. We propose that schools use informational posters
to educate the students about topics regarding mental health, including guidelines to approach
specific aspects of mental health decline and both nationwide and district-specific resources
that students can go to for help. These posters shall include safe plans in the event of a mental
health crisis, positive coping mechanisms, and the identification of school-based services that
students can utilize for social and emotional support. We can continue to invest in services
like counseling and peer groups, but they will be useless unless students are informed about them.
We recognize that the state has already made efforts to increase the mental well-being of
students. However, declining mental health is still a very real problem for students in California
and across the nation. The stark reality is that mental health is one of the most pressing issues
that students face today. Between 2008 and 2018, there was a 38 percent increase of hospital
discharges for mental health issues among California youth ages 5 to 19. The rate of suicide
among those aged 10 to 24 increased nearly 60 percent between 2007 and 2018. Every one in five
teenagers live with a mental health condition. Even worse, during this COVID-19 pandemic, 29
percent of children and youth are facing mental health declines. Many students know someone that
has suffered from a mental illness, and the youth that worked on this proposal are no exception.
Personally, I've experienced declining mental health, struggle with suicidal thoughts, and I
was once diagnosed with mild depression. Unfortunately, like most students in California,
I did not learn of any resources to combat my intense mental health struggles. I felt alone in
my battle, and I didn't know where to reach out to for help. This is a situation that no one should
ever have to face, let alone vulnerable children and teenagers. If I had seen resources and
information about where to seek help around school like the one we present today, I would have known
how to respond to my struggles. Thankfully, through reaching out to my friends and receiving therapy,
I was able to overcome my mental health obstacle. But this is not the experience for all students
in California, which is why we are proposing these posters to help other students get the help that
they need. In our ideal education system, all students have easy access to adequate support
and mental health resources. All staff and students are educated on how to recognize symptoms
of declining mental health, and the student body as a whole does not promote negative stigma around
asking for mental health support. We acknowledge that declining mental health is multifaceted
and complicated, and that there are important steps that we need to take to combat this issue.
One significant leap in the right direction would be for the California State Board of Education to
strongly encourage districts to create and publicize informational posters about issues
pertaining to mental health. When students return to in-person learning, posters will be put up
around campus. However, if students are continuing online learning, a digital version of the poster
should be put up on school websites, emailed to students, and posted on school social media pages
like Instagram and Facebook, so students will be encouraged to refer back to them and will regularly
review the information. Our proposal will be effective because these students will educate
students, make them feel heard, and encourage them to reach out for help. Because posters are
engaging and 65% of people are visual learners, children and youth are more likely to absorb
information from them rather than listening to a long lecture or a speech. Additionally,
they are accessible to many students at once and can create a larger impact in a shorter amount of
time. It is essential for students to have easily accessible and appealing information because
students' long-term academic success is directly affected by their mental health, further emphasizing
the fact that mental health decline is one of the most pressing issues that students face today.
Increasing sadness or hopelessness among students was related to subsequent declines in gains in
test scores in reading, language, and math. High school students who screen positive for
psychosocial dysfunction have three times the absentee and tardy rates than those without,
and high school students with significant symptoms of depression are more than twice as likely to
drop out compared to their peers. Not only does declining mental health impact test scores, but it
also increases the chance that a student will not attend school. If declining mental health is not
directly addressed using a proposal like ours, it will be impossible to increase the success rate of
students in California. So please prioritize the mental well-being of students by strongly
encouraging districts to produce and spread informational posters regarding mental health.
Thank you for your time and your consideration. Well, Karina, thank you for the presentation for
your committee and for the passion and energy that you gave to giving us some very specific
suggestions of what we should think about as we all really focus on the mental health support for
all of our students. I'll ask some state board members now if anybody would like to make a comment.
Member Malvo.
Yeah, I just want to thank you for this. As well as William prior, I didn't have an opportunity
to thank you both for speaking on safety and Karina on the social emotional mental health.
This is a huge issue and one of the striking statistics that you as pointed out in your
report is that the leading cause of death for students ages 10 to age 34 suicide. And I think
local educators are struggling with this and the idea that students need to be comfortable
and we all need to be comfortable asking for support and asking for help is a huge issue.
So I commend you on this and I would challenge your team to think of more than the posters
and the information that we can do more in this area. And I would think I would challenge your
team to think to think more, be more intrusive and more disruptive with the system when it comes to
elevating the urgency around mental health. But I thank you for this. It's incredibly
powerful. I loved the way you elevated the significance of this. As it's dear to my heart,
I know dear to many board members. This is an issue for our youth. It's incredibly challenging.
So thank you. Thank you, member Malvo. Member McQuillan.
I just want to congratulate you on a great presentation, very succinct, and taking the
recommendations that were made earlier this week and integrating those into your presentation.
Very valuable information that we all need to think about right now with the times we're in,
the crisis of the pandemic, and the need to get those resources out to our students, you know,
in multiple avenues that you brought up, the posters that can be posted on social media
or on the student ID cards. I think those are wonderful ideas. And we need to follow up on this
and get that out to all districts and all schools. So very good. And thank you for this presentation.
Thank you very much. Thank you, board member McQuillan. So we have our final area, Diego,
environmental sustainability. Would you introduce our presenter?
We actually have two more. First, we have distance learning presented by David Kim.
And then we'll be moving on. I'm sorry. I apologize. No worries.
Just one second. Before we present on distance learning, David Kim, member Rodriguez wanted to
make a comment on mental health. So I apologize. I didn't see her hand up. So just hold on one
second. Thank you so much. And also, I'd like to echo what's already been said. Great presentation.
This is a very pressing issue as I'm dealing with students who are very depressed right now,
suicidal. And fortunately for me, they feel comfortable to reach out to me.
But I'd like to echo what board member Navo said, that posters are nice. They add a level of
awareness. But we have to go deep into how are we handling the social emotional learning in our
classrooms? What are we as teachers doing to bring those conversations and take the shame away?
You know, because on the one hand, I have students who are very competitive. And it's great to see
them go and participate. But they put so much pressure on themselves that they're in my
classroom pulling their hair out, literally pulling their hair out because they're struggling so much.
And then on the other hand, my foster students who have so many issues that we need to create
spaces at school. And I'll bring back mock trial, truth and reconciliation, things that,
you know, where we can bring all of the students in so that they can use those skills. And as
teachers, we can also facilitate that closeness as human beings. So I do encourage you to push this
further than the posters and let's make it systemic so that we have a lot of nets in place so that
when students are falling, we catch them along the way and we don't let them slip through.
Thank you, member Rodriguez. So we're going to hear from David Kim presenting the proposal
on distance learning so relevant to the work we're doing today for all students. So David,
we're looking forward to hearing from you and your committee.
Good morning, board members. My name is David Kim, and I'm a senior at Lincoln High School in
Stockton. We, the Student Advisory Board on Education, recommend that the State Board of
Education convene a distance learning task force composed of students, teachers, administration,
and parents dedicated to improving distance learning and the transition back to traditional
learning models. Though the California Association of Student Councils meets annually with the Board
of Education in person, we are speaking to you today amid one of the largest crises in the history
of public education. COVID-19 has drastically changed the way schools across the state of
California operate. However, it hasn't changed the mission of equity, dedication to a high-quality
public education that the state of California promises. I'm speaking with you today as I face
the challenges that distance learning has brought forth, but I'm also speaking with you today with
a computer, a support system outside of school, and the ability to be successful by virtue of
the opportunities that I've been given. These personal experiences, from being able to actively
participate in hearings like these to accidentally being kicked out of my Zoom meeting for my calculus
class, have defined my outlook on distance learning and have reminded me that we must ensure the voices
of every student are heard. The vastly different experiences of students across California and the
United States are all indicative of an underlying issue. In many cases, students, administration,
and school boards lack input and communication amongst themselves,
prompting school districts to bring forth solutions that aren't beneficial for student learning.
Distance learning has emphasized the inequities that many students were faced with in traditional
learning models. Just over half of parents at 54 percent feel that California schools in general
are somewhat or very unprepared to offer distance learning. 79 percent of parents say that keeping
children motivated and sustaining their interests are their biggest challenges. In turn, students
report weaker understanding of curriculum, as seen as Shasta Union High School District, which has
reported a record number of deficiencies given out in the first quarter. Students watch firsthand as
their education falls short to work for them in these circumstances, yet by implementing student
voice, this issue could be mitigated. In such cases like mental health, student input is essential.
At Fremont Unified School District, the superintendent instituted a student-oriented
task force dedicated to finding solutions to address mental health concerns. This initiative
was successful in its effective collection and mobilization of student input to create a solution
that directly benefited those involved. The future is increasingly becoming digital whether COVID is
going to be present or not, and student voice is essential in this new era of education.
As such, the Student Advisory Board on Education proposes that the superintendent of public
instruction facilitate the creation of a multi-stakeholder task force that serves
to voice the opinions of students on multiple aspects of distance learning. Through the work
of the Board of Education, you've helped bridge the digital divide. Now it's the fall and we're
halfway into the semester. It's time for us to come together, check in, and work collectively
towards future progress. A task force can effectively compile the data across the state
and recommend participating members to disseminate best practices to local district administration.
The appointment of members on the identified task force incurs minimal cost due to the accessibility
and flexibility of an online platform. Therefore, the actions of the task force may produce a
financial dependency, however the task force itself will not. By connecting students from across
California with different backgrounds, we can bridge the gap between students and the problems
they face. We must ensure the validity of student voice and distance learning so that the next time
we undergo a global pandemic, we'll be ready. Thank you. David, thank you so much. What a relevant
topic in these days in our schools. So I'll look for Board members who would like to make a comment
on the distance learning proposal. Member McQuillan. Great job, David. Very good presentation.
And following the theme of student input of all of our presentations have had that sort of theme
to it. Very good suggestions. And I know our Superintendent Thurman has done a lot of work
in this area in trying to bring services and meet the needs of all of California throughout
California on distance learning. I think we've learned a lot over this past eight months, nine
months. And I think it would be really important to bring that student voice in to have us
validate what we've learned and add to what we are learning about distance learning and how it's
working for students throughout the state of California. So some very good suggestions and
I appreciate that. Thank you and good job. Thank you, Member McQuillan. Do we have any other
Board members who would like to comment on the distance learning proposal? Member Navo.
Yeah, I just wanted to thank you, David. And I believe our CDE and CCE are doing a tremendous
amount of work in this area. It seems to me that that would be a place to get your group plugged
into. Obviously the State Superintendent has done a lot of work on the digital divide conversation
across the state. CCE is doing a lot of work with the distance learning. That being said,
I agree with you. I think student voice needs to be present in those arenas, probably even more
so than they already are. So I would encourage you to seek those two entities and to put your
voice at those tables and conversations because that work is occurring across the state as well.
But thank you for your presentation. It's very informative. Thank you, Member Navo.
Just checking before we go to our final presentation. Anybody else want to make a
comment on this one? So seeing no hands, I'll turn it over to Diego for our presentation on
environmental sustainability. Right. So our last topic of environmental sustainability will be
presented by Adalia Lu. Thank you, Diego. Good morning, the esteemed members of the
California supportive education. My name is Adalia Lu and I'm a junior at Newbury Park High
School in Newbury Park. I'm here on behalf of the California Association of Student Councils to
discuss the development of environmental sustainability and consciousness in school
districts across California. Climate change is undeniably the most pressing issue facing
our world today. Despite incessant attempts to politicize it, climate change remains
the most destructive threat to our existence as a species, not as a political agenda. It's key
that educational systems recognize, acknowledge, and take action to lead the way towards positive
change. 2019 was the warmest year in history and global temperatures only continue to rise.
California students continually fail to receive the same quality of education at the expense of
these fires that burn up their fall semesters. In Northern California alone, classes were cancelled
for more than 260,000 students due to wildfires and those numbers only rise. Kennedy Delaney,
one of our group members affected by the fires every year explained, I've been out of school due
to evacuations, power outages, and even unhealthy air quality. Students are missing out on their
full opportunity to learn. We need action and we need it now. When education systems fail to
prioritize climate change, citizens fail to as well desensitize to its effects. It's our
responsibility to improve these conditions as much as we can for our students, to give voice to the
thousands of California students who rallied for sustainability to the state capital, ensure their
future, and enable their success. In the status quo, regulations for environmental sustainability
are lacking. Policies that promote combating climate change in our local school boards either
don't exist or fail to be equitably enforced. At Shasta High School in Reading, we can see that
almost no discussion is dedicated to sustainable practices or policy, which if implemented would
help mitigate the fires that Kennedy spoke about. However, in Oak Park Unified School District,
the creation of a sustainability group composed of students and teachers has led to many improvements
such as replacing toxic cleaning products and guaranteeing environmental literacy for every
student through science instruction. Thus, after thorough discussion this weekend at SAFE, we
determined that the most effective course of action was for the State Board of Education to
recommend all school districts to develop GDACs. Green District Advisory Councils focused on leading
and implementing a variety of sustainable initiatives at that local nonpartisan level,
allowing for district-specific environmental concerns like implementing hand dryers,
renewable energy, tribe and systems, and more to be addressed at their own timelines. Staffed with
qualified adult volunteers and passionate students, these GDACs would legitimize the urgency of climate
change as members would pragmatically and systematically combat it through the education
system. Locals with a passion for climate justice will be empowered and uplifted,
given the opportunity to hold their school districts accountable and make this tangible
change. This measure creates unification across the state and initiative, whilst maintaining
autonomy within each area, allowing them to take transparent action in what equitable,
effective and efficient manner is possible for each, all at their own pace. Our plan is not
solely concerned with the immediate. Legislative fluidity, consistency and continuity designed
for the long term are inherent in the creation of these GDACs, which we hope become a staple in
California school boards. The battle against climate change is lengthy, it's uphill and it's
definitely difficult, but with the establishment of these advisory councils, we take a step in the
right direction. Each district will be poised in a position to cause change. Environmentally
conscious legislation will receive the dedicated, continued focus from a number of committed
individuals without the loss of valuable time and energy of local school boards. Ultimately,
we'll be able to see a dramatic improvement, not just for those involved in the education system,
but for our society as a whole. The example that this prioritization would set is irreplaceable,
and it gives way to a significant improvement in student health, success, representation and more,
all at no risk. Thank you for your time. Thank you, Adalia, so much for you and your committee.
So we want some board member comments on environmental stability and the proposal of
GDACs, Green District Advisory Councils. So let's see, Member, President Darling-Hammond,
I'll call on you first. All right, first of all, thank you, and I want to thank the preceding
speakers that I was able to hear, all really amazing, wonderful and well spoken and well
thought out. This is really important, and I appreciate you developing a way to think about
what districts could be doing. I gave my remarks this morning in part on the same issue of climate
change, and what goes with the GDACs, I love the fact that you already have an acronym.
Once you have an acronym, you have a real thing in education, that these GDACs actually might
relate in some way to some kind of advisory council, like a state level, because we really
need to get the places that are doing good work. I flagged some districts this morning that are
really leading in some areas of climate conservation. We need a way that we can get those
ideas out to other districts as well, so I really appreciate this. I like your idea. It might,
we might think about whether there's an easier acronym, but the content is excellent, and I
appreciate you putting it out so thoughtfully. So I'll look for other board members, and while
I'm looking for any other hands, I'll just make a comment. As liaison to the next generation
science standards implementation, we've been talking about environmental practices and
through the implementation of science and helping students be more aware, and I do think
the suggestions and the examples that you gave Adalia with you and your team really highlight
the challenges, particularly in California, when we saw our entire state full of smoke a few in
September, and realizing how it impacts our student education. I think you bring up some very important
examples of what students are learning and experiencing during their learning process,
and what we really need to think about. So I just want to thank your committee and see if there's
any other hands raised. Member Song, I see your hand waving. Go ahead. Thank you. I wasn't sure
how to raise my hand in there, but just I had not commented yet on any of the specific proposals,
but I just I want to make kind of a summary comment that, you know, we know our schools
are microcosms of our society and often reflect the social and political issues that are happening,
and I just really want to thank the students who put so much thought, all the topics that you raised,
the environmental concerns, distance learning, safety, dealing with racial inequities, bullying,
civics, education, and valuing voice. All of these are issues that we are facing now in kind of our
larger society, which you are raising, and more than that, you have also come up with very solid
solutions to these issues and problems, and I completely agree that the value of the student
voice, because you're shaping our future, it's it best impacts you so that you really need to have a
seat at the tables when we adults have these conversations. So I just want to thank all of
you for your work and your time and for presenting to us today. So I'll look and see if in summarizing
any comments. I just want to miss any board members who would like to make a comment. This was a
really impactful presentation, gives us a lot to think about and a lot of ways to look at what we
can do to integrate our work and also to take a look at how we can help support counties and districts.
Member McQuillen. I want to thank all the students for their great presentations.
You did a great job with the research and working with your teams and taking the feedback in the
early planning and taking that feedback and integrating it. You all did great in bringing
important topics to this board. So thank you all. Any other board member comments? I just would say
so articulate, well written, and so well researched. Member Rodriguez.
Thank you, yes, and to echo all of that and thank you students for stepping up and
sharing your concerns with us. It makes me sad that you're the ones that are
looking at solutions for the environment in your high school years. However,
however, I'm glad that you are speaking up about this and we have to listen because
we are at a breaking point with a lot of the things as we've seen in California with the fire.
So the issues of justice and of race that you brought up, I read this report and I was just
so excited turning the pages. I printed it out because my lives have been changed by
the students that I've worked with and today is no different. You're not my students,
but I'm hearing your voices and I hear the voices of every child that's been in front of me. So
thank you and we will do our part to ensure that our schools fit the needs of the students that
are in there. Thank you, member Rodriguez. So do we have any other board member comments on this
item to close it? Let me just, I'm just checking the participant list or look at your picture and
put your hand up in the, if you want to make a comment. Okay, I'm going to turn the board
meeting back to President Darling-Hammond and we're going to move on to item four. Thank you.
Terrific. Thank you and thanks again to all the students. Awesome presentations.
Now we're going to move to item four, which is the mega assessment item.
This is the last item before lunch. If you're wondering when you'll get a chance to eat,
it will be right after this. We will make it expeditious so everyone can eat soon.
The California assessment of student performance and progress system,
the English language proficiency assessments for California, the California high school
proficiency examination and physical fitness test. This is approvable proposed revisions
to the Smarter Bell summative assessments for English language arts, literacy and mathematics
blueprints, approval of the proposed initial and summative alternative English language proficiency
assessments, students school reports and update on program activities. And this item will be
presented by Mel Vang of the CVE. I see that the PowerPoint is ready to go. Mal, please begin.
We're not hearing you. I don't know if you're on mute.
Okay. How about that? Better. All right. I apologize. Okay. So good morning,
Superintendent Thurman, President Darlin-Hammond and board members. I'm Mal Vang, the director
for the assessment development and administration division at the California Department of Education.
The item before you today is an action item. So for this presentation,
the California Department of Education has two recommendations for approval and we will finish
with time for questions for both recommendations. Rachel Maves, our deputy superintendent of the
Instruction and Measurement branch, will join me to share some opening remarks after I cover the
recommendations. So the California Department of Education is seeking approval on the proposed
revisions to the Spring 2021 Smarter Balanced Summative Assessments for English Language Arts,
Literacy or ELA, and Mathematics Blueprints as described in Tables 2 and 4 in order to allow for
ELA and Mathematics Blueprints as described in Tables 2 and 4 in order to allow for a short
test form and the proposed student score reports for the initial and summative alternate English
Language Proficiency Assessments for California or ALPAC as described in Attachment 2. So now
I'd like Rachel to come and make some opening remarks before I continue on.
Thank you, Dr. Bang. As we ask you to consider approving the adjusted blueprints or shortened
forms for ELA and math assessments, I would like to situate our discussion in the current context.
First, there are still many unknowns. I suppose we should not expect anything less from a year
that has brought a global pandemic, historic fires, rolling power outages, and I think the
only one that Madam President Darling-Hammond forgot was murder hornets. We do not know what
COVID cases will look like two months from now when the assessment window opens. We do not know
how many LEAs will move forward with their plans to bring students back for in-person instruction
in January or how many will be fully engaged in distance learning. We are bringing to you
our recommendation to approve an adjusted blueprint based on what we do know right now.
We know that the ED has indicated in a letter to chief state school officers on September 3rd
that they will not consider a waiver and that states should prepare to administer tests
as required under ESSA. We also know that we have LEAs in varying degrees of reopening across the
state. We know that we have students with varying degrees of bandwidth and we know that we must
continue to provide flexibility and innovative options to support students, teachers, and families
in an ever-shifting landscape. Second, timing is imperative. Consideration of an adjusted
blueprint is not a decision we can delay until the next board meeting. As you all know, California
serves 6.2 million students. Of the 6.2 million, 4.5 million test each year. Year over year,
California's participation rate in testing is upwards of 95%, indicating a high value in
our ability to understand how we collectively as a state are serving our 6.2 million students.
If we wait to discuss testing until some of our unknowns are settled, we potentially place
ourselves in a position without options. For California to administer a reduced blueprint,
it requires time for our contractors to revise the test itself. It requires time to support
the thousands of test administrators and examiners that work diligently to ensure testing is
seamlessly executed each year. And this year, it will require additional time to support and educate
parents as they have been and continue to be partners in their children's education.
If we wait until January to make this decision, a reduced blueprint will no longer be an option
for LEAs. During this time, LEAs need flexibility, options, and ongoing support as they collect data
across multiple measures to fully understand the impact of the last several months. Today's
recommendation to adopt the adjusted blueprints is one of many steps as we commit to working
alongside educational stakeholders to design a long-term plan to support learning recovery.
With that, I'd like to invite Dr. Vang back to the podium and she'll continue with this item. Thank you.
Thank you, Rachel.
So, before I go on, I want to provide an overview of our California assessment system to bring focus
into what our recommendations are about today. So, on one side of our system, we have our suite
of California assessment of student performance and progress. And under that, it includes the
Smarter Balanced Assessments for English Language Arts, Literacy, or ELA in Mathematics,
which consists of the summative assessments, interim assessments, and the formative assessments
through the Tools for Teachers system. We also have the California Science Test or CAST,
the California Alternate Assessments or CAAs for English Language Arts, Mathematics, and Science,
the California Spanish Assessment or CSA, and our Grade II Diagnostic Assessments.
And then on the LPAC side of our assessment system are the initial LPAC, the summative LPAC,
the initial and summative alternate LPAC, which is in development. And I wanted to remind us that in
2018, when the LPAC was integrated into the CASP system, with both programs, it became,
both programs went under the umbrella of the California assessment system.
So today's recommendations focus only on the summative assessments. Let me see if I can,
right here. Blueprint, summative assessments blueprint, and the initial and summative LPAC
student score reports of this big assessment system. So our division also
oversees and supports the work for several other assessments, including the physical fitness test,
the California High School Proficiency Examination, and high school equivalency
tests such as the GED and HICET, and the National Assessment of Educational Progress.
Just to give you a little overview.
As we go into the first recommendation, I want to cover some or highlight the key events
that brought us to where we are today. Remember that in March 2020, California requested and
received approval from the U.S. Department of Education to waive the testing requirement
given the pandemic. Well, in June 2020, the CDE issued our Stronger Together,
a guidebook for the safe reopening of California's public schools. Then through all summer 2020,
the CDE learned that an overwhelming number of local educational agencies or LEAs will return
to school using distance learning formats. So to meet the demands of distance learning, CDE did
explore and transition to offering multiple test administration options for the initial LPAC
and the optional summative LPAC during July and August, and these options went live on September
3rd. And another key event, as Rachel mentioned, was that the U.S. Department of Education
sent us a letter advising states that assessment waivers would not be considered for spring 2021
test administrations at this time.
So knowing that summative testing will not be waived again this year, the CDE understands
the following background points. So regardless of the mode of instruction in spring, there will be
more competing demands on our students' time than ever before, and the CDE is seeking opportunities
to really maximize flexibility for LEAs while keeping the critical elements of our instructor
intact. So the use of the adjusted short test forms for the Smarter Balanced summative assessments
for English language arts and math could provide gathering essential data with less bandwidth and
student testing time. So in order to use the test forms, the short test forms, and preserve the
maximum flexibility for our LEAs in spring 2021, the State Board of Education, or the California
State Board of Education, would need to approve revised shorter blueprints for both English
language arts and mathematics per California Education Code Section 60640C5. So the CDE does
not recommend changes to the other non-Smarter Balanced blueprints at this time.
So the following rationale were made for the revised blueprints, which are referred to really
the short test form in the item. So the revised blueprints are derived from our adopted Smarter
Balanced summative assessments for English language arts and mathematics. We are proposing
that the computer adapted portion be adjusted to about 50% for each claim, and the revised
blueprints will keep a comparable proportion of the content across the claims, which I will
cover more about claims in the upcoming slides. So given that the performance tasks are designed
to be integrated tasks, the blueprints associated with them have not been adjusted. We propose to
keep the performance tasks intact. So continuing on with further rationale,
the revised blueprints maintain the same proportion of depth of knowledge assessed.
So in this option, this does not require additional cost to California.
And finally, these revised blueprints are considered temporary for the 2021 spring administration.
So some pros or benefits with the adoption of the proposed adjusted blueprints
is that it reduces the amount of time students spend on the test. It provides more flexibility
in scheduling for the adequate monitoring of our administrations. It reduces the exposure,
potential exposure of the items from the item bank, and minimizes the risk of connectivity
or network issues that may arise. It allows LEAs to continue to meet federal testing requirements.
The individual student overall scores can be reported as I will explain further later.
And these are the measures that can also be used for federal reporting.
However, there are some cons and drawbacks that I will share on the next slide.
So in adopting the proposed revised blueprints, there is still potential risks of exposure of
the items as in any given year. And there are scheduling and time impacts on LEAs for completing
the testing. And there are less, again, there are less details that will be reported at the student
level. Again, those claim scores will not be reported. And at this time, as Rachel mentioned,
it is unclear what student data results will be available until all the analysis and test
administrations have occurred or has been completed. So I would like to
go on to share the proposed revised blueprints with you.
So this table displays the recommended revised ELA blueprint. The total items by grade for the full
form in italics are provided for reference. The row, this row here, let me see if I can get my little
pointer again. So this row here, oh, sorry, maybe I won't tinker with that.
So after the italics full form items, you'll see the row that indicates the proposed revised
blueprint. And it has the claims under that. Claim one is reading, claim two is writing,
claim three is listening, claim four is research inquiry. There are other words used for these
claims, like areas or domains, depending on the assessment. But for the Smarter Balanced,
we call them claims for this purpose. And the proposed items per claim by grade underneath.
So the difference is that the computer adapted test items, right here,
goes from, in grades three through five, goes from 36 to 39 items to 20. And then six to eight,
and then we're maintaining the performance task in grades six through eight. It goes from 36 to
from 36 to 40 items to down to 22. And then in grade 11, it goes from 37 to 39 items to 22.
And then here is the recommended revised mathematics blueprint. Again, the full
form here is provided for reference. And then for the short form in grades three through five,
it goes from 31 to 34 items to 17. Maintaining the PT or performance task, grade six goes from
30 to 34 items down to 16 to 17. And then grade six, we have only grade 11, maintain the PT.
And then in grade 11, we have 33 to 36 items down to 18.
So that, having said that, I want to give you a little bit more context and information about
estimated testing times for Smarter Balanced summative assessments, because that is what we
use for our English language arts and mathematics summative assessments. And here I've provided the
estimated test times for the computer adapted tests, here for the full form, and what it would
be reduced to for the short form. Now we're keeping the performance task intact by grade,
and then by yellowing math, and then by both. And then what the full form total hours and minutes are
by grade or grade span, and then what the totals would be for the short form. So the last two
columns really show that comparison of estimated testing times for the full form and the short form.
And as you can see, there is significant time savings, especially at the upper grades,
because you're really saving like two hours of testing time there, an hour and 45 minutes there
in grades six through eight, and an hour and a half in the lower grades.
Okay, and then I want to share some background information about our other non-Smarter
Balanced CASP assessments and the estimated testing time. So with those, as I mentioned earlier,
we are not recommending changes to these non-Smarter Balanced CASP summative assessments,
as they really are already shorter, much shorter, as indicated in this table.
Okay, and then for the ALPAC, again, they're much shorter, like an hour. Of course, the upper grades
do have more, because there's more writing and reading assessments. But again, it's much
shorter than even the Smarter Balanced assessment. So the question is, so I wanted to bring some
context to the types of reporting that are on a student score report. Here I have an image of an
English language arts assessment for a student, and at the top of the student score report is where
the student's overall scale score and achievement level, right here, are reported along with the
school and the state average scale scores and achievement levels. So the bottom part here
are the claims, and the claims are the more granular reporting areas that are available on
the full form. But with the revised blueprint, the claims scores are not going to be reported
at the student level. So I just want to remind us that while summative assessments are useful
for districts and schools to identify general areas of improvement, they're really not meant
to be diagnostic. So as Rachel mentioned earlier, using multiple measures that include diagnostic,
formative, and interim assessments or benchmarks can provide a more holistic picture of the
individual student's academic progress. So the removal of the claims scores from the student
score report could be considered a reasonable trade-off, given the multiple opportunities to
collect other rich student level data throughout the year. And with the performance tasks intact,
we will be able to provide writing trait scores at the individual and group level. So this image
provides a summary of writing trait scores by the categories of evidence or elaboration,
organization and purpose, and conventions through the California educator reporting system.
At the group level, in terms of scores at the group level, they can still be reported by mean
scale scores and achievement levels, such as this sample English language arts summary public report,
right? We can still do the scale scores here, sorry, a little too fast. The mean scale scores
here, and then the performance, the achievement levels by each level here as an example.
And although the claims or the areas cannot be reported at the student level, at the group level,
we can still provide that. So furthermore, these scores at the group level can be reported by
claim, such as our reading, writing, listening, research or inquiry. Again, this is from our
ELA summary public report by grade.
So the proposed, our proposed timeline for implementation is as follows. Currently,
the CDE has available under the CASP program, the California Alternate Assessment for Science
is already available since September 8th. And this is really the four performance tasks that
are administered close to instruction, they really have the entire school year to work on that.
So the regular, on January 12th, 2021 is when our other CASP assessments will be available.
This includes the California Science Tests or CASP, the California Alternates for English
Language Arts Mathematics, and the California Spanish Assessment. And then the summative
LPAC will open or launch on February 1st, 2021. And the revised blueprints are, if they should be
approved today, we anticipate that the CASP launch for the Smarter Balanced ELA Mathematics
tests will be available sometime in January, but we are being conservative with late February
as the latest they will be available. Right now, we, as Rachel mentioned earlier, we do have a lot
of unknowns. And what we do know is that we had a year without data in spring 2020. And this
really puts us on a path to the possibility of getting more information as a way to check on
the system. And once the summative testing window opens, the CDE will monitor the data along with
our contractor from the summative assessment throughout the whole entire window. And we will
provide updates on the availability and potential uses of the data as appropriate. So we are working
on guidance that will allow LEAs options and flexibility to meet the needs of their unique
contacts. So at this time, before I go to the second recommendation, I'd like to stop and see
if there are any questions about this first recommendation.
A member of Patel-Brownson has a question.
Talking to myself, I'm mute. Any clarification questions?
Yes. Please, Kim. Thank you. I just wanted to confirm
as to whether parents will be receiving these scores. Certainly in the context of my own
local district, I know parents watch these. And although they're not necessarily
used as a sole source diagnostic, I don't think anyone would propose that. It is oftentimes,
it's a feedback mechanism. And particularly in the context of COVID, and especially in the context
of the early years where parents are playing such an important supplemental role, especially
for early literacy and reading acquisition, it is a very helpful guide. So one, will parents receive
it? And then two, I pulled out my own kid's little scores that you can't see it here with the blue
screen. But will the scaled scores still be a part of the short order form that is provided so
you get, you know, the 2000 to 3000 range number that's there at the top of the screen that you
just had up and still have the child score, the school average, and the state average?
Yes, if everything goes according to plan and there are no
other natural disasters or emergencies of sorts, and we could fully implement this this spring,
you will still receive all the results at the very top. Your child score, the scale score,
and the school averages and the state averages. And also it'll tell you that the child's achievement
level as well. The only thing you're missing out is the domains here that roll up to be the total
score. Sorry, and I have one follow-up question. Because the domains or the claims are also very
helpful, I think, for parents who are trying to supplement and especially
catch up kids oftentimes over the summer when there's challenges. Has there been any conversation
about whether, for example, if the reliability of the data degrades because of the smaller
sample size of questions going to 50 percent? What I noticed, again, just looking at my own
kids scores, is that in the elementary school years, some of these claims are already collapsed.
So, for example, for my third and fifth grader, problem solving and modeling and data analysis
on the math are already combined. And does that potentially give us a mechanism by which to provide
more information to parents who want to actually do the supplemental work that's particularly needed
in the context of COVID? As you mentioned, this is really one source of data. So hopefully you have,
in terms of the reporting, if we go to the short form, we won't have those at the individual level.
But you could have your child's scale scores and achievement level to compare to how your school
did and how the state did overall. However, the reliability of the tests, Eric, are you here?
Okay, I will have Dr. Eric Zilbert come and share a little bit about the
reliability of the assessment going from a full form to a short form.
Let me just note that we have asked all districts in California to be using formative
assessment tools, diagnostic assessment tools, this fall. And that's actually been part of
their continuity planning, et cetera. So everyone should have more data about their child available
from other assessments the district is using. And we'll go to this discussion. I do want to
remind people that we're talking only about clarification questions right now. We still have
the rest of the item in public comment to go. So we'll take a brief discussion of reliability.
A couple other folks have clarifying questions and then we'll, I see you.
And we'll, but we will come back for full discussion. So go ahead.
Yeah, I was just going to say that the Smarter Balanced full forms have
all around .92. So that basically means that if you gave the test twice,
you'd have 92% agreement between the two tests. For the shorter form, those go down to about .88
or .87, depending on the grade and subject. So you can see you're getting a little bit more error,
a little bit less precision with the shorter form, but it should be adequate for reporting
scale scores and performance levels. Thank you very much. In the queue, I have
Ting, Patricia, and Matt. I think Matt was actually first on those list. And again,
let's keep it to clarifying questions, brief ones so that we can get through the rest of the item
and then we'll come back and have a full discussion. Matt? I'm good. I had a question
about parent communication. Kim covered it. Okay. And then we have Ting and then Patricia.
Mal, can you just clarify, you had mentioned that ED will not be entertaining any waivers
of assessments. Can you just clarify that means all the CASP, the entire CASP or just the Smarter
Balanced portions? No. So all the assessments that are required under ESSA, as I mentioned,
all those under CASP and LPAC are all required assessments under ESSA. Okay.
Let me just say, because we're getting a little into the other questions, that
this decision does not have to do with, is a separate decision from whether under a new
administration or under different pandemic conditions, we might ask for a waiver of
something having to do with assessment or accountability. This is a separate decision
about just the short form because we can cross that bridge if and when we get to it. Yeah,
that's fine. I just wanted to clarify so that we understand that we're talking about the
all of CASP and we talk about the federal requirements. And then my other question is,
for these two particular blueprints, they're part of Smarter Balanced. So does this or other
Smarter Balanced states also doing something similar to this? Well, they are exploring the
same options as we are. I believe that Hawaii already have approval on one of their short forms.
I just learned that they haven't implemented it, but they have approval on one of them.
So they're all in the same boat as we are. And a lot of times because we are so big,
many are kind of waiting to see what we do. I don't like to be first, but you know, sometimes
we just have to make the hard decisions. Right. Yeah. And I know that we share data and there's
some kind of data analysis within the consortium. So I was kind of curious if there's kind of some
consistency across the consortium on how they're handling the shortened form. Again, I want to ask
him quickly. Well, I'm sorry. I just see Tony Alpert sitting here and I thought maybe we would
ask him. Oh, yes. Tony, if he knows what's happening with the other states so that we
could get a quick answer. Yes, Madam President. So I think Mao described it accurately. The states
are looking at the blueprint options. The states voted on the blueprint that Mao has presented
to the board for its consideration. And then states have the option of using that blueprint
or using the full form or it is their option to deviate and use some other blueprint. But
given that this is one of the blueprints that Smarter Balanced has adopted, it would be a
blueprint that Smarter Balanced supports as part of its technical manual, its collection of validity
evidence and the data that it collects around it. Thank you. That was helpful. Okay. Patricia,
one more clarifying question and then we'll complete the item. Well, I'm glad I was last on
this because I did have a number of questions about the blueprint list itself. Could you go back to
the slide showing the difference in the number of assessment items? Because I do have a couple of
questions remaining. And then when we get to the general discussion, I'll ask the Smarter Balanced
logistical questions there. My first question is, I heard that there would be a difference
in the error that would be given. And first of all, let me just say, I found it amusing
when your colleague came up to the podium, the camera had to make an adjustment because he was
so much taller than you. I had a hard time not laughing about that, but that's separate. So I
did hear that there was a difference in error and that error is likely to increase with giving
the test. My next question is, so does the scale also change with the reduction of items
that are on this assessment if we go to this alternative blueprint?
Okay.
So I will have Tony, can you assist with that question?
Board member Rucker, so we do not plan on changing the scale and we will provide evidence
as part of the data collection that it is in fact a comparable use or comparable scale from
previous administrations. So that's an evidence that would be included as part of the technical
analysis. Okay. And then my last question is related to the depth of knowledge. With the
large number of assessment items on the full assessment, both for reading language arts and
math, there is a great deal of diversity or variability in the depth of knowledge required
for the students to explore and actually develop the answers for in their responses for these
questions. Could you go to the math blueprint? So I'm concerned when we look at the math blueprint
with the reduction of items, there would be one or one to two problem solving questions
and up to two modeling and data analysis questions. I'm especially concerned in
mathematics because this is the area that we have a statewide performance issue that mathematics
is almost uniformly the lowest test score that students are receiving across the grade levels
and grade spans that we're testing and across districts. And while the state does have separately
and a priority on providing a new professional development and new instructional support
to teachers to help increase the performance of students, I'm concerned about what the actual math
assessment is going to tell us if two of the areas where we're doing a lot of work to revise
the math framework really will not be well explored in this alternative assessment. And I
and I'm just raising the question knowing that this is just going to be a one-time thing,
but I'm not sure, Tony, on what the relative value of the math score will be given, you know,
what's actually going to be tested and we're not clear on what the depth of knowledge of those
questions are. So could we talk a little bit or think a little bit about giving guidance to the
LEAs about what this score will mean or what they should glean from the data they're going to get
from this score? Because I think that they're going, districts are going to need more help
with figuring this out even with the diagnostic work they should be doing with the formative
assessments. I'm not really sure they're going to know what to do with this information knowing
that there was only one or two items on what is proving to be some of their most difficult
instructional areas. I hope that question makes sense. Yeah, I think we're getting into the
discussion now. It's a great question. I don't know if there's a quick answer
now and then we can delve back into it when we get to discussion.
If I'm really about the depth of knowledge, really respond to the depth of knowledge.
We can get to the detail of the other part of the question, but I really
don't want to understand what would be the depth of knowledge.
So the depth of knowledge for problem solving and data analysis is really addressed principally
for math in the performance tasks. And so those were retained. And in the aggregate, I think that
the power of the summative assessment, even in the shortened form, is retained. And to at least
start at your question, Smarter Balanced acknowledges and I personally acknowledge our need
to augment and support the interpretation of the results in a new way and for a variety of reasons,
not just due to the shortened blueprint, but because of all the context of the data
that has to be taken into consideration. I certainly appreciate your response to that.
Thank you so very much. Great. Thank you.
Seeing no other clarifying questions now, why don't you go ahead with the rest of the item?
Okay. Thank you. So as you know, the development, as I mentioned earlier,
the development of the alternate LPAC has been ongoing. And the initial, the development,
the initial and summative alternate LPAC student score reports is the most recent step
in that process. So let's begin. It really began last spring. So the work began with two
parent focus groups, one in April and one in May. And the participants were provided with a sample
alternate LPAC student score report, translated into Spanish and Mandarin and asked to provide
feedback on its readability and usability. And these parents at least have at least one English
learner student with an individualized education plan, education program. So for the first meeting,
we focused on Spanish speaking parents and guardians because Spanish is the language
that is most common for English learners with the significant cognitive disabilities.
And for the second meeting, we included Mandarin speaking parents and guardians and provided feedback
and collected feedback from them as well. Then in July, a focus group was conducted with
representatives from a number of California stakeholder groups to provide feedback on the
design elements of the alternate LPAC student score reports, ability to communicate the results
to parents, students and guardians. And some of these stakeholder groups included the Small School
District Association, the Association of California School Administrators, the California School
Boards Association, the California Teachers Association, the California Federation of Teachers,
the California County Superintendent's Educational Services Association, and the California Science
Teachers Association. So having the feedback collected from the focus groups, the first component
was to make sure that the graphics would contribute to the test results being easy to understand.
And the next component was to make sure that terminology and language would be clear and
understandable to parents and guardians. And then the student score report also needed to identify
the skills that are needed to help the child progress along with an explanation of the child's
abilities. And the last component was that from the parents and guardians and stakeholders,
they recommended including links to sample test questions and available resources. So all in all,
the feedback was good and provided us with the ability to bring forward the alternate
LPAC student score reports that meet the feedback from these focus groups.
So the alternate LPAC SSR details
that once approved, these student score reports will become available for both,
for use for both the initial alternate LPAC and the summative alternate LPAC,
which are planned to be operational starting in July 2020. They will be available in five languages,
English, Spanish, Mandarin, Vietnamese, and Filipino. And finally, these student score
reports will provide universal access to the information for persons
with visual impairments through text-to-speech applications.
So this screenshot displays the front side of the initial alternate LPAC
student score report. The pop-out image displays the overall score and the proficiency level.
And this is the backside of the report. The pop-out displays the descriptions of the three
different proficiency levels that are reported by the initial alternate LPAC.
And then here's the proposed summative alternate LPAC student score report
front side. And the pop-out image displays the overall score and the proficiency level.
And then on the back, it shows the, the pop-out here displays the overall score,
the proficiency level, and a comparison to previous years, if available.
So I'm nearing the end. So just to recap, the CDE's recommendations for the California State
Board of Education are to approve the proposed revisions to the Smarter Balanced
Summative Assessments for English Language Arts, Literacy or ELA, and Mathematics Blueprints,
as described in Tables 2 and 4 in order to allow for short test forms. And the, and approve the
proposed student score reports for the initial and summative alternate LPAC or English Language
Proficiency Assessments for California, as described in Attachment 2.
Linda, I'm sorry. I think you're on mute.
I've been talking to myself on mute way too much. We're going to open the phone line for
public comments. So we want to get the slide up for public comment queue.
Members of the public wishing to provide comment on this item may do so by calling the phone number
and using the access code on that slide. And while we're waiting for members of the public
to call in, I want to ask Linda's son if she has any initial comments before I add mine,
and then we'll move to the public comment. Yeah, I just wanted to say that I think it
is really important that we have this conversation around the summative assessments
that we're looking at for the spring of this year. As Deputy Superintendent Maeve said
in her introductory remarks, that we don't know what the spring will bring us and what it will
take. We need to start working on preparing for whatever it might be. So I think this would be
the first step in looking at a shortened blueprint for the summative assessments.
Yeah, and I'll just echo Ting's comments and note again that
this gives us an option we may need, and it has to get started now if we're going to have that
option. But there will be much unpredictable in the coming months. And so there, I want to be
clear that if there are questions, as I've heard many about things like waivers that might pertain
to assessment or accountability to various tests, et cetera, of those we will not be taking up right
this minute. This is really just about these items because they are timely and necessary at this
moment. And we will continue to be responsive to the environment around us as we need to be beyond
this. And with that, I think we can open it up for public comment. Is there any public comment?
Yes, we currently we have four callers in the queue. And first caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. This is Edgar Sotsueta on behalf of the Association of California School
Administrators. I just wanted to state that we support the recommendation. We think it strikes
the right balance on ensuring health and safety of our students and staff while also allowing us to
get some information and data that will enable us to support our students from an academic standpoint.
We do have two requests from the state. One is that the state takes the lead on the communications
front. Our members, our school leaders are going to be the ones who are going to have to explain
to parents the changes and why we're making these changes. So just getting some uniform
communications from the state would be helpful. And then two, as it's been stated, the system will
need support in implementation of the assessments, dealing on the issues of security, administrating
the assessments across the different modes of instruction, and then it's been stated just how
to use the data once we get that information. So thank you for the discussion and for the action
today. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time
starts now. Hello, I'm Dr. Ingrid Lines-Robertson, Chief of Learning and Accountability at Alameda
County Office of Education. On behalf of SESPA, the California County Superintendent's Education
Services Association, consisting of 58 county superintendents of schools, we appreciate the
California Department of Education for proposing revisions to the English Language Arts and
Mathematics Blueprint to allow for a short test form. The 58 counties look forward to working
with CDE in providing ongoing support to our districts and schools on implementation issues
given distance learning, such as the need for additional devices for at-home administration,
the need to provide video training in multiple languages for parents and families to be able to
administer the short test form at home, the need for teachers and parents to know that scores are
a reliable measure of student knowledge and understanding of state standards. SESPA is
committed to partnering with CDE in the best interest of students. Thank you caller. Next
caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Angela DeRamos and I am a fifth grade teacher representing California Teachers
Association. CTA appreciates the CDE's efforts to be prepared for a variety of scenarios given
COVID-19 this year. And while we understand why there are efforts to develop the short form for
the CASP and LPAC, CTA strongly implores the State Board of Education and the CDE to pursue
a waiver for the required administration of the CASP for the spring of 2015.
of the CASP for the spring of 2021. Given widespread inequities in student access to
technology and the internet, as well as concerns about validity and the comparability of any data
gathered in some statewide summative testing administered in this condition, because there are
unknown and uncontrollable conditions, conducting standardized testing in the spring of 2021 would
be documented to students and limited use to teachers, schools, and school districts.
CTA is supportive of the exclusion of the LPAC from the waiver,
since it's used to reclassify English learners. Thank you.
Thank you, caller. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time
starts now. Hi, I'm Robert Van Waring calling from Children Now. Thank you for bringing this
item to the board. Just wanted to raise a couple of issues to be considered as you make this
decision. Getting a better sense of how this test, would this test meet the needs
in the English learner reclassification process? Generally, the summative test is one of those
indicators, one of the four main indicators used in that reclassification decision. And then
thinking about what are the implications that this might have for the growth model that you'll
discuss in the next item? Would there be the ability to have a comparability at some point
on a student level basis between a short form result in spring 2021 with a long form result in
2022? Or will this lead to a further delay of the start of the growth model? And then finally,
to the extent that there may be a potential waiver in the future, really thinking about
how is the state head around learning loss in the state? Thank you. Thank you, caller.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. This is Liz Guillen with Public Advocates. I am speaking to the comments from the
LCFF Equity Coalition. I appreciate very much the presentation today and the acknowledgement
that so much is unknown. And also good to know that the department engaged in parent outreach.
And I'll urge the department to take the recommendations of those parents very seriously.
One question we have is how will the dashboard be modified to reflect the changes to the test?
And echoing the prior speaker's question, what will be the impact to the rollout of the student
growth model? Given the changes in the learning modes that students and their families are
experiencing in distance learning, we know that accommodations and assessments that address
students' needs, especially those with unique needs who are having the greatest struggles,
they need to be addressed head on. And we hope that the department, and we urge you to
urge the department to plan strongly for ensuring that this is done well and equitably. Thank you.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. This is Sarah Lilas, Executive Director for Teach Plus California.
We just wanted to share some thoughts as you consider moving forward with this recommendation
about the role of the state in doing this. And one to reinforce a point that Ms. Guillen just made
is how do we as a state ensure all students have an equitable and adequate testing environment?
And so we urge the department to dig even deeper into what we're learning from the administration
of the initial LPAC, where there are LEAs that are struggling with that, and where there could
be additional resources coming from the state. In addition, we urge you to think about how you,
again, as Mr. Sveta mentioned, how you communicate the rollout of these assessments with not only
educators, but families and students and the role of these moving forward. Thank you very much.
Thank you, caller. This concludes public comment. Thank you, callers.
Okay, now we're ready for discussion, and we'll try to get to the most meaningful questions as
quickly as we can. I do want to use the prerogative of the chair to ask the question that several
public comment callers did ask about the implications of the short form for the
growth model. I think that's something that everyone will want to know the answer to.
And I know that Dr. Vang has really been looking at the questions of how remote testing,
online testing, bringing kids into small groups, and other things may work. So if
you want to say a word about the variable strategies that might end up being activated,
that would be helpful, too. And others, please raise your hands, and I will watch for those in
the participants. Linda, that question was for me about how we implemented the LPAC.
Well, the first question is the implications for the growth model,
if we know those. And the second is just a brief word on what we're learning about
assessment in this online environment. Okay, so again, like I mentioned earlier,
we just don't know what kind of results we will get, right, because of the unknowns of students
taking the test. And so as we analyze the data, we can't really make a definitive answer
how it can be used for the growth model or anything else until we go through the process.
And should we, you know, learn that we need to decouple it from accountability
purposes, then we could do that at a later time when we have more information and data collected.
I'm not sure if Eric or Cindy is here, if either one of you want to add on to the accountability
questions. Sure, good afternoon. Cindy Kazanis, the Director of the Analysis,
Measurement, and Accountability Reporting Division. We are working directly with
Educational Testing Services on the growth model, as you all know, and you'll hear in the next item.
And so if anything, they are closely evaluating this as we move along. So should the board take
action today on shortening the form of the test, we will definitely be in continued contact with
them on how this would impact the growth model. So as we bring forward future considerations of
the growth model and the actual adoption in March, this will definitely be a part of that
conversation. So I think now is correct, it's too early, but it's definitely on our radar.
All right, I know that we have questions from Sue, Patricia, and Cynthia.
In that order? Yes, we'll do it in that order.
All right, thanks. So just a couple things. First, I just want to express my appreciation
to both Rachel and Mao for their presentation. As somebody who's been around testing for a long,
long time, when I saw this item, I thought it needed a lot of background information.
And I hope, especially for our new members, that providing the kind of background that Mao did
about the scope of the testing writ large and the time it takes for testing was helpful.
So again, thank you very much for doing that. But to that point, I guess I understand the
short-term need here to try to get on the road with blueprints that will shorten the test for
English language arts and mathematics. But as I look at the PowerPoint, and Mao, you might want
to put up one of the earlier slides about what, again, CASP entails, the umbrella of CASP,
it includes a lot of other assessments. And if one of our objectives here is to try to be
planning ahead and thinking about, because there are so many unknowns, should we also be looking
at some of these other assessments? And I think especially about CASP, the science assessment,
since that's rolling out relatively newly, is that something that we should be considerate of?
Because again, if one of our initial, our rationales is to try to reduce the amount of time
spent on testing, given all of the other demands that are on our educators at this time, I just
want to make sure that we're thinking about this whole issue in a broader context. And not just
because, and it's not just because, but I feel like we're trying to respond like we do a lot
of times to the feds, because we think the feds won't give us a waiver. I just want us to have
a broader discussion about assessment in the context in which we're trying to ask our educators
to operate. Thank you. Mao, did you want to speak to that? Yes, well, the science test is also required
under ESSA. That is not something that I could just recommend to reduce or take out. And with the
timing, it is already a much shorter test than the ELA. And at this point, we think the only
two that we could reduce in a meaningful way, in a timely way, is the ELA and the MAC,
or are the ELA and the MAC? I think the question of what we'll face in the spring and whether
there will be a change in administration, which we'll learn in the next few days, and what the
framework will be for thinking about spring testing will all become clearer in the coming
days and weeks than it is right now. But I think that's a really good question to keep in front of
us. Patricia, you're next, and then Cynthia, then Eileen. Well, thank you. I want to begin by saying
I agree wholeheartedly with what Board Member Burr just said, so I'm glad that I was called to
speak after her, because I was going to say many of the same things. The questions that I raised
during the technical part of the discussion about the scale and about the depth of knowledge and
how these would be comparable and fit overall into what's reported and evaluated by schools
and ultimately by parents was related to that concern. So I was heartened, and I'm very grateful
that Tony Alford is on the call today to be able to talk to and recognize that there is a need to
change not only what we're doing and how we are doing the assessments because of the circumstances
we're in, but how we discuss and report and analyze the results we're getting. So I'm glad to know
that that conversation is on the table. But again, I want to reiterate what Board Member Burr said
for the purposes of what we are trying to do as a board and the policy that we're trying to create
and a focus on continuous improvement and in particular with what we're trying to do in
addressing our statewide concern about the performance of students in math and what their
math learning actually is. I think this conversation about assessment is taking on a greater context
in that overall big picture. So I will leave it there. Okay, thank you. Cynthia.
Thank you. I first would like to say again, and it's kind of been said already before,
that it is really important that this type of decision is looked at at this time in case
it is needed. To be able to implement spring testing administration at any point in time
always requires a lot of logistics on the behalf of school districts and schools. And if that is
going to indeed need to happen this spring, especially in light of the fact that students
are primarily in a distance learning environment and may be transitioning after the winter breaks
into perhaps a hybrid type of model. There are a lot of logistical decisions
that need to be made. So I'm very happy that we are looking at this at this point in time
and really keeping that in mind for everyone in the field. As we move forward, if it is determined
and if the board does vote to utilize the more reduced size blueprint for spring administration,
it is going to be very important that we look at some guidance that can come from CDE regarding
communication of the shortened format and what that means. Perhaps even a communications toolkit
that LEAs can then use to communicate at their local level to their stakeholders.
A uniform communication will be really important with this particular change.
The other aspect of consideration where I think there may need to be again some guidance that
again LEAs can use at their local context is in regards to various administration models.
If this is going to be, spring testing is going to take place in a mode that is very different
from what we've done before and that's what we are anticipating. To have again some type of
guidance document on models that can be utilized in different situations for schools that are smaller,
schools that are larger, elementary, middle, high school. That I also feel will be very helpful
for those in the field as they make decisions about how to go about ensuring students have
a spring testing environment that will best set them up for success.
It's really important if I could just note that some places are operating with very strong
bandwidth and internet capacity, others not. It's very hard for kids to get through long
assignments on Zoom. Some places are in person, others are not. Some places are bringing students
back in small groups. That might even be the context for assessment in some places in the spring.
So having an assessment that can be managed in all of those different contexts in a reasonable way
way is important to consider and then of course the guidance about how contingencies in different
circumstances might be handled will be helpful. Eileen? Well, I just want to build on previous
all the board members comments so far. I appreciate the advanced planning. I know we have to do it
this month and if we want to be ready for spring testing. I think the issues about access to
bandwidth. I just think about the stories of advanced placement students who took a short
form and then couldn't upload their exam and then they had to retake it again and all the anxiety.
So I do and I know that we're continuing to work on this but whether it will be in remote which
has its own challenges or in small group in person, we've never given these tests remotely
before. I appreciate the short form and I appreciate the desire to align and to get some
good data feedback on where our students are but I realize that as we look forward and we don't
know what spring will look like in our schools. I know we're all hoping students will be back at
least some of the time. I'm assuming that the guidance from CD will include the settings and
the options that we will have to administer to get valid and reliable and also to give students
a fair chance to show what they know without being cut off the bandwidth or having unable to
upload an answer. So I just think it's complicated. I appreciate the advanced planning so that we're
ready in case we have to do this but I do believe we need some clear benchmark of where our students
are but I don't want to overly complicate and make it frustrating for them in the challenges
that we're facing right now with remote and hybrid learning. I think that's a good point at which to
I don't see any other hands up for discussion so I think this is the moment where we ask for a motion
to have a motion regarding the CDE recommendations. A motion. Matt, thank you.
We have a motion. We have a second. Any further discussion? I'll ask Brooks to call the roll.
Member Burr. Aye. President Darlene Hammond. Aye. Member Fatah. Aye. Member Glover-Woods. Aye.
Member McQuillan. Yes. Member Navo. Aye. Member Patil-Brownson. Aye. Member Rodriguez.
Aye. Member Rucker. Yes. Vice President Strauss. Aye. Member Sun. Aye. It's unanimous.
All right. Thank you very much, Mal. We appreciate the presentation. We have earned ourselves a lunch time.
It's 1240. We'll come back in a half an hour at 1 10. See you then. Thank you. I think you want to
leave. Stay in the meeting but stop your video and put yourself on mute.
We're going to reestablish a quorum so Brooks is going to call the roll.
Member Burr. Here. President Darlene Hammond. Here. Member Fatah.
Here. Member Glover-Woods. Here. Member McQuillan.
Here. Member Navo. Here. Member Patil-Brownson. Here. Member Rodriguez. Here. Member Rucker.
Present. Vice President Strauss. Here. Member Sun. Here. Thank you.
Okay. So we're going to start now with agenda item number five. This is an update on the
implementation of the integrated local state and federal accountability and continuous improvement
system. The recommended action on revisions to the student growth model and reporting
recommendations of the California advisory task force on alternative schools. And I'm going to
this item will be presented by Cindy Kazanis from the CDE. Dr. Jorge Ruiz de Velasco of the
California advisory task force on alternative schools. Diana Walsh-Royce of the Riverside County
Office of Education. And Mike Ilic of the Corona Norco Unified School District. We'll start with
Cindy. Please begin. Thank you. Good afternoon. I'm Cindy Kazanis, the Director of the Analysis,
Measurement and Accountability Reporting Division. Very excited to present item five to you this
afternoon. We have a couple of attachments we're going to walk through today and we're going to do
them out of order. We'll take clarifying questions after each of the attachments from board members
before moving to public comment at the very end. So first just to clarify what the board action is,
the Department of Education recommends that the State Board of Education first confirm that the
Empirical Best Linear Prediction or EBLIP model will only be used, will only use the same subject
area when modeling student growth and number two maintain the current student level methodology
which holds the same expectation for growth and for all student groups and allows comparisons of
student group data. So with that we're going to start with attachment two and I'm going to
briefly introduce this piece of the presentation to you. This is a review of a partnership and
really the culmination of a report that was prepared under direction of Dr. Jorge Luis de Velasco
who is at the Gardner Center for Youth and their Communities at Stanford University. Jorge was
introduced to us back in 2017 by then President Kirst and what a relationship this has become.
We have unlike any other subject area that we've participated in we had the benefit from this of
Dr. Luis de Velasco's just extensive national knowledge California specific knowledge of our
alternative schools population. In addition he was able to really persuade I think some of the top
experts on practitioners in the field of alternative education to participate in this in this task force
and accordingly what the department gained from it was such a great capacity and knowledge of
students and practices of our most vulnerable schools and also students. In doing so I have
to say we learned from a variety of folks on this all the way from our county offices of education
the advisory commission on special education weighed in for our most vulnerable students
with disabilities to the to another end of the spectrum where you have charter schools who really
focus on credit recovery which is very unique population and so we had just a wide range of
voices we've learned a tremendous amount as you can see in this report which again is a culmination
of this work but finally I wanted to just mention as in my opening remarks is that we've raised the
profile of these students the words DAS now means something folks know that are in education
community and look at educational data we've added this to our standing reports on our website for
data quest the an actual filter for alternative schools and so really the lexicon and mission
I think has far exceeded what we thought it was going to do about four years ago so with that I'd
like to turn it over to Dr. Luis de Velasco to begin the conversation and really introduce you
to the work of this group and you're going to hear from two very practiced practitioners
in this area to talk through what we've been doing and where we're headed
Jorge yes
I'm happy to be here all right well first of all thank you Cindy I've given me an introduction
that's going to be a little bit hard to live up to but I really appreciate it and a Valentine
to the state board from the task force in so far as this work is already in progress at the CDE
the development of the dashboard and the implementation of of measures and two things
that are really really have already caused a good deal of positive system change is the
implementation of the one-year graduation rate this kind of change is going to this change in
the indicator metric is will be will generate relevant and more actionable information for
system leaders about one of the core functions of the alternative schools which is to get kids a
second chance to a standard diploma the the other the other thing that that the task force has
been very uniformly happy about is the work that Cindy and the department and the state
board has been doing to add new and collect more information about the college and career
readiness indicator this is important not just for accountability purposes but by adding these
indicators and lifting them up in the system it's encouraging school and district leaders to put
more of these opportunities in alternative schools the creation of the collection of data on
completing state and federal jobs or pre-apprenticeships or student-led enterprises
will not only create more opportunities for young people to connect to work and further
education and to the diploma but is going to support the and has been implementing the support
of cte pathway programs and integrated studies integrated courses of study in alternative schools
and we're already seeing places like oakland and san bernardino and los angeles pave the way
for this in their alternative schools i want to use just my remaining time to to to do to talk
about two points before i hand it over to my my co-presenters mike and diana one is in the report
there is the the next stage of work is to articulate something on the dashboard that would
be an important local indicator and one of those the task force thought was super important was
the creation of of a positive transition rate this rate would measure the percent of those students
who age out of of alternative schools or otherwise leave alternative schools without a diploma
we know from our data and from data that the cde has run for the for the task force
that anywhere from that an average of 60 percent of seniors in alternative schools actually wind up
graduating by the end of but what happens to the rest there many of those many kids
which is it's a good indicator but many kids wind up aging out of the system or otherwise
leaving and many of these kids tend to be foster youth english learners late entering immigrants
expelled or incarcerated youth that have re-entered the system that are aging out
and alternative schools do an important job of making sure that they don't exit to the street
that they exit to positive transitions like for example exiting to to work programs like
youth build that allow them to continue their path to a high school diploma to community college
programs to adult education and to the growing number of charter schools that help with credit
recovery adding this kind of indicator would honor student persistence in in persisting in
their education beyond the k-12 system where they are they're turning 19 20 and 21 and it would
also honor the schools and the principals and teachers who put the shoulder to the wheel to
make sure that all their kids are either getting a diploma or if they're aging out that they're
making positive transitions to continued education or work and education we know the system the way
it's currently designed signals that these kids are either system failures or losers and but we
know that in many schools 80 90 percent of them are actually making positive transitions and we
should measure that to know what schools are doing a good job of it and not because we know it makes
a big difference whether they make those kinds of transitions or exit to the street two other points
that are related is the continuation schools still make up the lion's share and students in the lion
sheriff of secondary school students and alternative ed right now as an artifact of an
anachronism of an anachronism of history those schools continuation schools are limited to 15
hours of of capture for apportionment rate which is half of the 30 hours per week that traditional
high schools get this is a the and the fact is though that most districts continue to offer a
full day of programming and they have to pull that money out of their general funds
because they're not treated the same and this is an artifact of the 1950s and it signals that
for many that the system has given up on the six percent of secondary school students in these
schools and that those students don't merit the same level at least of investment as students in
those traditional schools that failed them in the first place it's something that that needs to be
fixed the other one is and i i'm hopeful that diana and mike will put a little more meat on this
but we also know that and the system will generate better information about the disproportionate
number of these alternative schools that wind up in the bottom five percent of performance
right now we do not have either at the cde or in any of the counties or in any other intermediary
a locus for best practices and for providing technical assistance and targeted assistance to
these leaders of schools in alternative settings that is appropriate to their setting and that
would really incentivize continuous learning and improvement it is a big gap in our technical
assistance ability to to improve make system improvement particularly for for schools at the
at the lowest end of performance i'm going to stop there and i'm going to hand it over to
mike illic who is the administrative director for instructional support at corona norco unified
school district and also a leader in access and options council mike good afternoon it's nice to be
um i would uh i would like to just uh tail tail off of uh of what or he was talking about
and because we do have the uh the new accountability system we have to have the staff
that's going to be able to implement uh implement uh programs and procedures that would that would
be successful for those schools and not necessarily end up at the bottom of the heap
and not necessarily end up at the bottom of the heap and and what i'm talking about is is the
the principal the principal is is is it has to provide effective leadership that is essential
in schools so those principles they need to be they need to be at those alternative schools
because they want to be there and not because they're at the tail end of their um career in
some assistant principal role at some other site and this is given to them as a as a as a reward
for graduate or for um for uh retirement same thing graduation retirement but anyway so um
it so that that is a critical piece in that and then having that principal who sets the tone
who impacts the school climate and student learning to be able to hire their own teachers
and and so that those teachers are there for the specific reason of teaching these kids
now getting a a teacher from a traditional site doesn't work they don't understand the student
they don't they don't understand that piece because it's more than just the just delivering
curriculum it's about meeting the student where they are and working with those issues and breaking
down the barrier so that that student uh can can access the curriculum so giving giving
principals autonomy is very very very important and we've seen in the past where that that hasn't
happened and it's still it still doesn't happen but those schools that do very well have strong
school leadership strong strong teachers and you know i've been on on many continuation school
model continuation school visits and where the kids say this is like family this school is like
family students are engaged they want to come to school because of the the uh the adult presence
there that want to be there so i just i just really want to uh emphasize that because we've
seen in data that there's issues with equity you know justice student achievement and and students
are overrepresented in certain areas either with african-american hispanic special education
which is a more restrictive environment so those those things are really really important
also usually there is a district person that oversees of the the alternative school and they
don't understand necessarily what what happens in those schools and i think it's really important
if those schools are given assistance because they're they're in the bottom in the bottom rung
that i think the uh i believe that the district person who oversees it needs to be a part of that
of that assistance so that they understand what is necessary for the school to be uh to be
successful and to and to do the right thing for their kids the for so long we've moved um our
ineffective teachers more our most at-risk teachers to teach our most at-risk kids and that's
quite simply malpractice we want our at-risk kids to be at promise kids and for that we need the
people on on the uh in the schools to be able to do that and uh and those those folks are integral
part in having the students move a transition uh transfer to the alternative school from the
traditional school when necessary and to have all partners parents district office sending school
receiving school all on the same page following best practice to do to do this work so that's
that's what i wanted to share uh from my from my end and i would like to introduce diana walsh
royce from uh riverside county office of ed the retired associate superintendent
good afternoon president darling hammon superintendent thurman and esteemed members of the board and
and colleagues and guests it's an honor to be here with you today i hope that you're doing well
during these unprecedented uncertain times in my role at at the county office of education
i serve students in the juvenile court and community schools a re-engagement charter adult
jail programs special and in migrant education i also served as the past chair for the student
programs and services steering committee under the umbrella of the county office superintendent's
organization currently i serve as a was commissioner and continue to work with schools and districts
um as i said it's an honor to be with you today and even more of an honor to be a part of the
development of the das alternative accountability model in 2017 a group came to you about the need
for relevant transparent accountability system with measures that are appropriate for students
in alternative settings you've listened and you approved and that this work has moved forward
so thank you so much for for that das has allowed alternative programs to enter the realm of
accountability using metrics that are more applicable to the students we serve the importance
of this can't be overstated in the past models lacked rigor and appropriateness alternative schools
can now visibly demonstrate their significant role to the to the value added in our school community
as a result i believe that many alternative schools are undergoing a transformation through
improved instructional practices rigorous relevant curriculum individualized student-centered
practices using research based holistic approaches and this dedication has led to thousands of
students graduating from high school and realizing their dream for a better life
das provides meaningful data to drive student learning growth and achievement and it emphasizes
the importance of sharing this information with key stakeholders data on steroids as one of my
colleagues said is a very valuable commodity most importantly data can help identify root causes
that create barriers for students and this can lead to early intervention
and earlier intervention is absolutely essential there may be a day sometime in the future if we're
able to use early warning systems and early intervention to catch kids early where we won't
need as many alternative schools i think it's essential that we continue to support schools
and districts in using all facets of data and cde does an excellent job of this with kelp had
support in addition many county offices provide intensive support through networks trainings
and systems of support led by geographic leads i was fortunate to be part of a county office
where das accountability updates were provided with follow-through support networks implemented
and target assistance provided in other words differentiating support to focus specifically
on das schools in addition as cindy mentioned the selfa system improvement leads have also made
great strides in data informed practices for programs serving students with disabilities
das has also incentivized the use of high impact strategies to creatively and innovatively
ensure that our students graduate from college and career ready and grow academically and socially
keeping in mind that building positive relationships and trust with students is foundational
foundational many alternative schools have worked to increase their rigor by adding a to g
course offerings they have achieved wasp accreditation however we know that many of
the students arrive to our schools with gaps in their education and are credit deficient
there's a need to continually build capacity to address the academic and programmatic needs of
our students it's really all about continuous improvement and there are many outstanding
organizations that have been mentioned in networks that focus on best practices but many times these
organizations work in isolation but student programs and services steering committee the
accent ed options the gardener center and numerous non-profits have created a repository of best
practices but there's a need to lift up these evidence-based practices with a designated
lead for more coordination among all of these groups there are many outstanding practices
that schools scattered throughout pockets of the state and cde recognizes some of these schools
through model continuation schools but this recognition doesn't expand to other schools
such as opportunity community or court schools i believe there might be value in recognizing
these schools as well and and the final point that i would like to make is that many students
in alternative settings are served by multiple agencies such as probation social services
mental health the district attorney's office community colleges and and many more and alternative
schools leverage these key partnerships to support students social emotional and academic growth
but there's a need to foster a coherent integrated system of support among agencies
breaking down silos for unprecedented collaboration getting in the way of this collaboration
our policies lack of data sharing separate funding streams and just the bureaucracy of
large organizations we need to look to streamline services and work together with our sister
and brother agencies for seamless services and then finally i want to take a moment to acknowledge
california department of education cindy kazanis and jenny singh and their team and dr de la vasco
and milbury mclaughlin from the gardener center at stanford for their vital leadership
in creating a system that truly captures and reflects the strengths of our students i also
want to give a shout out to the 22 members of the task force we worked with a true spirit of
collaboration had many rich spirited discussions but passion always drove our work and lastly i
want to take a moment to acknowledge and express gratitude for those educators who work directly
with our students in alternative settings each and every day they do the heavy lifting we take
great pride in our work with the most vulnerable students and believe that we continue to make
great progress to help them achieve learn and thrive and i know there's so much going on in
the world today with so many challenges and urgent needs but those challenges also have
a silver lining to create better opportunities to serve our students so thank you so much again for
the opportunity to speak today thank you so at this time i just wanted to touch base briefly on
on next steps for this ongoing work this of course this this report is a culmination of
four years of work but you have also been a part of this work as the state board in taking action
on things that affect our alternative schools each year so we've been able to develop out
not only the alternative school system the DAS system we've made corrections where we've needed
so we've had continuous improvement in the system we will bring back to you in march as we do every
march our work plan for the year and we will make every effort to include part of the recommendations
of this task force where appropriate in that work plan so with that i wanted to open up for
any clarifying questions at this time and i'll turn it back over to president darlene hammon for that
yeah all right i'm gonna start off by just thanking this team and Jorge i remember when
you started this work so many years ago it's wonderful to see it shaping state policy as
well as practice in these directions really really really appreciate you and your colleagues
giving us this very both hopeful and useful for our future thinking
um type of briefing are there any other clarifying questions for this team before
we go on to the next item all right so uh please proceed thank you so with that i'm going to turn
it over to my colleague jenny sing who you see often associated with the growth model and she's
going to walk you through the two part recommendation that we have for you today
good afternoon everyone so i am in charge of um giving you the information that we've prepared
in attachment one the analysis and recommendations for the parameters of our growth model
so this is coming in we have two pieces in here so the first piece
we're going to talk about is how to use the use of same subject test scores in the empirical best
linear prediction model or e blip and um we're coming back to you um regarding this because
we've decided to do a slight shift in our business rules for the e blip model and we want to make
sure that the board is comfortable with that shift and because when we come back in march for an
approval we don't want people to be surprised no surprises i'm done with surprises so remember
that the e blip methodology actually takes the data from the residual gain scores and rolls it
up and aggregates it up and i just wanted to remind everyone that in february we will be
doing a memo and the memo will have a full report of everything we've done regarding the new growth
model and it will have all the data in there for all the student groups all race the ethnicity
groups and all program groups so that's el's homeless students with disabilities and foster youth
so at the september board meeting ets and cde staff presented an update on the student level
growth model and we shared information about the e blip again the e blip is just a methodology for
aggregating up the scores the rg scores and in that we indicated that we were using multiple
years of aggregate growth information this was going to improve the accuracy and stability
of district school and student group growth scores and of course it did a much better
job at improving the accuracy and stability for smaller end sizes
so
we also indicated that we were using multiple subjects for each of the growth scores so for
the ela district school and student group growth scores we would use a weighted average
from both prior english language arts ela and mathematics assessments of course most of the
weight going to ela but some going to mathematics as well that's true for the mathematics so for
us for the math growth scores district school and student group we would use a weighted average
with scores from both prior english language arts and math and here of course the greater weight
would go towards mathematics so during the presentation nobody raised any questions or
asked any questions about this but after the meeting there were some concerns that were raised
about the challenges of communicating the e blip scores to schools and districts using multiple
subjects in the calculation so we had a couple of conversations with ets staff and we thought
that that was a really valid point and we thought well we should make the shift to use the single
subject only and one of the reasons we can do this of course is because with the residual gain
model the calculations at the student level already include prior year scores in both ela and math
now that decision was made based on the data from ets and a recommendation by the tdg in 2017
and just to be sure we went back to the tdg had a conversation and they said yes we want to keep
both subjects for the residual gain score in order to improve the validity of the score
the accuracy of it and then of course in may of 2018 the board approved this methodology
so restricting the e blip aggregate scores to only include prior year data from the same subject
will help with communication to the field it does not significantly change the gross score results
and it will not affect the current timeline that we have of delivering this product by april of 2021
okay on to recommendation number two to maintain the current student level methodology
and not to incorporate student characteristics in our growth model
so i'm going to start by going back to 2017 where i know we have some members of the board who
weren't there at the time but in 2017 the board discussed the criteria that we should use in the
selection of a student growth model and based on that discussion it was clear that they did not
want to include student characteristics such as race social economic status or language status
or language status into the calculation formula for growth model
and so why did that why was that decision made because when you do include characteristics
demographics or other variables it does change growth expectations and results
for each student because it's impacting the residual gain score it eliminates the ability
to compare results across student groups so you would no longer be able to compare
the results from students with disabilities to foster or homeless
and it eliminates any measurement of the achievement gap so we don't know if the
achievement gap is getting wider or if it's closing and that was a very important point for the board
so we shared this we had quite a few conversations with the stakeholder group the growth model
stakeholder group and one of the conversations was about demographics and so we did talk a lot about
growth models and what questions that they can answer so when you're looking at growth
really what you want to do is to look at how much did students learn over the last school year
that is one of the big purposes that we wanted to reach and that the stakeholder groups wanted
and so in order to do that you can't include demographics
because that doesn't determine that doesn't tell you how much growth they want to do
because that doesn't determine that doesn't tell you how much growth they've had you've adjusted the
scores and we did talk about putting in demographics but the question that that answers
is how much did students learn over the last year compared to other students with similar personal
family and community backgrounds
so that answers a very different question
so at the september 2020 meeting we received a letter that included a report from dr pete goldsmith
and the report outlined a suggestion to include the english language proficiency assessment
for california lpac achievement levels in the student growth calculation for english learners
and at the meeting we were asked to investigate
whether this is something that we would want to consider
so cde convened a meeting with dr goldsmith along with sb staff ets staff and two members of the
tdg we had some technical questions we wanted to make sure we had the right people at the meeting
dr goldsmith was very kind gave us an hour of his time we had a really great conversation
and we did come to the conclusion of consensus that is adding lpac levels would not allow
for meaningful comparison between eels and all other student groups and that's really important
because if we're going to put the growth model into the dashboard when people come to the dashboard
they come thinking that they're they can compare student groups and they would not be able to
determine that they couldn't compare them on the academic indicator because they would not know
that those results reflected different metrics
we also reached out to californians together we had a meeting with them
to talk about the conversation we had with dr goldsmith and they understood why we didn't
want to go down this road and dr goldsmith did say it was not his intent to slow down the progress
of the growth model but he just wanted to bring our attention to the fact that the lpac scores
shown along with smarter balance scores was really an important thing
so we thought that that was probably a really good idea and it could be useful to schools and
districts so we did commit to coming up with some kind of report where you could see the results
of the cast scores by english language by the lpac levels i wanted to be very transparent
transparent i did say that that's work we cannot do right now we're really busy with the growth
model but that that would be one of the next big things that we took on and dr goldsmith
seemed to be okay with that and and it seemed like when we had our conversations with
members of california together they were supportive of that as well
so with that i will take any clarifying questions
thank you very much jenny are there clarifying questions and thanks by the way for following
up and you know finding out more about that proposal and really digging in on it both
intellectually and with the stakeholder groups and with dr goldsmith himself so much appreciated
i think you gave a clear rendering of the issues patricia do you want to ask a clarifying question
and then i think i saw one other hand go up matt first of all i also want to thank you and the staff
for the tremendous amount of work that it took to follow up on this request i was the board member
who made the request to look at the report and the recommendation or suggestion that came from
dr goldsmith so i truly do appreciate the investigation and the research that was done
i'm looking here at the slide that you have concerning looking at options for breaking down
the data when you use that term of art breaking down the data you're talking about
disaggregating the information in particular ways as well as giving a larger group kind of report
or is that or are you looking at doing something different well there's multiple options that we
have for displaying lpac levels with calf scores so we're looking at that and there was also a
request to do a breakout of english learners versus rfp students so we're looking at that as well
so those okay okay uh again i certainly appreciate that and i appreciate that
pat we've lost your sound
oh well we hope you got it in what you uh wanted to say
uh i don't see any other hands up for clarifying questions
so um cindy is that the last part of the item i just wanted to add that you know when we're
going to report out the data the lpac data levels with the cast and break them out by ela and
rfp that's consistent with how we're reporting the academic indicator on the dashboard we do
break that information out so that people have access to it if they want it okay so is this the
point then at which we want to get the public comment slide up cindy yes so just to to close
out this item i just wanted to let you know that in the midst of the pandemic and working remotely
we continue to provide technical assistance to the field and stakeholder sessions and so
just wanted to highlight that information in this last slide and i will just briefly show you the
board action before you before moving over to the public comment slide that was very brief
but we all have it in our documents thank you at this point i want to encourage people to call in
for public comment by calling the number on that slide and entering the access code and while we're
waiting for members of the public to call in i want to first ask member burr and then vice
president spouse if they have any initial comments for us now i would just say i also
expressed my appreciation to to cindy and jenny and the whole team for following up both on the
residual gain model because questions were raised about it as as jenny explained and also on the
concerns that were raised about whether or not to include lpec in the model so after public comment
i'd be happy to make a motion on the department's recommendation terrific thank you and vice president
strauss i just wanted to say that i just so appreciate the department working so hard
on the growth measure to continue to move us forward to get it right for us and to address
all the issues i do appreciate the clarification that cindy that jenny singh said about the
disaggregated data that will be available on all the different subgroups and to remind
our stakeholders and those watching that there will be ability to take a look at how the different
groups are doing and finally i just want to make a comment about the the das report and just so
appreciate the comments but i'm very um i i agree with what um of lascaux talked about
the giving us actionable data for students in alternative schools and also what um diana walsh
talked about about looking at options with the career indicator so that alternative schools
continue to provide workforce pathway options access to a to g so that students leave the
alternative setting with pure options successful options for post-secondary achievement so i i
really feel like the work is really i'm going to strengthen our work because when you have those
on the college and career indicator it does help districts focus and schools focus on offering
those opportunities yeah thank you that's a really good point and patricia i see that your
hand is up did you want to try again to ask your clarifying question or finish it
oh we're not hearing you i'm so sorry oh we thought we had solved your technology problems this week
something's going on okay i hope you can fix it can she type it in the chat box and then we can
take it in the chat it will come back around to it all right with that being said i think we are
ready then to go to public comment and are there any are there any public commenters
yes there are good afternoon caller please state your name and affiliation for the record your
time begins now good afternoon this is martin and this i am the executive director of california
together and former county and district administrator i first want to thank the
department for exploring the additional option of breaking down the data reports among the el
student group with respect to their alpac level in march in the march meeting of the state board
of education the california department of education presented a data run as an example
of the application of the proposed growth model for students with disabilities and homeless youth
the board requested data runs for the other students subgroups and so we continue to request
those data runs for all student groups including english learners with the l plus rfs and also of
course disaggregating the two core hosts before any final decisions are made on the growth model
design having this information is important to be able to see how best to use the new academic
indicator for identifying needs program instructional planning and al cap development
thank you very much
good afternoon caller please state your name and affiliation for the record your time begins now
now
good morning president darling hamman superintendent thurman and members of the board
my name is ruth borahus and i'm with californians together while it is great to hear today that the
cde will be looking at disaggregating the two cohorts of el's and our febs you know we believe
this information is gained you know will will that that we gain from this will warrant this effort
and we hope to see this before march having served as a school principal and an el specialist
at both title one schools and large populations with large populations of the el's and and also
schools of smaller populations um the where the growth target was very important and we need to
be addressed i can tell you after spending countless hours looking at data to drill down
to see how our el's were progressing or not we could have benefited greatly from this state
accountability system based on this growth model with special attention to these groups
if there and and if there is an absolute agreement that we cannot increase these
numbers of subgroups then we propose that the definition of the english runner subgroup
include the current el's and only the arklips who be classified in the second year after the data
thank you
okay
good afternoon caller please state your name and affiliation for the record your time begins now
good afternoon president darlin hamid superintendent thurman and members of the board
my name is crystal vias i was a former preschool teacher and i am here with
californians together initially the sbe and cde were concerned about the volatility of the data
comparing grade level to grade level that would include newcomers and rfps entering and exiting
yearly respectively resulting in an unstable group for analysis however with the growth model used
matching scores the group would be more stable and with less volatility we would suggest that el to
reclassify within the first year of data collection be included in the rfp group and those who
reclassify in the second or subsequent year to be included in the el subgroup thank you
good afternoon caller please state your name and affiliation for the record your time begins now
good afternoon president darlin hamid superintendent thurmond and members of the board
my name is ashley aguirre i am a former english learner student and i am here today with californians
together i'd like to add that using the same formula aggregating one year el data and four
year rf rf data and continuing to use the same methodology to determine performance levels
when there are clearly unintended negative consequences may be equal but it is not equitable
and is counter to the spirit of continuous improvement english learners who come to our
schools speaking a language other than english require a system of accountability that includes
an adjusted formula and methodology that uplifts their successes and highlights their needs
within the framework of the state accountability system thank you
good afternoon caller please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
hello it's eric premack with the charter schools development center good afternoon
president madam president and members i support the recommendation from staff with respect to
the e blip and how to handle that i would note however that with respect to the larger issue of
demographic adjustments i don't think the state should limit itself to a single model i support
single model i support the notion of the model that we're currently pursuing but i think that
we could also have a second growth metric that is demographically adjusted that would be
informative and in many cases more useful for high stakes decision making purposes and would
encourage you to pursue both thank you
good afternoon caller please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
good afternoon this is jessica saco with children now i want to thank the board for our thanks
uh the team for bringing this item forward today um as we have mentioned previously we strongly
encourage the board to take up in january which would be in January and we would like to thank
the board for providing us with the information that we would like to share with you about the
previously we strongly encourage the board to take up in January which would be the last
opportunity to do so before the march meeting where we're projecting a decision to be made
regarding the growth model particularly we'd like the board to discuss the use of and release of
individual student growth scores as well as a provide input on a robust communication plan
which would be critical to the successful implementation of and release of the data with
the growth model finally in regards to the alternative ed schools we find it to be a very
interesting idea to measure chronic absence which ranges at about 50 percent and it's likely the
most important measure and provide the most substantive information relative to the performance
of alternative school thank you
good afternoon caller please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
good afternoon board members this is Manuel Bonrostro with Californians Together and I am
calling to voice uh support for for the for the for the state to conduct data runs on aggregated
scores of English learners and RFEPs and separately for ELs and RFEPs with color
performance levels at this point in time we are not requesting any changes to the definition
but ask that these runs be conducted so that we can better understand the impact for program
planning LCAP development and accountability it is our hope as well that these runs and analysis be
reported before the board meeting in in March with additional luxury that COVID-19 has afforded the
state it is critical that we use this opportunity to determine the best approach for redesigning
the academic indicator for growth for the growth model and rethink what equity not equality would
look like for English learners thank you good afternoon caller please state your name and
affiliation for the record your time starts now
Good afternoon Dr. Darling-Hammond, Superintendent Thurman, and State Board of Education members.
My name is Lorraine Richards. I am a classroom teacher representing the California Teacher
Association. California Teacher Association appreciates the CDE's continued work on developing
a growth model for the state of California. While CTA has expressed many questions and concerns
on the growth model in past letters, we are supportive of the CDE's continued work on developing
questions and concerns on the growth model in past letters. We are supportive of the two main
recommendations. The CDE's recommendation to only use the same subject area when modeling student
growth is a sound and an appropriate approach. Additionally, the recommendation to not set
different bars for students based on their demographics is in alignment with CTA's stance
on equity. Although it would be appropriate to conduct data simulations and to share those
simulations with the growth model stakeholder group and stakeholders prior to any final
determination made by the State Board of Education. We look forward to having additional discussions
on the issue of a student growth model as part of the accountability system for schools and
districts to ensure that is not used for teacher evaluation purposes. Thank you.
Good afternoon caller please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now.
Good afternoon Martha Zaragoza Diaz representing the California Association for Bilingual
Education and Californians Together. We appreciate CDE staff taking the steps of further breaking
down data especially regarding the disaggregation of the EL and RFIP data separately. Districts
require accurate and transparent data for the identification and development of appropriate
and effective goals actions and services for these students in their LCAP. This is
essentially critical for EL's and RFIP's not progressing academically. However, we request
that this data be presented to the State Board members before its March meeting when they will
be approving the growth model. Thank you. Good afternoon caller please state your name and
affiliation for the record your time starts now.
Good afternoon Board members and President Darling-Hammond. This is Liz Guian with Public
Advocates. I'm speaking to the letter we submitted on behalf of the Equity Coalition.
We don't have a position on the technical changes that the department is proposing today on the
student growth model but we are still concerned with the issues that we raised at the July and
September meetings and we urge you to direct the department to address these concerns in their
work plan between now and January so that they can address them prior to the first data release
in March. This is about releasing historic individual student data in December developing
the communication strategy which we know will be very important disaggregating English learners
subgroup data. Also we appreciate the report and recommendations from the Gardiner Center
and believe that those additional metrics should be explored and we also suggest that the chronic
absence indicate one that is used. Thank you.
Good afternoon caller please state your name and affiliation for the record your time begins now.
Are you there caller?
This concludes public comment.
Let me get off mute. Thank you to all the public commenters
and at this point we are open to further board discussion. Please raise your hand in the chat
I mean in the participant list if you want to make a comment. I know that
we were having some technical difficulties with Kim's technology. We'll wait in here
Brooks is checking. Patricia your hand is up.
Was that a question and then I have Matt after that. Thank you President Hammond. I just wanted
to verify that we I think my problem has been fixed. My question with Jenny was just a follow
up in response to her answer about the flexibility to do some data analysis in particular ways
about the ELs and she heard some questions or suggestions during the public comment that came
from a number of stakeholders. So we have time between now and the January board meeting to look
into that so I don't need to go into that again but thank you very much. All right and Matt did
you have a question? Your hand went up and then it disappeared. Yeah no I figured I'll forget to take
it down so once you see it. No I have two clarifying questions. I a couple of callers
that mentioned the chronic attendance indicator chronic absence indicator being part considered in
the recommendations for alternative schools and I was wondering if Jorge was still on the line and
and if they're considering that and the second one is it seems to me that we continue to hear
this idea around ELs and RFPs being separated but if I understood correctly and based on what I know
districts can do that. Is that correct Cindy? Yes so to answer your first question unfortunately
Jorge did sign off a little early. I don't think I asked him to stay around actually so
I apologize. No worries. For the data runs and I just wanted to clarify this for everyone
we will be providing you an information memorandum in February for all the student groups that
appear on the dashboard as well as the further disaggregation as you see it for the academic
indicator for the English learner student group. So you will see all that information ahead of
your meeting in March so that you will you know have enough time to to work through that
but that is our anticipated that's the work plan that we have with
educational testing services to to deliver that. Great thank you. Kim is on the phone she's having
some video tech problems but Kim are you there? Do you want to ask her?
I'm not hearing you.
I think that was just answered right now so we're all set thank you.
Okay great terrific and glad you're at least able to be on the phone.
Are there any other questions or comments from the board
before we look for a motion on this item?
Seeing none can I have a motion? Yes I would recommend that the board adopt the department's
recommendation per the powerpoint that's up on the screen that we confirm in the model the EBLIB
I don't like that acronym but we'll only use the same subject area when modeling student growth
and two that we will maintain the current student level methodology
which holds the same expectations for growth for all student groups.
Terrific I will second it thank you very much. Any further board discussion?
Seeing none we'll take a roll call vote. Brooks please call the roll. Member Burr?
Aye. President Darling-Hammond?
Aye. Member Fatah?
Aye. Member Glover-Woods?
Aye. Member McQuillan?
Yes. Member Navo?
Aye. Member Patil-Brownson?
Yes. Member Rodriguez?
Yes. Member Rucker?
Yes. Vice President Strauss?
Yes. Member Son?
Aye. This is unanimous.
Terrific we had hoped we would be taking a break at 2 15 it is precisely 2 15 congratulate yourselves
for being right on time we'll see you in 10 minutes at 2 25 remember don't leave the meeting
just turn off your meet yourself and turn off your video this is going to be a short
um consent calendar then we're going to take another break while they set up for public
comment for the next consent calendar so a little bit choppy in the next uh little while
let's see if Kim is back
Kim is okay Linda we're live a lot of people we're live you're live okay
still waiting for a couple of people
there's a day
i think we're waiting for soon
so
we have a quorum so i think i can go ahead and proceed
Brooks will you please call the roll to reestablish our quorum
Member Burr
President Darling Hammond
Here. Member Fatah?
Here. Member Glover Woods?
Here. Member McQuillin?
Here. Member Navo?
Here. Member Patil Brownson?
Member Rodriguez?
Here. Member Rucker?
Here. Vice President Strauss?
Here. Member Son?
Here.
Okay I know Member Patil Brownson is sharing um bandwidth with several members of her family
most days so hopefully uh somebody else will get it offline so she can come back on at some point
soon uh meanwhile i'll take up our waiver consent calendar which includes waiver items
W01 through 06 and W08 we'll now open the phone line for the public comment queue
that slide is up members of the public wishing to provide comment on any of these items may do so
by calling in now to the number on the slide and access code that is there and i will ask are there
any public comments on any waiver items waiver 01 through 06 and 08 and no one has called in
for public comment at this time okay uh given that there's no other public comment i'll ask
for a motion on waivers W01 through 06 and 08 do i have a motion i will move thank you do i have
a second second thank you i will now hold a roll call vote and brooks can you please call the roll
Member Burr?
Aye. President Darlin Hammond?
Aye. Member Fatah?
Aye. Member Glover Woods?
Aye. Member McQuillan?
Yes. Member Navo?
Aye. Member Patil Brownson?
Aye. Member Rodriguez?
Yes. Member Rucker?
Yes. Member Strauss?
Aye. Member Son?
Aye. Do you want to announce the result?
Brooks we're not hearing you sorry i believe that makes it unanimous of the members present yes
yes of the of the members present uh given uh with that we're going to take a few moments now
of additional break to give time for callers to get into the queue for providing public
comment for the regular items that are on proposed consent uh so we're
actually going to give a few more minutes of break uh and um wait for people to queue up in the queue
so we'll give it another minute
okay we can move ahead
i'll now ask board members Glover Woods and Strauss to recuse themselves i think they both have
um so that we can proceed with this consent calendar uh uh and um the consent vote so
plus staff please move them into the separate zoom room i think they've gone uh so is there
any public comment um this is on regular consent items six through eight and 11
um no one has called in for public comment at this time all right um
seeing that there is no public comment uh i'll ask for a motion on consent for items six through
eight and 11 i'll move thank you and do i have a second i'll second okay we'll now hold a roll
call vote rooks please call the roll member burr aye president darlin hammond aye member fatah
aye member mcquillin yes member navo aye member patil brownson
member rodriguez yes member rucker yes member son
yes so it passes with eight votes eight zero
um so now the staff can please allow members Glover Woods and Strauss back into the zoom
all right we got one
pretty exciting zooming in and out there we go all right now we're going to go to
waiver number seven which is not on consent uh and uh this is a waiver request by the 14
the way of california education code sections governing the process for selling or leasing
surplus property uh and the cde i will allow Juan Morelos from the cde to share the cd
recommendation uh and present the item thank you good afternoon president darlin hammond
chief deputy superintendent grexen board members my name is Juan Morelos i'm the director of the
school facilities and transportation services division here at cde and i'm going to be presenting
waiver seven today waiver seven is a request by the torrance unified school district to
waive certain sections of the law that would require them to go through the sealed bid process
and select the highest bidder instead the district plans on using the request for proposal process
which will provide them greater flexibility in selecting
beneficial terms and being able to consider other factors instead of just the highest price
cde staff recommends approval of the request to waive the sealed bid and highest bid
sections of the law with the following conditions that the proposal be selected within 30 to 60
days of the public meeting where it was received and that the reasons for determination be discussed
at a public session included in the minutes of the meeting another condition is that prior to
entering negotiations the governing board shall hold a public hearing where members of the public
including labor organizations can discuss possible uses of the surplus property and share concerns
regarding the impact on the community including the potential relocation of the programs currently
operating at the property and then lastly that this approval is just for the lease of the property
should the district decide to sell the property then another waiver would be required
so
cd staff recognizes that one of the reasons for denial is if the bargaining units were not participants
in the development of the waiver however cd staff believes that the bargaining units were
participants in the development of the waiver given the correspondence and the discussion
between the two parties over time now before we get into the specifics of the waiver request
we wanted to provide you just a very high level overview of the surplus property process here in
california which the districts have to go through at the local level before we get these types of
waivers the first step is to identify a property in this case the property in question is known
as a hamilton adult center then there's a public engagement process that's specified in law through
what's called a 7-eleven committee now the 7-eleven is because it's a minimum of seven members
and a maximum of 11 the law also specifies that the membership of the committee must be represented
of the community by assigning specific representation from different ethnic age groups
and socioeconomic composition of the district business community store owners managers supervisors
teachers landowners administrators parents persons with expertise environmental impact
legal contracts and building codes the committee is charged with looking at current and future
facility needs enrollment and any other factors may impact the need to retain the property
the committee is charged with holding public meetings and to establish a list prioritizing
uses for any of the unused property and then finally to submit a report with recommendations
to the governing board once the governing board receives the recommendation from the 7-eleven
committee then at a regularly scheduled public meeting they can decide that they're going to
accept the report and adopt the resolution to declare all or some of the properties surplus
in this particular case the 7-eleven committee began holding public meetings in october of
2017 they had a total of six public meetings through april 2018 the committee issued their
final report on july 31st and the district's governing board declared the property surplus
on august 6 2016 next we're going to walk you through some background and sequence of events
starting with the original waiver that was submitted back in august 2019
then in november of 2019 due to some conflicting information regarding one of the bargaining
units positions the item was withdrawn by staff and moved to the january 2020 meeting
in december 17th of 2019 the district met with the bargaining units to discuss the waiver
and on december 30th 2019 the district requested to withdraw the waiver request from the january board meeting
next march 2nd the district met with the bargaining unit representatives
to further discuss the waiver on august 17th the district sent letters via email to all of
the four bargaining units on their intent to refile the waiver request and to solicit feedback
they also indicate that they had additional conversations with two of the bargaining units
regarding the waiver and then finally on august 27th of this year the district submitted the
current waiver request through our review we confirmed that three of the four bargaining units
opposed the waiver the following reasons were for opposition were stated that the district has been
less than transparent a refusal by the district to be inclusive in the process poor planning and
execution of plans by the district mischaracterization of the position and lack of community support
including the sports program we received a letter on october 28th from csea urging the board to
deny the waiver request the main concerns raised in the letter were as follows that the educational
needs of the pupils are not adequately addressed that the pupil or school personnel protections
are jeopardized they also mentioned that planned staff reductions of 10 instructional aids
and that the exclusive representatives of the employees were not a participant in the development
of the waiver we received two letters from the school district one dated november 2nd
which stated the following that the district recognized the importance of the hamilton adult
center program and that they were fully committed in maintaining the programs in the district
that the reductions in adult education funding and the inability to offset the laws were the
reasons for staff reductions and that the reductions were unrelated to the waiver request
the adult education staff reductions were approved at the september 8th 2020 board meeting
and that the district worked with their local bargaining unit
and agreed on a memorandum of understanding specific to the effects of the reductions
on november 3rd the district submitted another letter stating that the district will be
rescinding the layoffs of the adult education classified employees that the district intends
to employ the staff in positions at school sites for distance learning and if the district is
unable to find new positions for the affected classified employees through december that the
district will consider revisiting staff reductions at that time once again the district is requesting
to waive the sealed bid and highest bidder process to lease surplus property cde staff recommends
approval of this waiver request with the conditions that are mentioned earlier as cde believes that
the bargaining units were afforded an adequate level of involvement
through the correspondence and discussion between the two parties over time
with that i'd be happy to answer any questions
i'm going to call on member rucker for some comments in a moment but first if we have the
could have the public comment slide up it looks like we do um great we're going to open up the
phone line for the public comment queue members of the public wishing to provide comment may do
so by calling the number on the slide and entering the access code and then while we're waiting for
members of the public remember rucker i turn to you for initial comments sure well first of all
i do want to thank the staff in the department and the state board staff who have worked very
diligently on this waiver as you can see the development for this waiver for presentation
and consideration by the board it's a been a long and winding pathway in the timeline
that you can see over the course of a year this is an example of something that typically comes
to the board and we're familiar with in the run-up to the approval of the local control funding
formula we heard from busloads of parents who came to the state board to plead with the board
to create metrics and criteria and guidance for districts on what the stakeholder engagement
process looks like and what it means to honor and take the time to listen to community stakeholder
input in meaningful ways and so it's important for the purposes of understanding what we're actually
asked to approve in this waiver to separate a number of things this waiver is simply a request
by an lea to simplify the process for them to lease this property that they have declared surplus
what has arisen in the waiver that is completely unrelated to approving the request that they are
making is the manner in which the development and the stakeholder engagement process for related
to this waiver unfolded it is it is material to the stakeholders in this community that
in making their request and giving their input for this waiver that they see connecting approving
the waiver in some way tacitly approving the behavior of the district and that's not what
we're doing but having said that it is important to state that this exemplifies very poor leadership
on the part of the district and how they chose to handle the stakeholder engagement process
it's not good and it's not adequate when you present a waiver to stakeholders and say we really
don't need your input we really don't need your approval because we're going to get the waiver
anyway it's not adequate input to hold a meeting about the waiver and not have the waiver paperwork
available for the participants to see during the course of the meeting that said that is not
material to be considering whether or not we're actually going to approve simplifying the process
for the district to approve the waiver so when it is time after we hear the comments from
stakeholders who are going to explain to you their frustration with the district on how they felt not
included and disregarded in the stakeholder process to develop this waiver I am going to recommend
approval of the waiver but further I think we need to pay attention to and Dr. Darling Hammond and
board member for Teal Bronson you have worked with the commission on teacher credentialing
we approve standards for administrators concerning you know criteria for them to receive their
certification one of the most important elements of that criteria is that they understand their
role as a leader in working with and supporting the inclusion of stakeholders from the complaints
that you're going to hear from these stakeholders that did not occur here and this is not unique
it's not an isolated incident this is for many in many areas it's the norm not the non-exception I
recall sitting at a different meeting for the for that concerning student student engagement
and school improvement and when the superintendent was asked point blank well what is your conversation
been with the stakeholders he says he's not doing that yet so we have a lot of work to do
in the area of continuous improvement to also continue to improve what our leaders are doing
to support stakeholder engagement and create norms that don't lead us to be confronted with
matters like this but again the issue about how the district conducted itself is separate from
the issue of approving the waiver itself so I would ask my colleagues on the board to listen
carefully and with great concern to what you hear from the stakeholders that at the same time
I am going to recommend when it is time for us to look at the waiver that we do approve the
waiver for the sole purpose of allowing the district to simplify its process to approve a
lease and to surplus the fact I hope all that makes sense thank you very much and at this point
we do have a number of people lined up for public comment I do want to acknowledge that
Kim is back with us on the phone and we'll go on to public comment
good afternoon caller please state your name and affiliation for the record your time begins now
hi my name is Jean Alvalar I'm actually the president of the softball league that is at
this location can you hear me because I'm not sure if you can we can hear you
okay great okay and I can appreciate what was explained before that we do agree that it wasn't
adequate adequately transparent to us what was going on we don't feel like we were ever included
in this decision-making process things tended to just move along without
things being considered by our community this place has been here for 40 years and it's just
unfortunate that it's gotten to this point I can appreciate that this is a waiver it's material to
you but I think it goes a long way just to be on the record as a part of this community that what
she said was true it's a very heartfelt and we very we very much feel slighted by the school
district the way they they did this thank you caller thank you
good afternoon caller please state your name and affiliation for the record your time begins now
now
good afternoon madam chair and superintendent Thurmond SBE members my name is Kathy Kelly and
I'm the president of CSCA Torrance chapter 845 I've been a member of the Torrance community for
the past 38 years we are opposed to waiver requests from Torrance Unified the district
has refused not only to include us in the development of the waiver and address our concerns
but has avoided providing us information which continues today the district still doesn't have
any clear consent concise plan as where our programs will be placed additionally it's been
a case in recent layoffs with adult ed the district refused to comply with our information request
until September 17th after the board had approved the layoff on September 8 nearly a month after our
first request the district misled us to the board to think that the coming up on September 21st
our recent experience with the district does not promote confidence that our staff students and
community members will be protected if the state board of education approves this waiver
we respectfully request that you deny the waiver at this time thank you
good afternoon caller please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
my name is dr linda scott and i'm calling for item 10
of the waiver this is not item 10 please call back later
good afternoon caller please state your name and affiliation for the record your time begins now
good afternoon members of the board and thank you for this time i am dr keith butler
chief business officer for the torrance unified school district since july of this year
our adult education program has lost significant funding this year from both state and federal
sources as a result we conducted multiple negotiation sessions with our local csa 845
resulting in an agreement september 22nd regarding the impacts and effects of these adult education
layoffs to hear these layoffs as somehow being tied now to the waiver application is completely
incorrect to make the point clear we agreed this week to receive those layoffs and i am working
with human resources to find long-term positions for those employees if possible while this action
does hurt our general fund in the present i know that the waiver is very important to the fiscal
health of our district for the long term i hope this board recognizes that we have been transparent
about this process since it began and that this waiver request is truly in the best interest of
all parties thank you
good afternoon caller please state your name and affiliation for the record your time begins now
my name is kay peterson and i am the vice president of csh torrance chapter 19
we are opposed to the waiver request from torrance unified we are deeply concerned with the
lack of transparency and the inclusion in the development of the waiver at no point in time has
the district included us in any meaningful way in the development of the waiver or satisfactorily
addressed our concerns regarding the impact of the waiver that would have upon students and staff
our members are fearful that the approval of the waiver will result in the elimination of the adult
education program they are concerned not only with their own job security but with these
programs that will be taken away from the computer community where many of our members
and their children have benefited directly from these programs we respectfully request that you
deny the waiver thank you good afternoon caller please state your name and affiliation for the
record your time begins now
good afternoon esteemed board members superintendent and support staff
i'm dr tim stowe t usd interim superintendent since 1975 i've been fully invested in the
torrance unified school district as a student a teacher a parent a principal and other administrative
roles i live and breathe what is best for our students our staff and our community
i've been involved in the potential lease of the hamilton property since our board formed a 7-eleven
committee and have been responsible for the outreach to keep the community informed and
engaged for more than three years what you see before you in the waiver application meets all
cde requirements including significant consultation with our labor partners i respect our labor
partners but i respectfully disagree with any contention that this has been a closed process
what i do know is that a negotiated lease will provide the absolute best possible terms to
benefit our students our labor partners and our community thus i respectfully request approval
of our waiver request thank you
good afternoon caller please state your name and affiliation for the record your time begins now
good morning madam chair superintendent thurman and sb members my name is robert duwitz and i
represent the classified employees in torrance chapters 19 and 845 we are opposed to the waiver
request from torrance unified this waiver impacts adult education programs the special
education transition program and the ball field heavily used by the community the district has
continued to refuse including us in the development of waivers despite continued promises to provide
us a copy of the draft waiver spanning nearly a year the district only provided us with a copy
they intended to submit less than five business days to submission the district continues to
mischaracterize its meetings with us which have been cursory and superficial to date the district
has offered no substantial assessment or response of its capacity to protect these vital programs
and services instead communicating that while the approval of the waiver may permit it they
have no obligation to do so we implore you to make the district's blatant lack of respect and
disregard for our involvement of primary consideration in your determination we respectfully request that
you deny the waiver thank you good afternoon caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record your time begins now
hi my name is alan glassband and i represent the community of north torrance and general
i was a board member at the little league when this began and like many other people including
somebody from your own board mentioned the school district handled this were in a really poor
fashion lack of transparency has been always been the problem unlike what the superintendent still
mentioned they did not include us in any of the conversations other than duly noted and we'll march
on with our own opinion of what has to happen in your community there's a high special needs group
that will not be able to go anywhere else there are elderly people who can't take classes and
they started cutting them a few years ago in preparation to try to sell this property they
actually falsified information on your own application when they said that there was no
objection from the 7-eleven committee there are actually two nay votes with objections
because of community opposition and those were not included on your application
time or other instances i only have one minute thank you caller thanks thank you
good afternoon caller please state your name and affiliation for the record your time begins now
good afternoon my name is michael juba and i am a classroom teacher representing the california
teachers association cta is extremely concerned with the waiver request from torrance unified
past waivers of this sort have been for properties that are empty lots or empty buildings
we are hard pressed to understand how a building that houses a significant number of programs with
no plan for relocation can be deemed surplus cta supports our local association's opposition
to this waiver request as well as the opposition from our labor partners at csa cta recommends the
state board reject the waiver and ask torrance unified school district to conduct authentic
stakeholder engagement with community stakeholders and specifically with the bargaining units and
good faith most importantly torrance unified must ensure that the best interest of the students
served in these programs are met by protecting these programs currently housed at the site in
question thank you good afternoon caller please state your name and affiliation for the record
your time begins now
this is not general public comment please call back later okay okay thank you
good afternoon caller please state your name and affiliation for the record your time begins now
Madam President, Board Members, Superintendent Thurmond, my name is Dolores Duran-Flores and I
represent the California School Employees Association and we oppose this waiver. We urge you to deny it
because the district failed to meet three criteria set forth in the reasons for denial. First, the
educational needs of the students are not adequately addressed. In fact, nobody knows what will happen
to the programs and the students because the district hasn't told us. Secondly, school personnel
protections are just sized. The district approved laying off 10 of our instructional aids at this
site. Only after the superintendent Thurmond inquired about the way off did the district rescind
nine and only until possibly December. While we appreciate the superintendent's help, the district
failed to meet this requirement and finally the union was not a participant in the development
of the waiver. The district had two waiver meetings that didn't provide a copy of the waiver.
You can't involve us in the development of the waiver when you don't even have a copy of it.
The district failed to meet this requirement. For these reasons we urge you to deny this waiver.
This concludes public comment. Perfect, thank you very much. At this point
we want to open up for board discussion. Board members please you know raise your hands in the
participant list if you have a comment or a question. Give it a little wait time.
All right. So seeing no questions or comments, I wonder if someone would like to make a motion.
I would like to ask the staff to put the slide with the staff recommendation
on the screen again please. Thank you.
Okay so you can see on this recommendation there are basically four parts to this
recommendation. First of all the department does recommend approving the waiver. The approval
of the waiver is approving simplifying the process for the district to be able to lease
and simplifying the bidding process so that they can have other factors that they can consider
in approving a lease of the property in addition to other criteria other than the highest bid as
there as the consideration. That's the first part of what is being recommended in the waiver
and that is the only thing that is material to the waiver itself as it relates to the sections
of the ed code statute. Leave it on that section. Leave it on that slide please.
As it relates to the ed code sections that the district is seeking but based on the comments
that you heard from the stakeholders on a lot of the work that has been done by department staff,
by state board staff, and as you also heard from the superintendent's office,
we are recommending these additional conditions as part of the approval of the waiver. The first
recommendation requires a public hearing. The first recommendation that requires that the
governing board determines what's the most desirable way where the proposal can be received
and the reasons for that determination and include that in the minute. The second recommendation
is that prior to entering into negotiations that the governing board hold a public hearing with
the members of the public including labor organizations to discuss the issues about the
relocation of the programs that are currently operating at the property. The most important
concern you heard from the stakeholders is that they do not believe the district has actually
exercised its due diligence to protect the students or the programs that are involved in figure out a
way to maintain the integrity and the continuation of those programs. And second and finally this is
a waiver that only applies to the lease of the property if the district decides to sell the
property they will need to go through this process again and they will need to consider if they're
going to support provide another waiver request. The department staff believes particularly with
the inclusion of the requirement for a meaningful stakeholder engagement process in a public hearing
that and the fact that we have made clear and put sunshine on what the concerns are that the
community has in the way that the district has conducted the process to get to the waiver at
this point. While it hasn't solved the conflict or the norms of the culture of stakeholder engagement
in the district it has it has raised the level of expectation from the department and the board
to the district about what should be done going forward to try to qualm and calm down
some of the concerns that have been raised. So because of these three conditions and
we do feel that these conditions do attempt to try to carve out some way of creating some ways
for the stakeholders to mediate their concerns and at the same time raise some accountability
for the district in the ways that they work with their relationship with their stakeholders on this
particular project we think that this waiver should be I do recommend approval of the of the
waiver for the lease of the property with these with these conditions in place. That's my motion.
Thank you. Is there a second? I second. Thank you very much.
Is there any further discussion from the board?
Seeing no hands we'll ask Brooks to do a roll call vote. Member Burr?
Aye. President Darling-Hammond?
Aye. Member Fatah?
Aye. Member Glover-Woods?
Aye. Member McQuillan?
Yes. Member Navo?
Aye. Member Patil-Brownson?
Yes. Member Rodriguez?
Yes. Member Rucker?
Yes. Vice President Strauss?
Yes. Member Son?
Aye. It's approved unanimously.
Thank you very much and thank you Juan for that clear presentation. We appreciate it.
We're now up to agenda item 9 which is the last one. I'm not sure if it's the last one for the
day but it is our next one. I'm going to hand the gavel to Vice President Strauss for this item
because I have to step out for another meeting short. Okay so we are now going to hear item 9
which is a retroactive request for funding for three non-classroom based charter schools.
This item will be presented by Stephanie Farland from CDE. So Stephanie would you please begin?
Good afternoon Vice President Strauss, Board Members, Chief Deputy Gregson.
We are here today to present items 9 and 10 both on funding determinations. I'm going to
hand it over to McKenna Huey who is the manager in our division that is the expert on funding
determinations and conducts all the reviews to go over the item, the first item, item 9 and then
we'll both be around for questions. Good afternoon State Board Members. My name is McKenna Huey
representing the charter schools division and I will be presenting item 9 of today's meeting agenda.
So prior to jumping into item 9 just a brief update on funding determinations. So for the next
two fiscal years the CDE anticipates that the State Board will hear fewer funding determination
items as a result of the passage of Senate Bill 820 which modifies the request process for existing
non-classroom based charter schools for fiscal years 2020 to 21 and 2021 to 2022. So additional
information regarding this bill and its implications on the funding determination process
will be provided in item 13 of tomorrow's meeting agenda.
So getting back to item 9 this item consists of retroactive requests for determination of funding
for three renewing non-classroom based charter schools, Horizon Charter, Guahome Learning Center
and Loma Vista Charter. So the CDE uses the term retroactive to refer to determination of funding
requests submitted after the regulatory deadline. For existing non-classroom based charter schools
this deadline is February 1 of the fiscal year prior to the year the school's current funding
determination expires. All schools presented in this item fail to submit their funding determination
request for renewal by the February 1 deadline. As such they were required to obtain a waiver
permitting them to submit the request after the deadline and waivers were submitted for all schools
and were approved by the State Board at its July 2020 meeting. So upon the State Board's approval
of the waivers the CDE reviewed each school's request for determination of funding. In order
to receive 100% funding for its non-classroom based instruction charter schools are required
to meet specific criteria which are detailed on this slide and are as follows. Spend at least 40%
of its public revenues on instructional certificated salaries and benefits. Spend at least 80% of its
total revenues on instruction and instructional services and maintain a people to teacher ratio
that does not exceed 25 to 1 or an equivalent people to teacher ratio of the largest unified
school district in the county or counties in which the charter school operates.
So based upon CDE staff's review Horizon Charter and Wilma Vista Charter meet the criteria for a
100% determination of funding. Guahome Learning Center does not meet the criteria to be eligible
for a 100% funding as it did not spend at least 80% of its instruction and instructional related
services. Rather this school qualifies for an 85% funding level which is the level of funding
that the school did end up requesting. So each school's exact spending percentages and people
teacher ratio information is provided in attachment one of this item and detailed information regarding
each school's respective revenues and expenditures can be found in their funding determination forms
which are provided as attachments two through four of item one of the October
ACCS meeting agenda which is linked in this item. So for an existing non-classroom based charter
school regulations state that an approved funding determination shall be for a minimum period of two
years and a maximum period of five years. Unless a shorter period is requested by the school it is
the CDE's current practice to propose a funding determination period of three years for charter
schools that are seeking renewal of their funding determination for the first time and a period of
four years for schools that have gone through this renewal process one or more times. So all schools
in this item have gone through the renewal process more than one time their funding determination
periods have been recommended accordingly with the exception of Guahome Learning Center which
requested a funding determination period of two years.
So at the October ACCS meeting it was requested that the CDE share the school
budgets used to complete the funding determination forms and the CDE would like to make it clear that
the budget is not required to be submitted as budget information is not used to complete the
funding determination form for renewing our existing charter schools rather these schools
use audited financial data. So upon the receipt of a complete funding determination form CDE staff
compare the information submitted in the form to the school's actual audit and those audits are
housed in the school fiscal services division of the department. So also at the October ACCS
meeting concerns regarding each of these schools funding determinations requests were brought up
the ACCS's concerns primarily focused on the school's high level of reserves expenses paid
to other agencies and the terms of the school's board members. So the CDE notes that maintaining
high reserves are not typically a cause for concern or reason for the CDE to grant a lesser
amount or deny a funding determination request pursuant to regulations if a charter school meets
the 4080 spending criteria and the people teacher ratio requirements the ACCS shall recommend that
the state board approve the request at 100 percent unless there is a reasonable basis to
recommend otherwise. So after the October ACCS meeting CDE staff did reach out to all the schools
for clarification on the specific points of concern that were raised by the commissioners
and all schools were responsive to the CDE's request for more information.
Horizon Charter cited as reasons for the high reserves as being in the process of restructuring
its budget and updating its multi-year production for the first interim report. The school also
stated that they are setting aside funding to open a resource center in its authorizers district
and regarding its expense to write Engel productions which was something that was also
brought up by the ACCS. Horizon Charter provided documentation to support that its contract
with write Engel productions was for advertising partnerships social media marketing and so on and
so forth. Guahome Learning Center they cited multiple reasons for their high reserves including
they are saving for new facilities they also plan to use that money to maintain full operations
and continue providing all their services to students while being funded at 85 percent for
the next two years. They're also saving for additional uncertainties due to the COVID pandemic.
And regarding this charter school's board members and their expired terms
the school did provide an updated list of their board members with current terms to the CDE.
And then the last charter school Loma Vista Charter their authorizer provided information to us and
cited reasons for their high reserves as being that the authorizers are
charging the school a little bit less for support services provided. The authorizer has stated
though that it will charge the school more in order to spend on the school's reserves if it
continues to be deemed an issue. So upon the completion of these three funding determination
requests review the CDE finds that all requests are reasonable and adequately supported and
recommends that the state board approve the determination of funding requests for Horizon
Charter and Loma Vista Charter at 100 percent for four years and the determination of funding
request for Guahome Learning Center at 85 percent for two years as requested by the charter school.
And at its October meeting the ACCS moved to approve CDE staff's recommendation and that motion
passed by a vote of eight to one. Thank you for your consideration of this item and I'm
happy to answer any clarifying questions the board will have. Thank you so much for the presentation
and for the follow-up on the questions that were raised at ACCS. So would we put up the slide for
public comment? Members of the public can comment on this item by calling 712-432-0075 and entering
the access code 651905. So while we're waiting for members of the public to call in I first
want to ask members Burr and Son or our liaisons to ACCS if they have any initial comments then
I'll ask board members if they want to ask one clarifying question or make a comment before we
go to public comment then we'll go to board discussion. So raise your hand in the zoom panel
if you have a clarifying question and I'll move to member Burr and Son for some initial comments.
I'm going to defer to Ting because she attended the ACCS. I was not able to attend.
Yeah and I just wanted also to thank the staff for following up on the questions from the ACCS
meeting and from the commissioners there. These funding requests have become come under more and
more scrutiny as you know we have seen over the last few months here and you know I would just
kind of emphasize that these are funding determinations go through real thorough scrutiny
by the CDE staff having had a school that has gone through this process and that they are following
the regulations that have been established for the the review of these determinations.
I do think that these regulations are 20 plus years old and that I think we might want to
relook at those regs and I'm hoping that we get an opportunity to be able to review funding
determinations in the process in the future. Thank you member Son. So do we have any
clarifying questions before we go to public comment? I don't see any hands up.
So do we have any public comment available? Yes. Go ahead. We do have public commenters.
Good afternoon callers. State please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time
begins now. Dr. Linda Scott. I'm affiliated with WEB Du Bois Public Charter School. That is also
up for waiver. Excuse me. There's a delay between the computer and the phone. That is the next item.
Please call back then. Okay.
Good afternoon callers. Please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time begins now.
Good afternoon everyone. My name is Kevin Humphrey and I'm the superintendent of
Guahomey schools. I oversee the Guahomey learning centers which is a small independent study
learning program that is a part of the program. I'm the superintendent of Guahomey
I oversee the Guahomey learning centers which is a small independent study
learning program that serves about 100 students in Vista, California. We provide support to
families who are looking for a blended learning model for their students. Many of our high school
students utilize our program for credit recovery purposes. The Guahomey learning center's facility
is currently located in one of our lobbies of Guahomey Park Academy. We are in the process
of looking for a facility to better meet the needs of our students. A facility that will help
us provide more one-on-one support and intervention for our students. We apologize for missing an
classroom-based funding determination deadline and we have installed protocols to ensure that
it doesn't happen again. We hope that we can get past this bump in the road and continue to meet
the needs of some of our most vulnerable students within our community and we appreciate your
we appreciate your support in doing so. Thank you for the opportunity to speak.
Good afternoon caller. Please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Dodd-DeFratz. I am a...
Is this public comment? Is there no public comment? I know. Okay.
Good afternoon caller. Please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
SBE members Sheila Whitley classroom teacher speaking for California teachers association.
CTA would like to express our continued concerns with the funding determinations of non-classroom
based charters. In our letter we called out a variety of issues but I would like to discuss
the following. They each have very large reserves ranging from 41 percent to 159 percent. These funds
should be spent on the classroom for the benefit of students. Horizon charter has sizable expenses
of more than $549,000 going to a closed NCB that is run by their own administrator and a public
relations contract of more than $445,000. At Guaynomi Learning Center there appears to be
a conflict of interest between GLC and Guaynomi Park Academy with overlapping board members staff
and GLC sending 18 percent of their budgets to GPA. CTA questions the need for 100 percent funding
determinations for the NCBs during the lack of transparency and sizable reserves they each have.
Additionally CTA believes that CDE must also share the NCB budget time
submitted with the determination of funding request forms to help ensure that another
that concludes public comment.
Thank you. We'll open up for board discussion now so board members please remember to raise
your hand in the participant panel of zoom if you have a question or a comment. Are there any
comments from board members? Let's see member Navo. I think Patricia Rucker board member Rucker
you had your hand up before me so feel free. Okay member Rucker. Oh okay I was just going to say
you know we've had this is not the first time in the conversation for a board item on funding
determinations that I have heard from board member Sun that there is a need to revisit
the regulations and our criteria because they seem to be out of date. I would just like to
comment on this item when are we going to do that and what exactly is the step that needs to be
taken because there are there is merit to the concerns that are being raised here about these
funding determinations especially in a year when we know that there are serious budget concerns for
all LEAs not just charters and so I'm not sure what is the need for 100% funding determination
for a school that has a 159% reserve yet the regulations provide the flexibility
to approve something like that so I do have some concerns about what we need to do and what steps
need to be taken for us to actually either as a board action to have a public conversation as an
agenda item or to do the work with staff update and review update and revise this criteria before
we have another set of funding determinations that look questionable like these do to me.
Hi thank you member Rucker. Member Novo.
Actually board member Rucker that was exactly the question I was going to ask it just wasn't
it wasn't the first time that I've heard the concern around coming back to revisit
the these regulations that are 20 plus years old so I wanted to just put us a stamp on the reality
that we do need to have that conversation and I think that even though the the reserves are not
they're they're not part of the non-funding determinations in the sense that they're not
part of the decision making for that they do create questions and questions that are probably
justified when you get with the charters and you have them explained but I would I would just say
that if if we were looking at these and they were local school districts with that large of reserves
it would generate questions as well. Thank you member Berger.
Just a couple comments. Some of the answer about redoing the funding regulations for
non-classroom based schools will be discussed tomorrow when we talk about the major changes
that have been made to the charter school law. There will be a moratorium on non-classroom
based schools for a period of time and so I think and presumably to examine their relevance,
their appropriateness, their success with students and so a decision will be made about whether or
not to continue with that modality under charter schools so and I will just say related to the
change in legislation we will have lots of work to do around charters and all kinds of regulations
around charters so that's I just put that in the parking lot we'll hear a lot more about that
tomorrow but in the meantime we do have very specific criteria and I really want to commend
the department on how they put on the presentation that was made about how they come to these
decisions. You can tell from our advisory committee on charter schools that there was a compelling
recommendations they're acting on them based on the department's best advice so some of these
other questions that come up really are not relevant to the decisions that are being made
about funding determination so I would just like to suggest that we move forward with this and I'd
be happy to make a recommendation to adopt the department's recommendation, make a motion to
adopt the department's recommendation. Do we have a second? Member Sanyu, are you seconding it? Yes.
Okay so our executive director now will take the roll call vote. Member Burr. Aye. President
Darlene Hammond. Member Fatah. Aye. Member Glover Woods. Yes. Member McQuillan. Yes. Member Navo. Aye.
Member Patil Brownson.
Member Rodriguez. Nay.
Was that a nay or a yay? I apologize. It was a nay, no. Thank you.
Member Rucker. No. Member Strauss. Vice President. Yes. Yes. Member Sun. Yes.
That passes with a vote of seven to two.
Thank you. So now we're going to move to agenda item 10 which is a retroactive request for funding
with mitigating circle number one non-classroom based charter school
and so this item will be presented by Stephanie Farland from CDE. Stephanie and just this is
actually specified in attachment one just so everyone's aware. Stephanie please begin.
Thank you Vice President Strauss. I'm going to hand it over again to McKenna Hewie.
Hello again. Again I'm McKenna Hewie and I'm representing the charter school division and
I will also be presenting this item to you. So item 10 consists of a retroactive request for
determination of funding with mitigating circumstances for WEB Dubois public charter.
So as explained in the last item retroactive requests refer to determination of funding
requests submitted after the regulatory deadline. So this charter school failed to submit its funding
determination request by February 1st and they were required to obtain a waiver from the state
board which was approved at its July 2020 meeting. So once the school obtained an approved waiver
the CDE reviewed the school's funding request and found that it does not meet the criteria
for 100% funding. The criteria for full funding is detailed on this slide. The school's exact
spending percentages and people teacher ratio information can be found in attachment one of
this item and detailed information regarding the school's revenues and expenditures can be found
in its funding determination form which is provided as attachment two of item two
on the October ACCS meeting agenda.
So when the criteria for full funding are not met regulations permit the advisory commission on
charter schools to find a reasonable basis also referred to as a mitigating circumstance by which
to make a recommendation other than one that results from the expenditure criteria to the
state board. So if the charter school does not meet the designated spending criteria it can
submit mitigating circumstances for consideration and the charter school does not meet the
it can submit mitigating circumstances for consideration and these circumstances may
include documented data regarding individual circumstances of the charter school and or
one-time expenses or unique or exceptional expenses and without a reason for mitigating
circumstances a charter school's funding rate may be reduced from 100% to 85 or 70% or may be denied
at 0%. So WEB Dubois public charter did not meet the criteria for full funding.
They submitted mitigating circumstances for consideration and cited as their mitigating
circumstance the need to expend a considerable amount of revenues on facilities as well as a
decrease in their non-classroom based ADA caused by campus closures resulting from the Anderson
versus Shasta court decision. So in order to comply with the Anderson court decision the school
closed two of its three campuses and the school was able to end one lease for one of its closed
campuses but was still obligated to the lease for its other campus through 2020 to 2021 and
additional details regarding their request and their reason of mitigating circumstances
is provided in this item.
So as I also previously stated for an existing non-classroom based charter school regulations
state that an approved funding determination shall be for a minimum of two years and a
maximum of five years although typically the CDE recommends a period of three to four years for
renewing charter school when considering requests for mitigating circumstances the CDE generally
proposes a funding determination period of two fiscal years and this permits the CDE to timely
revisit a school's funding and ensure that the school is meeting the spending requirements outlined
in regulations. So at the October ACCS meeting concerns regarding WVB Dubois public charter's
funding determination requests were brought up and are detailed on this slide. The school provided
the CDE with additional information to clarify the concerns discussed at the ACCS meeting.
So regarding the leases the school clarified that it is still using the facility of one of the
campuses that they previously closed and this facility is being used for back office services
as well as for professional development for staff. The school wanted to make it very clear that they
are not paying for a facility that they are not using and then regarding the cost of fronting
their facilities the school stated that the amount that they pay in rent has been the same
since 2006 and they have and they have also provided their authorizer with comparisons
for other facilities in the area justifying the amount that they pay in rent. The school also
clarified that the GAPE is a community-based organization not a charter management organization
and it gave acts as a parent organization over the two charters that they operate under a
non-profit status, WVB Dubois being one of them, and all board members are volunteers and they do
not get paid. So the CDE has determined that the information submitted by WVB Dubois public
charter supports its claim for mitigating circumstances therefore the CDE recommends that
the state board approve the school's request for consideration of mitigating circumstances
and approve the determination of funding request for 100% for a time period of two years as
outlined in attachment one and at its October meeting the ACCS moved to approve the CDE's
recommendation and that motion passed by a vote of eight to one. So thank you again for your
consideration of this item and again I'm happy to answer any clarifying questions.
So thank you for the presentation and for the follow-up to the questions at ACCS. We're going
to put up the slide for public comment. Members of the public wishing to provide comment on this
item may do so by calling area code 712-432-0075 and enter the access code 651-905 pound. So while
we're waiting for the members of the public to call in I'll ask member Sun if you have any
initial comments and then I'll ask board members if you want to ask one clarifying question or a
comment before we go to public comment after that we'll come back for board discussion.
No specific items on this, I mean no specific comments on this item other than to thank CDE
staff again for their follow-up. So member Byrne did you want to make a comment?
No, no specific comments. Thank you. Member Navo?
No, I forgot to put my hand down. Okay, member Glover Woods?
I just had a clarifying question and this goes back to the slide around the questions and concerns.
My question is the Agape LS LLC, are the school board members from W.E.B. DuBois
also members of that LLC? That's my first question and my second question to that is
is the Agape LLC the organization that owns any of the buildings that the charter is leasing?
So that is correct. The board members of the charter school are the same as the board members
on Agape. I believe Agape owns the facility and they partner with Ellis for that so there's like
a joint partnership there. Do you want to, while we go for public comment, do you want to go back
at your notes and take a look at that if you haven't? Yes, I will definitely do that. Okay,
so let's go to public comment and then we'll come back and clarify member Glover Woods
questions and any other discussion from board members.
Good afternoon caller. Please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
SBE members, my name is Sheila Fitley and I'm a classroom teacher representing
the California Teachers Association. In our letters for item 9 and 10, we called out a
variety of issues but I would like to reiterate the following. W.E.B. DuBois' public charter is
requesting mitigating circumstances due to having a move from three sites to one site
after the Anderson case but still having to pay for two sites. For their funding determination
forum, DuBois is paying $516,000 to Agape Ellis LLC. This group is described as Agape,
a non-profit has a partnership with the Ellis family for the purposes of partial ownership
and the leasing of two facilities of our schools. The Agape directors have no personal soccer
ownership. It is unclear at the least that they cannot be negotiated with this partnership or
another entity. The three board members of DuBois charter are also board members for the Agape CMO.
CTA does not believe that these mitigating circumstances are reasonable and therefore W.E.B.
DuBois should not be 100% funding. Thank you.
Good afternoon, caller. Please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time begins now.
My name is Dr. Linda Scott. I am the CEO of W.E.B. DuBois and Agape schools, the non-profit.
Did you want to make public comment?
Yes, I'm sorry. It's a delay between this, but thank you to the state board today for
allowing me to speak. I was on the call for the commission to clarify some of the questions that
the union member had and was not allowed to, I was left on hold and was not allowed to provide
public comment in regards to our school to clarify the question. And so today I wanted to
say that Agape is not a CMO. Agape is the parent organization to W.E.B. DuBois and
Carter G. Wilson public charter schools which operate under its non-profit. Our board members
are all volunteers. And with that being said, Agape LLC does not have the same board as far
as the lease. Okay, caller, go ahead and respond to the question.
So I wanted to say, I clarify we're not a CMO. So if the charter was affected, it would directly
affect the non-profit itself because they operate under the non-profit. And then as far as the Agape
LLC, they do not have the exact same board members. They're a limited liability corporation
only formed for the purposes of when the school was built in 05, 06. Caller, your time concludes
now. Thank you. Do we have any other public comments? Yes, we have one more public comment.
Hello, is this general public comment? No, this is still not general public comment.
Sorry, I thought it was public comment for item 10, right? Yeah, sorry. This is item 10. Okay.
Does that conclude the public comments?
That concludes the public comment. Okay. So now we'll open up for board discussion.
And I see member Rucker, you have your hand up.
Thank you, board member Strauss. This item was confusing to me. I'm still not clear about the
relationship between the two entities. But that's not what actually confuses me. What really confuses
me is the lease of the property and where the relationship is there. If the property is owned
by one of these two entities and the charter is leasing property they no longer use, why can't
the entity that's overseeing this non-profit charter just simply let them out of the lease?
So that's not an expense or a contract or consideration for why they're currently
seeking mitigation. So I'm confused about that. And probably my question is either based on
a misunderstanding about that relationship or misinformation altogether. But to me it seems
somebody owns that property who has the authority to let them out of that lease. And the lease
is a material expense for why they're seeking this mitigation. So I don't get why they just simply
can't be allowed out of the lease by the entity that is managing them as a non-profit organization.
So I am confused about that. Thank you, member Rucker. I did know that CDE staff was looking
at research on their notes. Do you have anything more Stephanie and your team to add?
Yeah, so we did do a deeper dive after the ACCS meeting into the kind of the lease concerns that
were brought up at the ACCS meeting. And we did not find really any thing that was super
concerning that would cause us to change our recommendation. What we can do is we can continue
to kind of get information from the school. Regulations does permit the State Board of
Education to request additional documentation and then later go on and modify the funding
determination level as appropriate or as necessary. And in response to the question
about the relationship between Agape and Ellis, I believe that is described in the
funding determination form. I believe it might be on page five. However, unfortunately I don't
have it in front of me so I can't say for certain. But board members might find some clarification on
actual funding information. And also this is Stephanie. So there is the option of the
board not approving mitigating circumstances in which the school will then be funded at 85%.
So that's an option. Do we have any more comments from board members? I'm just looking
for any more hands. I don't see any. Board member Strauss, I raised my hand again.
Oh, sorry. I thought it was the same from before. I apologize. Go ahead.
No, that's no problem. I've been trying to be diligent about lowering and raising my hand. So
I understand why. I want to thank the staff, Stephanie, for responding to my question or
inquiry about the relationship. Let me be emphatic when I make this next statement.
I don't easily get confused about factual information. And so I'm going to repeat again,
I am confused about the relationship between these two entities. So I would like to say
what is provided to me is not clear or plain or transparent or apparent. I can't think of
any other adjectives to give you, but I don't understand it. Thank you. Do we have any more
comments or clarifying questions from board members? Vice President Strauss, can I say
something? This is Stephanie. Please. I did just a second ago give the option of not approving
mitigating circumstances. But you also can, if you want us to take an even deeper dive,
we're happy to do that. And then we could bring this item back to
the December ACCS and the January State Board. So it really, you know, your call.
Any members? So I appreciate the questions. I appreciate the staff's additional work in
reviewing some and responding to the questions. Are we starting to move outside of our regulations
for this process? No regulations do permit the State Board and the department to go back and ask
for additional information in order to make an accurate recommendation for funding.
This is Judy Saez. I just want to, it won't hurt the school if we delay until January, correct?
That's correct. That would be the last meeting that we have. So it won't harm them and delay
them getting any apportionment or anything like that. Okay. Say, Member Sung, are you
done with that comment or do you want to say any more before I go to the next board member?
No, I don't need this anymore. Okay. Member Rodriguez?
I just also wanted clarification because I really don't feel comfortable with the information that
we have now. So if it's not violating our rules and we can, you know, just get clarity because I
really also feel like Member Rucker, I don't have clarity on this. I'm hearing, you know,
a lot of disparate information. Do I have a motion to continue or a motion to approve?
Do I have some motion? Member Strauss, this is Judy Saez again. We do not need a motion to
delay it unless there is the desire to approve it and to make a motion. That's fine. But if the
desire is to research and get further information, if there's a consensus to do that, then we're happy
to come back, again, like Stephanie described, and pull it from this and not take any action
at this time. So I've heard from two board members that they would like some clarification
of additional information before taking action on our next board agenda. Let's see. How do I do this
on Zoom? Do I have a Member Burr? Yeah, I just would suggest that because there are questions
that are unanswered and need clarity that we do delay this until the December ACCS and the January
board meeting. Thank you. Member Glover-Woods, I see your hand up. Yes, I just wanted to clarify,
and I would agree it would be very helpful to bring it back. I want to clarify specifically
what I would like to have more information regarding is the relationship between the LLC
and the buildings that are leased that are causing the mitigating circumstances.
So I just want to support all these requests. I know, Stephanie, in the past, we've actually
had a chart which showed who was related to who and who connected and who was in charge and who
owned what. And I don't know if once you do the research, you'd be able to explain that to us,
but I think there's enough concern on the board that we need more clarifying. So we'll ask you to
follow up on the comments that the board members have asked and to bring it back to ACCS
in December and in January for the state board meeting. Yes, that's what we'll do.
Any more comments from board members or any more
clarification you'd like Stephanie and her team to do before we end this item?
Okay, then I think this ends that item. And thank you, CDE, for a really thoughtful and
good presentation to us and we look forward to hearing the next steps at our next meeting.
So and now we're going to go to item number 12. I hope we haven't lost our public commenter.
I hope we haven't lost our public commenter. This is general public comment for items that are not
included on our printed agenda. So we're going to open up the phone line. So this is the number
that you can't call. Area code 712-432-0075. Enter the access code 651905. And I now ask,
are there any public comments? We encourage you to state your name and affiliation for the record.
And remember to turn down the volume on your computer if you're following the live feed.
Speakers will be limited to one minute. So do we have any public comment? We do.
Good afternoon, caller. This is general public comment.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time begins now.
The caller dropped. Oh, there. There. But wait, there are more. Oh, good. Good afternoon, caller.
This is general public comment. Please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time
begins now. Hello. I called earlier. This is Dr. Linda Scott and it hung up when I was trying to
explain the affiliation between the LLC and the nonprofit. Caller, this is general public comment.
This is not the time. My apologies. Okay. I just, I just want to.
Good afternoon, caller. This is general public comment. Please state your name
and affiliation for the record. Your time begins now.
Hello. My name is John Fratch. I'm a freshman and a ninth grade class co-president from San
Pedro Senior High School. I am calling in to support the recommendations made by the Student
Advisory Board on Education. I participated in state this weekend and I am honored by the
presentations made by fellow colleagues and presenters in today's meeting. Student voice
and utilizing student input in making decisions about our schools is most important to me.
As an autistic student, I am part of a student population whose input is never solved when it
comes to decisions that affect student exceptional needs like myself. Student voice, especially in
student populations whose input is not solved or understood, is needed so that students can be heard
and included in the decision making. We must, we understand the concerns and needs of our communities.
We must be able to voice our concerns, our needs, and our recommendations to make our schools better,
to make our schools what we need them to be successful and reach their potential. Thank you.
Good afternoon, caller. This is general public comment.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. This is Liz Guillen, Republic Advocates. The LCFS Equity Coalition is concerned
that the board's agenda omits an item discussing the department's proposed changes to the local
control and accountability plan annual update template and instructions that were made by this
year's education budget trailer bills. While the trailer bills changed your role in approving the
template, making the executive director a consultant in the process, they did not change the role of
the LCAP as an accountability tool for local district communities to participate in LCAP
development in an informed way. The revisions are significant. They reflect new requirements of the
local continuity plan for districts to address learning loss as a condition of receiving millions
in state and federal dollars. We think this is a big deal and should not have been omitted from
your discussion. We're very concerned that the revisions will not adequately provide LEAs with
enough guidance. We urge you to ensure this goes to CPAC. There is no further public comment.
So thank you. So before I announce the end of the meeting, I want to say that we're going to
continue our meeting at 8.30 tomorrow morning with closed session to discuss the following
legal manners, Martinez versus Newsom, today's fresh start versus Englewood Unified School District,
Los Angeles County Office of Education, California Department of Education and the State Board of
Education. We're anticipating that we will come back into public session between 8.45 and 9 o'clock
in the morning. And so I hereby end today's meeting at 3.52 p.m. and we will see you all
tomorrow morning, closed session at 8.30 and public session starting between 8.45 and 9 o'clock.
I want to thank staff for all the support, all the work to help us get to this point.
So thank you all very much and I will see you in the morning.